THANK YOU MISTER A CHAIRMAN AND
MR UMBERG.
THANK YOU -- HAD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
PRESENTED BY BOTH THE GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE IN THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU. FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH MY OFFICE TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB FIFTEEN WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH -- THE LOCAL
STATE SUSTAINABLE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM OVER LYLE
LOCAL AGENCIES REDUCE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE -- OBVIOUSLY -- WE
ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
REDEVELOPMENT IN THE DISTANCE
WHEN I WAS DISSOLVED I'VE GOT
THE BATTLE SCARS TO SHOW. FOR
STANDING UP FOR CITIES BACK THEN
AND OBVIOUSLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION AND
CERTAINLY WORKING WITH MR BELL
AND MR MCGUIRE IS THERE BILLS
PROGRESS.
I WOULD LOVE THIS TO MOVE HIM
APPROACH AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALSO WE'RE AN **** IF YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND AND
I JUST WANNA INFORM EVERYBODY
UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM THIS IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SPLIT ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I KEPT IT SHORT.
WHAT IS YOUR REMEMBERS JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT WE
WERE MUCH IN SUPPORT?
OF THIS MEASURE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION AND AS
THE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
MALLORY SMOKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM AND WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND WILL RESPECTFULLY BE HAPPY.
TO BUT VOTE ON THAT BILL.
OKAY JULY TWENTY OVER THE NEXT.
ONE YES.
SB [inaudible]
FIVE SIXTY TWO MY I SEE MR
CHAIRS HERE. FIVE THIRTY TO FIVE
THIRTY TWO I'M SORRY.
MY CLASSES HAVE THIS MUCH
.
THE READING RESEARCHER YOU CAN
RECEIVE MISTER TWENTY THANK YOU --
SB -- FIVE THIRTY TWO MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT --
PRESENTED BY THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND HOUSING COMMITTEES
AS WELL AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER CONTINUED WORK WITH MY
OFFICE AS I SAID -- THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE CITY OF
GLENDALE TO USE THE REMAINING
BOND PROCEEDS FROM THEIR TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SOME MORNING
TAXABLE TAX ALLOCATION BOND. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF INCREASING
IMPROVING AND PRESERVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN BUDGET CAT BUDGET.
ACT.
APPROVAL WAS GRANTED DISSOLVING
THE STATE'S FOUR HUNDRED
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES THESE ARE
AGENCIES SERVED A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT -- THROUGH
REDEVELOPMENT AND CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
PROVIDING NEARLY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE CLOSURE OF REDEVELOPMENT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE REMOVAL OF
FINANCING FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
I KNOW THE CHAIR IS PROBABLY THE
MOST.
PASSIONATE PERSON IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- TOOK A HIT WHEN
REDEVELOPMENT -- WAS DISSOLVED
GLENDALE WAS LEFT WITH TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF NON
HOUSING DOLLARS FROM THE CENTRAL
GLENDALE REDEVELOPMENT PROJECT --
IT IS THEIR DESIRE TO USE THAT
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
AND LEVERAGE IT AND I'M TOLD
THERE MAY BE AS MANY AS FOUR
HUNDRED UNITS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IF THIS BILL GETS SIGNED INTO
LAW -- SO THEY WANT TO USE 1100%
OF THAT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I THIS THINK THEY NEED TO BE
COMMENDED FOR THAT DESIRE.
BUT WE NEED THIS BILL TO
AUTHORIZE THEM TO DO THAT IN
WHAT THEY'VE TOLD ME IS THEY'RE
GOING TO USE IT TO ACQUIRE SOME
PROPERTY AND THEN LEVERAGES THE
FINANCING. TO I THINK CREATE A
POT OF UP TO A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. TO SPEND ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO -- I HAVE CARE ROSS
HERE FROM THE CITY OF GLENDALE
ALSO AT HER VOICE AND WE SPEC
FOR YES FROM MY BUT WHEN YOU
HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CARE RUSSELL WE HAVE THE
CITY OF GLENDALE THE CITY TAKES
ITS COMMITMENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SERIOUSLY WE BELIEVE IT
IS OUR OBLIGATION RESPONSIBILITY
AND OUR DUTY TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHENEVER AND
WHEREVER WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO SO.
IN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
GLENDALE IS CREATE A CLOSE TO
SEVEN HUNDRED OF OUR NEARLY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED NEW CONSTRUCTION
AFFORDABLE UNITS FOR LOWER
INCOME SENIORS FAMILIES AND
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATIONS.
SUCH AS VETERANS AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THE CITY ALSO
HAS IMPROVED HOUSING ELEMENT.
THE CITY IN GLENDALE HOUSING
AUTHORITY HAVE ADOPTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STRATEGY THAT
IDENTIFIES THE FUNDS TOOLS
POLICIES NEEDED TO INCREASE THE
SUPPLY OF ALL TYPES OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS STRATEGY IS ALLOWING
GLENDALE TO MOST EFFECTIVELY
FOCUS ITS RESOURCES TO MEET ITS
HOUSING NEED.
THE STRATEGY IS BUILT CONSENSUS
DEFINED NEEDS AND AS IDENTIFIED
RESOURCES FOR FUNDING AND SB
FIVE THIRTY TWO IS ONE OF THE
KEY ELEMENTS.
BUT THE TASK THAT GLENDALE IS
CURED AND STAFF TO DO WITH OUR
GLENDALE HOUSING AUTHORITY AND
WITH OUR DEDICATED STAFF WITH
IDENTIFIED LOCATIONS WITHIN THE
CITY WHERE PORTABLE HOUSING CAN
BE DEVELOPED.
THERE ARE IDEALLY LOCATIONS THAT
ARE NEAR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SCHOOLS AND YOUR GOODS AND
SERVICES.
THE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION THAT
WAS REQUESTED TO BE BE PURPOSE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING CAN BE
LEVERAGED WITH ANOTHER
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY MILLION IN
FINANCING THROUGH PARTNERSHIPS
AND OUR WITH OUR DEVELOPMENT
TEAMS.
THE COUNTY THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT IS A
CRISIS THE GLENDALE HAS NOT
ESCAPED AND WE DEFINITELY WANT
TO SERVE OUR RESIDENTS AND THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS IN NEED.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW GLENDALE TO
USE TO THE USE THAT DEDICATED
FUNDING TO DEVELOP NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
IMMEDIATELY BEGIN ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS IN OUR COMMUNITY AND IN
THE REGION AS A WHOLE.
THE FUNDING OF THIS BILL ALONG
WITH THE LEVERAGE FUNDING FROM
OTHER SOURCES CAN HELP US
DEVELOP UP TO FOUR HUNDRED NEW
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE SINCERELY THANK THE AUTHORS
EFFORTS ON THIS ISSUE WHEN WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR SB FIVE THIRTY TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MALLORY SMOKER CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
THREE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEN ON WE WILL BRING IT
BACK OUT TO THE COMMITTEE --
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE BILL.
OKAY AND YOU DID ACCEPTED
MEMBERS CART YES SIR THANK YOU --
DO WE HAVE A MOTION I SHOULD
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I PRESENTS CLEANER PRESENT
MORROW.
HERE MORRELL PRESENT BATES HERE
BATES PRESENT CABRERO.
BROWSER.
BROTHER PRESENT MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT ROUGH SKINNER.
AMBERG.
NUMBER PRESENT WILL CASKEY.
DOES HE PRESENT.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM -- SO
HONEST VIEW OF FIVE THIRTY TWO
DO I HAVE A MOTION -- THE MOTION
WOULD BE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
NUMBER.
WITHOUT THE CLOSE YES I WOULD I
REALLY DO WANT TO COMPLEMENT THE
CITY OF GLENDALE -- THEY HAVE
HAD A LONG STANDING COMMITMENT
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- FROM A
LARGE DEVELOPMENT PERSPECTIVE
ALSO RIGHT DOWN TO HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY OF ALL THE CITIES IN
THE SAYING YOUR VALLEY.
THEY GO FROM ONE HABITAT PROJECT
TO THE NEXT AND TO HAVE LOCAL
RESOURCES STATE LOCAL.
AND BE DEDICATED A 100% TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- YOU KNOW I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL --
JUST ON THE PRESIDENT OF IT AND
ALSO IN ITS ITS FINAL IMPACTS SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
PERFECT -- SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE THREE
TWO BY SENATOR PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES AYE.
DORADO.
DORADO FIVE MCGUIRE.
MARLA.
LOOK NO ROUGH SKINNER.
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER I WHO CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
OKAY.
OKAY THE VOTERS FIVE TO TWO WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN AND WHEN WE GO
BACK AND BUT TO ADDRESS.
WHEN WE VOTE ON US OPEN THE ROLE
IN THE SPEED FIFTEEN ARE BECAUSE
WE HAVE A QUORUM BEFORE?
CLASSES THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE
SB -- FIFTEEN COULD I HAVE A
MOTION WHICH IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MOTION BY SENATOR WHY KELSEY --
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS ISN'T A BILL FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
NO BATES.
BATES SNOW COVER -- DRUGS SO.
DRUGS SO I MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK MORE LIKE NO ROUGH
SKINNER.
UMBERG FIVE UNDER I AM CASKEY.
GUSTY AYE [inaudible]
YES.
OKAY THE VOTERS FORTY THREE
REALLY THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO.
OKAY I SEE THAT SENATOR
JACKSON'S HERE SO WE WILL CALL
ITEM.
SENATE JACKSON HAS TO ITEM OR
THREE ITEMS ALTHOUGH ONE OF THEM
THE SONG.
RIGHT.
YES ONCE AGAIN SINCE THE TWO
ITEMS TO PREVENT PRESENTS WILL
START WITH.
ITEM THREE SB ONE IS.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF ME START OFF BY
INDICATING THAT WE'VE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE.
PRESENTED IN -- GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE -- BY SENATOR MCGUIRE ON
MY BEHALF LAST WEEK AND I
APPRECIATE HIS WILLINGNESS TO
PENSION FOR ME IN THAT.
SO WE WILL ACCEPT THOSE AS
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS -- I BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS ANOTHER AMENDMENT
THAT.
WE WILL BE TAKING -- TODAY THAT
REDUCES -- TO INTENT LANGUAGE.
A COUPLE OF PROPOSALS SO THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THE PRIMARY ISSUE OF
THIS BILL WHICH IS TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
DAMAGE.
WORLD NOT IN -- ANYWAY USING
THAT AS A WAY TO UNDERMINE OUR
RENO.
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOUSING SO I
WILL ACCEPT THAT AMENDMENT AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT.
AGAIN THE THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS IS NOT TO GAIN RAIN
EXEMPTIONS THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO PROTECT AGAINST
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES SO.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE.
THAT EFFORT TO DO SENATORS AND
JUST TO BE CLEAR THERE SO THERE.
THEY'RE COMING FINANCE
AMENDMENTS.
ATTENTION THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
I MEAN THIS IS AND THEN FROM
FROM THIS COMMITTEE WERE TO
AMENDMENTS THE ONE YOU JUST.
MENTIONED ARE REDUCING TO ATTEND
LANGUAGE SO WE CAN KEEP WORKING --
AND AND IT WAS THE OTHER ONE
THAT LANGUAGE CLARIFYING.
THAT IF THE LOCALITY MIX
FINDINGS THAT PREVENTED THAT
PREVENTS IT FROM APPROVING A
BUILDING PERMIT AND A VIOLENT
URBAN INTERFACE ABOUT WILL NOT
NEGATE ITS RETALIATION.
I'M SORRY WOULD YOU.
YES IS IT LISTED IN THE HOUSE.
SO THAT ISN'T THAT SWEET WE HAD
A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
WE TRUST CAME UP WITH JUST A
SHORT TIME AGO.
WITHIN TEN LANGUAGE WITH THE
INTENT WHEN DOES NOT I'D
ARTICULATED THAT YOU WANT TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT IF I MAY -- I
APOLOGIZE I SHOULD HAVE IT.
TRY TO THESE FOR THE ONES THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT AND I AND THAT --
WE WOULD BE TAKING -- Z.
PROVISIONAL WE'RE NOT GOING TO
NEGATE RENO THIS ARENA
OBLIGATION.
AND THEN THIS IS KNOWN OF LOS
SIX USERS SHOULD HAVE BEEN NO
NET LOSS ONE CORRECT THAT WHEN
WE'RE GOING.
TO RETAIN SO.
TO THAT'S GOING TO KNOWING THAT
LOSS IS GOING INTO THE BILL YES
WHICH WAS WHAT YOU OKAY WHICH IS
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT IN AGREED.
TO THE OTHER ONE IS THE ONE THAT
WE'RE STILL GOING TO WIN THAT WE
NEED TO WORK ON WHICH DEALS WITH
THE INTENT -- OF LOWERING THE
RENO NUMBER.
AND THAT WE CLEARLY ARE NOT
ATTEMPTING TO DO THAT IN THIS
BILL AND THAT WILL CONTINUE
WORKING ON LANGUAGE IT SATISFIES.
AND CLARIFIES. TWO TO EVERYONE'S.
OF THE COMFORT LEVEL THAT WE ARE.
GOING TO CREATE THAT BALANCE WE
NEED AND SO.
I BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE IT WAS
PROPOSES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
FINDS AND DECLARES NEED TO
RECONCILE.
THE CONFLICTING GOALS OF
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF STATES
RESIDENTS THAT WILL FACE
WILDFIRE RISK.
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
ADDRESSING DECADES OF LOW
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION RATES.
AND THE COLORS THE INTENT TO
DETERMINE A METHOD OF ADDRESSING
THESE TWO GOALS.
IN THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION PROCESS THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING -- SO STOP.
SENATE THE AUTHOR.
AND THE COMMITTEE WE'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS BUT WE NEED MORE
TIME -- TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING BOTH THIS CRITICAL
NEEDS -- AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR WORKING WITH US AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TO CLARIFY AND
COME UP WITH LANGUAGE IN THE
COMING WEEKS THANK YOU.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
TWO THIS IS A BILL THAT REDUCES
THE RISK OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE DAMAGE IN CALIFORNIA --
TO OUR COMMUNITIES BY
STRENGTHENING LOCAL PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS FOR PERMITTING
DEVELOPMENT IN VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS.
BY DIRECTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE
RETROFIT STRATEGIES FOR
STRUCTURES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IN THE NEED.
OF WHAT WE REFER TO AS FIRE
HARDENING.
ANOTHER WAY OF SAYING WE NEED TO
PROTECT TO THE EXTENT WE CANDLES
INFRASTRUCTURES BY DOING THINGS
THAT WE KNOW.
WE'LL CREATE GREATER PROTECTIONS --
IN THE CASE OF FIRE -- END OF I
AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE IN ENSURING THAT WE
CAN ADDRESS THAT ISSUE -- WALLS --
ALSO RECOGNIZING THE NEEDS OF
FURTHER -- HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IN OUR STATE.
MEMBERS OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
OUR STATE HAS EXPERIENCE WITHOUT
DOUBT THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE SEASONS IN
ITS HISTORY.
COMBINATION OF YEARS OF DROUGHT
FUELS ACCUMULATION AND CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DO SEVERE WEATHER.
HAVE RESULTED IN WILDFIRES FIRES
OF UNPRECEDENTED SIZE AND
INTENSITY THAT HAVE KILLED WELL
OVER A HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND
BURNED WELL OVER A MILLION ACRES.
CALIFORNIA'S PERSISTENT THREAT
OF WILDFIRE POSES A SIGNIFICANT
RISK TO HOMES AND BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WELL MUCH IS BEING DONE TO
BETTER MANAGE OUR FORESTS.
MORE MUST BE DONE TO HARDEN OUR
EXISTING HOMES TO MAKE THEM MORE
RESISTANT TO WILDFIRE.
AND IMPROVE LAND USE DECISIONS
TO MINIMIZE THIS THREAT.
PARTICULARLY TO NEW COMMUNITIES
INCREASINGLY BEING BUILT IN
WILDLAND AREAS OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS MOVIES WILDLIFE URBAN
INTERFACE.
AND MUCH OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN PARTICULAR IS BUILT IN THESE
AREAS WHICH ARE PRONE.
TO WILD FIRES AND OTHER
DISASTERS.
AT A MARCH THIRTEENTH HEARING
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE
PRONE REGIONS THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND NATURAL RESOURCE
COMMITTEE.
RECOMMENDED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER ACTION TO BOLSTER LOCAL
PLANNING EFFORTS TO DESIGN MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
CONDITION DEVELOPMENT APPROVED
APPROVALS TO ENSURE THAT
STRUCTURES AND COMMUNITIES ARE
ADEQUATELY PROTECTED FROM FIRE.
OR ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT OUT OF
HARM'S WAY.
THIS BILL.
THE GOAL AND ITS AIM IS TO DO
EXACTLY THAT.
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES STRATEGIC
LOCAL PLANNING FOR RETROFITTING
EXISTING AT RESTRUCTURES.
MODIFIES LOCAL PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS TO REDUCE FIRE RISK
THROUGH BETTER PLANNING AND
COMMUNITY DESIGN.
AND GIVES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FLEXIBILITY WHEN MEETING
REGIONAL GOALS FOR NEW HOUSING.
AMONG OTHER THINGS IT CONDITIONS
NEW CONSTRUCTION AND IDENTIFIED
WHAT WE AREAS UPON CITIES AND
COUNTIES MEETING.
SPECIFIED WILDLIFE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS.
IT REQUIRES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO VERIFY ONGOING COMPLIANCE
WITH DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND LOCAL
FIRE PLAN AND WHILE FIRE HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS INCLUDING
DOCUMENTING COMPLIANCE FOR EACH
IMPACTED PROPERTY.
AT LEAST EVERY THREE YEARS AND
IT TO REX COUNTIES IN TANDEM
WITH UPDATING THEIR GENERAL PLAN
SAFETY ELEMENT. TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE RETROFIT STRATEGY.
FOR ST STRUCTURES THAT ARE
VULNERABLE TO WILDFIRE.
INCLUDING PROCESSING.
UP OR PROCESSES FOR IDENTIFYING
IMPACTED INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS
AND MILESTONES FOR COMPLETING
RETROFIT WORK AND IDENTIFYING
POTENTIAL POTENTIAL FUNDING AND
FINANCING STRATEGIES.
NOW WHILE THIS IS NOT EXACTLY
THE SEXY STUFF IN THE WORLD IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IF WE
ARE GOING TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
NEXT SET OF WILDFIRES.
THAT RUN THROUGH OUR STATE
CAUSING PROPERTY DAMAGE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE LOSS OF LIFE.
REQUIRINGALL DEVELOPMENT IN WE
WE AREAS TO MEET SPECIFIED FIRE
RESPONSE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND IGNITION RISK REDUCTION BUT
SCALING THOSE REQUIREMENTS BY
THE NUMBER OF UNITS BUILT FOR
DEVELOPMENT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU STORIES ABOUT
HOW IN THE RECENT FIRES THERE
WAS INADEQUATE WATER INADEQUATE
ELECTRICITY INADEQUATE ALL SORTS
OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
HAVE HELPED.
DEAL WITH THESE FIRES AND THE
LOSS OF LIFE WE ARE NOW TRYING
TO BE AS PROACTIVE IN THIS
PREEMPTIVE FOR THE NEXT SET OF
THE VANCE SO THAT WE CAN AVOID --
THOSE TRAGEDIES.
THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO UNDERTAKE A
NOTICE AND COMMENT RULEMAKING TO
ESTABLISH NEW WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS.
THAT ACCOUNT.
MORE PRECISELY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE OR WHETHER A TOP
BIOGRAPHY AND OUR DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS.
MEMBERS WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
CREATING THE POTENTIAL FOR
LONGER AND MORE SEVERE WILDFIRES
IN OUR STATE IT IS IMPORTANT WE
ACT NOW TO STRENGTHEN OUR LOCAL
PLANNING.
AND REDUCE THE RISK TO OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS COMMUNITIES AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS.
TRACY RYAN FROM THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND PAUL MASON.
FROM PACIFIC FIVE FOUR STRUCTURE
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE AND TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR -- WHOSE
FIRST GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY
REINER OKAY REPRESENTS A
CALIFORNIA -- AND I WANNA THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THAT CHAIR STAFF
FOR WORKING.
WITH US IN TRYING TO GET THIS
BILL TO A PLACE THAT -- WE THINK
THAT WILL HELP.
THE WILD FIRE RISK IN --
BUILDING IN THOSE AREAS -- LAST
YEAR WE WORKED A LOT ON WILD
FIRE RISK AND IT REALLY FOCUSED
MOSTLY ON VEGETATION VEGETATION
FUEL MANAGEMENT -- THIS YEAR AND
THIS BILL IN SB ONE EIGHTY TWO
REALLY FOCUSES ON CREATING MORE
FIRE SAFE COMMUNITIES AND
CREATING MECHANISM TO ENFORCE --
COMMUNITY AN INDIVIDUAL HOME
FIRE SAFETY.
SB TWENTY TWO SETS FOR SPECIFIC
WILDFIRE REDUCTION -- STANDARDS
AND THOSE INCLUDE.
CREATING SAFE AREAS AND
COMMUNITIES FOR EVACUATION AND
ALSO CREATING OPEN SPACE -- IN
THOSE AREAS THAT DO NOT PERMIT
PROMOTE THE SPREAD OF WILD FIRE.
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO ALSO CREATES A
STRUCTURE -- FOR INSURING
COMMUNITY AND HOMEOWNER
COMPLIANCE WITH DEFENSIBLE SPACE --
THROUGH TWO DIFFERENT -- PRONGS
ONE IS AN ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO ENSURE THE
DEFENSE WILL SPACES ACTUALLY
BEING KEPT UP -- AND THAT IS
THAT EVERY THREE YEARS AS THE
SENATOR I REFERENCED.
THE OTHER THING THAT IT TO THE
OTHER PRONG WOULD BE -- AN H. O.
EIGHT TYPE OF ASSESSMENT ON
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT THAT
DEFENSE WILL SPACE IS MAINTAINED
AND CREATES A KIND OF A A
FINANCIAL STREAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT CONTINUES ON A
COMMUNITY WIDE BASIS.
THIS IS STRUCTURE CREATES A AWAY
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO LOOK AT
BUILDING IN THE WILD WILD FIRE
I'M SORRY WELL THEN URBAN
INTERFACE AREAS BY PROVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM APPROVING
PERMITS FOR DEVELOPMENTS UNLESSTHE PROJECT MEETS.
ALL OF THE COMPLIANCE WITH ALL
THE WILD FIRE RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS OUTLINED IN THE BILL --
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT CREATES --
BALANCE AND IT IS THERE'S A
BALANCED LOOK AT THE WAY THESE
DEVELOPMENTS WORK BY HAVING A
TIERED STRUCTURE AS THAT SENATOR
REFERENCE.
NOT ALSO ALL DEVELOPMENTS ARE
TREATED EQUALLY AND THE FIRE
REDUCTION STANDARDS -- DIFFER
FROM EACH TEAR IF YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED PLUS DEVELOPMENT THE
FIRE REDUCTION STANDARDS ARE
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAN IF
YOU HAVE LESS THAN.
NINE IN THAT DEVELOPMENT.
THE OTHER THING THAT SB ONE A TO
ATTEMPT TO DO IS ON SILO THE
CONVERSATION OF HOUSING NEEDS A
AND WILD FIRE RISK IN OUR
COMMUNITIES -- ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BILL SAYS THAT
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT THE
HOUSING ADDS THAT HOUSING HE
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT -- AND
THE COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS NEED TO
LOOK AT WHEN I'M DOING RIGHT NOW
ALLOCATION IS.
IS THE FACTOR OF OF WILDFIRE
RISK IN THAT AREA.
NOW I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR DID --
TAKING -- THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD
REQUESTED IS REMOVING THE
PROVISION THAT ACTUALLY LOWERS
THE ALLOCATION OF REINA AND SO
WHAT THIS SAYS WHAT THE BILL
STILL CONTAINS IS JUST THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT AS A
FACTOR.
AND IN LOOKING AT THE
METHODOLOGY FOR ALLOCATION.
WE BELIEVE BECAUSE OF THOSE
STATING LOSS OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY -- BUT HAS HAPPENED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE FIRE
SEASONS -- THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT THE HOUSING NEEDS NOT
IN THAT SILO LIKE I SAID BUT
ALSO -- WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WILDFIRE IN THE HOUSING NEEDS
TOGETHER AND HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
RE NOT BEING USED AS AS A WAY TO
TIE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING GOING
INTO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND WE JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SORRY WE HAVE TWO MORE
WITNESSES.
ONE I'M SORRY ARE THERE WHY LEAN
FROM OUR C. R. C.'S HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
ANY.
IT'S A TWO WITH TWO MINUTES IS
OF A GREAT.
HOMEMADE SOUPS OF THE FOREST
TRUST MY CAN BE VERY BRIEF
BECAUSE I WANT TO COMPLEX BILL.
THE FUNDAMENTALS ARE REALLY
PRETTY STRAIGHT FORWARD WE NEED
TO BE SMARTER ABOUT BUILDING
THESE REALLY HIGH RISK AREAS YOU
KNOW AS WE'RE IF WE'RE GOING TO
BUILD INTO AREAS WITH HIGH FIRE
RISK.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT THE PROCESS
IS FOR ESTABLISHING SOME
CONSISTENT MEDICATIONS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
MANAGING THOSE RISKS IN A
CONSISTENT WAY ACROSS THE STATE.
WE STRAIGHTFORWARD OF RACISM
INTERESTING CHALLENGES AROUND
THE RING THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF TIME ON YOU
MAY ASK WHY PACIFIC FOREST TRUST
WHICH MOSTLY WORKS ON FIRE NOT
TO RESOURCE FOR TWO ISSUES.
IS HERE BECAUSE THE FLIP SIDE OF
THE HOUSING CHALLENGE HERE IS
THAT WE KEEP BUILDING HOMES OUT
INTO WILDLAND AREAS MAKES ALL OF
OUR OTHER CHALLENGES WITH
DEALING WITH FIRE WITH.
FOREST MANAGEMENT WITH
PRESCRIBED FIRE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO NEED TO BE
ADDRESSING THIS FROM BOTH
DIRECTIONS SO OVER SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IN OUR DRIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SORRY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND THAT YOU SUPPORT.
A LITTLE BIT OF A TWEENER TO BE
HONEST.
OKAY -- YOU KNOW YOU CAN YOU CAN
DO IT NOW OKAY AS ELEVEN SALAS
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
FIRST OFF WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR JACKSON FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON
THE BILL.
BUT WE DO AGREE WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA -- WE
NEED.
TO SORRY WE NEED TO RETHINK THAT
LAND USE POLICIES I HAVE PUT
PEOPLE IN HARM'S WAY AND THAT
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION OWEVER WE DO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY USING TEACHER OFF
THE HEALTHY FOREST FUNDS
EXCLUSIVELY FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS WE THINK THAT WE
NEED TO FIND BOTH COMMUNITY
PROTECTION.
AND OF COURSE RESTORATION BUT WE
THINK HER FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL OR ANY
SUPPORTS.
MYSTERON.
MR MEMBERS JUST RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES THAT WERE BETWEEN -- AS
WELL -- BUT I DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
RAIN AND WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR
IS CLARITY WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT
THE STATE POLICY IS GOING TO BE --
BECAUSE WHEN WE GET OUR ARENA
NUMBER THAT IS THEN IT DEMAND
UPON OUR CITIES THE PLAN IN ZONE
FOR THAT NUMBER OF HOUSING.
AND IF WE'RE GOING TO CONSTRAIN
WHERE WE CAN OR CAN'T OR MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR US TO
IDENTIFY SITES -- WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE THE NUMBER
THAT THE STATE IS GIVING US --
SO WE CERTAINLY WANT TO WORK
WITH THE CHAIRMAN WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR I'M TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
DO THAT SO THAT OUR CITIES
UNDERSTAND WHAT EXACTLY IS BEING
DEMANDED BECAUSE ONCE WE ZONE IN
PLAN.
THE HOUSE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
APPLIES AND REQUIRES IS BY LAW
TO APPROVE THIS PROJECT SO WE
LOOK FOR THE CONVERSATION LIKE
TO CONTINUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
IS CRAIG THOMAS WITH THE FIRE
RESTORATION GROUP WERE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF SENATOR JACKSON'S
EFFORTS TO IMPROVE LAND USE
PLANNING AND FIRE HAZARDS OWNS
AND WE WANT TO SEE THE BILL.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THE FUNDING
COMES HOMES WE HAVE THE ONE
CONCERN THAT SPENCER THE TNC TO
IS A GT ARAFAT'S BUT OTHERWISE
IT'S EXCELLENT EFFORT TO IMPROVE
SAFETY AND HOUSING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY THREE NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WHAT INTERESTING CASES IN
QUESTION?
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NAY CAMERA
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THIS BILL IS A HOUSING KILLER.
I THINK THE REASONS FOR THAT ARE --
MULTIPLE I THINK FIRST OF ALL WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE DATA THAT WE
HAVE.
ON WHAT IS REQUIRED UNDER
EXISTING LAW AND HELP THOSE
HOMES AND SUBDIVISIONS SOME
PROJECTS ARE PERFORMING.
UNDER THAT EXISTING REGULATORY
REGIME WE HAVE FOUND THROUGH OUR
OWN ANALYSIS BUT ALSO.
ALSO THROUGH -- WHAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED IN THE PRESS AND OTHER
MEDIA.
THAT NEW HOMES ARE THE ONES THAT
HAVE THE HIGHEST RESISTANCE TO
WILDFIRES THEY ARE IN FACT DOING
THEIR JOB.
AND IT'S THE EXISTING POPULATION
HAS THE BIGGEST RISKS OF
WILDFIRE -- WE SAW THAT BOTH IN
THE THOMAS FIRE AND HOW THAT
AFFECTED HOMES IN.
THE CITY OF VENTURA HOW THAT
AFFECTED THE SANTA ROSA AREA
COFFEE PARK THESE ARE IN FILL
AREAS THESE ARE NOT JUST WHERE
YOU THINK OF WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WE WE FOR MORE PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THIS
BILL AND SAY.
WE'RE TO SUPPLY AND WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO IN THOSE AREAS SO -- IF WE
CAN'T GET OUR HANDS AROUND THAT
AND THEN IT'S REALLY FOR US THE
RISK OF PLAYING GOTCHA WITH
APPROVALS.
AND FOR US THE HIGHEST FIRE RISK
AREAS OF THOSE VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY SOUNDS WE'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT THAT'S MAPPED
THAT SET BY STATE AGENCIES WE
KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH IT IT'S
UPDATED REGULARLY AND SO WE KNOW.
WHERE THOSE AREAS ARE BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT THERE ARE OTHER
AREAS ADDITIONAL AREAS THAT ARE
NOT FOUND IN THOSE HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES?
ADDED TO THAT YOU CAN SEE THIS
IN THE DEFINITIONS THERE IN THE
BILL.
THIS IS ANY AREA WHERE STRUCTURE
INTERMINGLED WITH BUDGET.
THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS THAT
MEANS THAT IN ANY AREA WHERE
THERE ARE TREES THERE BUSH'S
THERE'S GRASS WITH THE YOU HAVE.
PARKS OR YOU HAVE AN URBAN
INFILL AREAS IN AREAS LIKE
SACRAMENTO AND IN ALL OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE THESE AREAS.
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD HIGH
DENSITY MULTI FAMILY HOUSING?
NOW WE HAVE A NEW -- OBSTACLE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH A NEW REASON FOR
US TO HAVE OUR PROJECTS DENIED I
THINK THAT THE BILL AS IT EXISTS
IS OVERBROAD.
I THINK THAT.
YOU HAVE TO APPROACH THIS ISSUE
LIKE YOU DO EVERY OTHER ISSUE
WHICH IS THERE'S NO PERFECT
PLACE TO BUILDING CALIFORNIA FOR
SOME.
IT'S WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE --
DISPLACEMENT WE DON'T WANT HAVE
GENTRIFICATION WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE SEISMIC CARESS WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE.
THE SEA LEVEL RISE OR WETLANDS
OR AG LAND PRESERVATION OR
FLOODS OR TOXICS FOR YOU NAME IT
WHATEVER THE THE THE PARTICULAR
INTEREST IS.
THAT'S THE REASON FOR OBJECTING
TO HOUSING IN EVERY PLACE THE
ENTIRE STATE IS COVERED WITH.
HAVING IN PERFECT PLACES TO
BUILD AND SO DON'T MAKE THE
PERFECT THE ENEMY OF THE GOOD.
THAT'S HOW WE GOT INTO THIS MESS
IN TERMS OF A HOUSING CRISIS WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A
PATHWAY FOR HOUSING.
SO MUCH FOR THE PLACES WHERE IT
MIGHT APPLY.
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IN THOSE
AREAS I CAN TELL YOU AS A LAND
USE AN ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYER FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS I CAN'T TELL?
WE'VE SINCE THAT SINCE I
COULDN'T TELL I IN BUT WE WENT
OUT AND TALKED TO EXPERTS.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO TELL US WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO WE
NEED TO KNOW FROM A PLANNING A
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
PERSPECTIVE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO DO IN THOSE AREAS. ONE
OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT WAS TAKEN
IN SENATE GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE
PROVIDED SOME.
THE SIDE BOARDS TO WHAT MIGHT BE
IMPOSED ARE PROJECTS.
IT WILL ONLY APPLY ONLY APPLIES
TO THE SMALL DEVELOPMENTS NINE
HOMES ARE FEWER.
HERE'S WHAT IT IS.
THEY HAVE TO BE REASONABLE.
FEASIBLE AND THE CHIEF OF ALL.
IF THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR NINE
HOMES IT SHOULD BE GOOD ENOUGH
FOR ANY PROJECT WE SET LIMITS ON
HOW WE DEAL WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
WE DEVELOP A SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES THEY HAVE
TO BE ACHIEVABLE.
NOW WE'RE SAYING EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT ACHIEVABLE EVEN IF THEY'RE
NOT FEASIBLE EVEN IF THEY'RE NOT
REASONABLE.
WE SHOULD BE ALLOWED OPPOSE
THOSE ON NEW HOUSING PROJECTS.
WE HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS.
IF YOU WANT TO PLAY GOTCHA THEN
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO.
SO WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR AT THIS POINT IS. TO MAKE
PROVIDES SOME LIMITATIONS ON
THOSE.
THOSE REQUIREMENTS THAT WILL BE
IMPOSED ON US EVEN THOUGH WE
CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY ARE.
JUST SOME LIMITATION TO PROVIDE
THAT BALANCE THAT WE NEED.
OTHERWISE IT'S JUST A NO HOUSING
BILL.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SIGNAL BRING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
LIKE HEALTHY.
ON THE HARDENING OF THE EXISTING
STRUCTURES AND THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS NORMALLY THEY
ASSESS IF THEY'RE IN THE IF
THEY'RE IN THE HIGH -- FIREFIGHT --
AREA I I PREDICT PRISON THIRST
WAS TO MEET NEW EXCEED BILL A
CLASS B. STANDARDS TO HARDEN
THEIR ASSETS SOME WONDERING IS
THAT A HOMEOWNER.
PAYMENT THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
THAT THE TO IMPROVE DEBTORS AT
HERE IS A ANTICIPATION THAT IT'S
PART OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS
FOR FUNDING THIS I DON'T KNOW AT
THIS POINT IF WE'VE TOTALLY
IDENTIFIED THE SOURCES OF
FUNDING.
THAT WILL BE USED FOR THIS --
BUT WHAT WERE TRUE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I WAS LISTENING.
TO BUILDING INDUSTRIES HOUSING
KILLER TO NEW PHRASE TO ME I
KNOW THE CHAMBER LIKE JOB KILLER.
NUMBER CLINCH BUT I'M REALLY NOT
SURE EVEN UNDERSTOOD WHAT HE WAS.
COMPLAINING ABOUT HER BUT BUT I
THINK WHAT WE HAVE IS A
SITUATION WHERE WE ARE TRYING.
TO IDENTIFY THOSE RISK AREAS.
AND BY THE WAY SACRAMENTO UNDER
NO CIRCUMSTANCES EVEN ONE'S
WILDEST IMAGINATION WITH ANYONE
CALL IT A WEEK.
WHO IS IN LAGUNA MIGUEL OR WHERE
THE MOUNTAINS COME DOWN TO THE
HILLS THE COME DOWN? TO TO THE
YEAR IT TO THE BEACH AREAS SO
SINCE THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PRIMARILY OF THE BERKELEY HILLS.
SACRAMENTO LAST I LOOKED AT HIM
FONG TOO MANY HILLS THERE'S NO
MOVIE HERE SO THOSE.
ARGUMENTS JUST REALLY.
DON'T HOLD WATER -- WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS IDENTIFY THOSE
AREAS WHICH ARE AT HIGH RISK AND
MAKE SURE THAT IN THOSE AREAS WE
HARDEN THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES?
WILL MAKE IT CLEAR WHAT IT IS
SAID TO EXPECTED WHAT IS
REQUIRED GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOW SEEING THESE FIRES
HAPPENING IN DECEMBER.
BURNING AT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
DEGREES THINGS THAT WE NEVER HAD
TO DEAL WITH BEFORE AND SO AS WE
BUILD WHETHER IT'S NEW HOUSING
WELL WE TRY TO HARDEN EXISTING
HOUSING.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS BRING
TOGETHER?
THE PLANNING -- AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
REQUIRING THAT THEY ASSESS THIS
ISSUE AND CREATE THE STANDARDS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO REQUIRE.
THOSE WHO LIVE IN THOSE AREAS.
TO TO DEVELOP IN ORDER TO DEAL.
WITH THE REALITIES OF THE ALL OF
THE POTENTIAL FIRE SO AS FAR AS
THE FUNDING MECHANISM GOES WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T QUITE BEEN
ABLE.
TO WORK THAT OUT I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR IS PUT MONEY IN THE
BUDGET FOR ADDRESSING THESE
WILDFIRES AND THIS IS AN AREA.
THAT HAS BEEN LEFT.
BUT THERE'S A VOID IN THIS AREA
PLANNING.
AND WHAT WE ARE DOING INDEED IS
TALKING TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND SAYING HEY FOLKS TO GO TO
STEP UP HERE WE CAN'T TRUST.
YOU KNOW CLEAN OUT OUR FORESTS
WE CAN'T ADJUST TO PRESCRIBE
BURNS WE CAN'T DO THE THINGS
THAT WE IN LEGISLATION WE DID
LAST YEAR THAT'S PART OF THE
ANSWER BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
ADDRESS WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO BE
BUILDING.
AND TAKING THE NECESSARY STEPS
TO HARDEN THAT INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROTECT HMAN LIFE.
AND PROPERTY YEAH I I THINK IF
I'M MISTER CHAIR IS THAT IF I A
WITH WITH REGARD TO THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS THE
ASSOCIATION'S CANNOT STOP YOU
FROM ALTERING YOUR CHANGING YOUR
ROOF IN ORDER TO HARDEN NET.
RIGHT ISN'T THAT A PROVISION OF
THE OF THE AT ALL CORRECT BUT
THERE'S SOME OF THE I GUESS
COMMON AREAS THAT ARE THAT ARE
IN THE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION --
RIGHT IN A CLUB.
ROOM OVER WHATEVER IS EVERYBODY
SHARES ON OUR DOES.
THAT'S MY QUESTION THE SAID ARE
THOSE -- HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
IMPROVEMENTS IN A FIFTY DECIDED
IF THEY MAKE THE STEP THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO IT THAT'S I
DON'T EXPECT AN ANSWER HERE BUT
I I SEE THE GOOD PART IS SAID.
IF YOU HAVE ONE OF THE SEVENTY
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION THAT'S
SHAKE ROOF AND SHAKE CITING YOU
CAN'T MAKE IN SAY THAT'S OUR
RULES YOU GOT A YOU GOT TO HAVE
THAT THAT'S A CRAZY THING.
NOWADAYS SO I ASSUME THAT
CORRECT SET WELL AGE IT'S
DESIGNED TO I MEAN WE'RE TRIP A
LOT OF WHAT PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW
IS WHAT DO I DO TO PROTECT MY
HOME.
IN CASE OF A WILDFIRE IN ANOTHER
ELEMENT BY THE WAY WHICH WILL
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE SIS IS
TRYING TO GET INSURANCE.
WHEN YOU LIVE IN A HIGH FIRE
AREA AND HAS SO I WAS JUST TWO
MONTHS AGO NON RENEWED -- FOR
INSURANCE AND WE HAD TO GO OUT
AND THE COST OF THAT NEW
INSURANCE.
BECOMES.
A CHALLENGE BUT THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TO SAY YOU NEED TO DO
A. B. C. AND D..
IF YOU WANT TO OUR INSURANCE AND
EVEN THEN AGAIN WITHOUT TAKING
THOSE MITIGATION MEASURES GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE THOUSANDS
OF HOMES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST AND
THE ENORMOUS COST. TO EVERYBODY
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY PROBABLY
P. JEANNIE AND OTHERS IS SUCH
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE SOME OF THAT RESPONSIBILITY
SO I'M ASSUMING THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE'LL GET OFF THE YOU KNOW WE'LL
GET ON BOARD AS WELL JUST
BECAUSE THE EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
WITH NOT DOING THAT WORK WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT. ONE WOULD HOPE AND
I MISTER CHAIR ONE FINAL
QUESTION THE STAFF REPORT AT
PAGE FOUR IS TALKING ABOUT THE
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY SOUNDS.
FIRST WHICH I ASSUME ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE HI FIRES
ZONES VERSUS THE JUST THE FIRE
SEVERITY SO AND SO ARE WE IS
THAT.
WHAT TYPE OF UNIVERSES THAT WELL
UNFORTUNATELY -- THEY THE THE
MAPS HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE
I THINK IT'S TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR I AND WE KNOW THAT THOSE
AREAS.
GIVEN THE CHANGING WEATHER
PATTERNS GIVING GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HAD DROUGHT THAT
THOSE NEED TO BE DRAMATICALLY
NEED TO BE UPDATED AND UPGRADED
BECAUSE YES THE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN WHAT'S A CHALLENGE ANYWAY
BETWEEN EARTHQUAKES AND WHAT
HAVE YOU BUT SOME AREAS ARE
CLEARLY MORE PRONE. TO PROBLEMS
IN THE MOVIES ARE THOSE AREAS.
IF YOU JUST LIVE ANYWHERE.
NEAR THE WILDLIFE URBAN
INTERFACE -- YOU ARE YOU ARE
SHOULD MORE SUSCEPTIBLE AS
COMPARED TO THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO WHICH IS.
NOT IN A WEEK.
YOU SEE MY CONCERN IS YES JUST
TO DO A MOVIE VERSUS THE VERY
SAYS.
SUPPORT SUPER HIGH -- AREAS ON
THESE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT I DON'T WANT.
TO WELL PART OF IT PART OF IT IS
WE NEED NO ONE'S BEEN DOING ANY
PLANNING -- AND SO THIS IS GOING
TO GET US TO DO THE PLANNING
FISH ARE BELIEVED BENEFITS
EVERYBODY I EVEN THINK IT
BENEFITS THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S ONE PERSON'S
MEETS ANOTHER PERSON'S POTATO
SEVERAL.
GIVE A UP.
A POTENTIAL NUMBER OF RESIDENTS
THIS WILL -- AFFECT.
AT THIS TIME -- OR POTENTIALLY
HOW MANY -- POTENTIAL BUILDINGS --
PROJECTS WILL AFFECT WILL AREAS
I SHOULD SAY -- WE'RE LOOKING
MORE TO ADD GEOGRAPHY HOW MANY
HOW MANY AREAS ARE THERE IN THE
STATE LIKE AT THAT HAVE LOUISE
BE OUR SQUARE MILES GIVES THEM.
HAVE YOU ARE YOU HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THAT FAR THEN I TAKE A I DON'T
HAVE THAT NUMBER OKAY OKAY
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH.
A YOUNG FIVE ACTUALLY LIVE I
THINK ANY LAWYER SOMETHING CLOSE
TO THAT AND ARE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION IS REQUIRED BY THE
FIRE AT THE READY. TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS WITCHER'S FUEL
MODIFICATION WE HAVE A WHOLE
PLAN ON THE BACK PART OF OUR
HOME AND WE LIVED A. G. SENT TO
THE CANYON.
THAT THANK GOODNESS FOR THE
CANYON OF STOP THE LAGUNA FIRES
FROM LEAPING THE CANYON COMING
OVER SO.
THE IDEAS ARE GOOD AT I JUST
WONDER WHY YOU WOULD BE
RESISTANT TO TAKING THEY
AMENDMENT.
THAT'S BEEN SUGGESTED BY A ON
THE B. I A THAT IS REASONABLE.
FEASIBLE -- FORGET THE OTHER
TURN THE REASON BEING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE VERY GOOD AT
USING THAT DISCRETION TO PROTECT.
THOSE HOMES IN THEIR AREA AND I
I THINK MY HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
AN ORANGE COUNTY IN PARTICULAR.
HAS BEEN VERY DILIGENT IN MATH
BUT TO MAKE IT SO RESTRICTIVE
FOR THE LARGER DEVELOPMENTS I
THINK THE I A HAS A GOOD POINT.
THAT WE START TO TO NARAL -- THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE THERE FOR
BUILDING DURING THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
BEYOND -- DOUBT THAT TROUBLES ME
BECAUSE WE'VE WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
TO DO WHAT.
IS BEING REQUIRED IN THE US.
AND THE NEWER DEVELOPMENTS SEE
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND ALLOWING
THAT SORT OF DISCRETION THAT'S
MENTIONED IN LET ME GET THE
TERMINOLOGY CORRECT IT SAYS.
REASONABLE FEASIBLE AND
ACHIEVABLE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN APPLIED -- FOR
MANY OF THE HOMES THAT WERE
BUILT IN REMEMBER IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE TWO MAJOR
DEVELOPMENTS.
RANCHO MISSION VIEJO AND THEN WE
HAVE -- FORSTER RANCH AND THEN
THERE'S ONE IN ON THE LAKE
FOREST WHERE BY THE WAY THE
FIRES AN ORANGE COUNTY DURING ON
THE MID TWO THOUSANDS CAME OVER.
THOSE CANYONS BUT AGAIN THOSE
HOUSES WERE HARD.
SO YOU HAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE ALREADY DOING IT IN GOING
FORWARD IT WOULD SEEM TO ME YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE.
MORE DISCRETION TO GET THOSE
LARGER DEVELOPMENTS ESPECIALLY
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE ATTACHED --
MULTI FAMILY IS WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR OUR DEATHS SO I I'M
I GUESS MY MY QUESTION IS MORE
OF A STATEMENT SENATOR JACKSON.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND MAYBE
CONSIDER THAT OUT FOR THE LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS BECAUSE I THINK IT
CAN BE ACHIEVED.
OUR I'VE JUST SEEN IT HAPPEN
THEN WE WENT THROUGH SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT.
OUR TIME IS AN ORANGE COUNTY
DURING MY ROLE ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IT WAS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I THINK SOME OF US
SENATOR MORE WALKS ARE COMING
DOWN. TO IRVINE SO I TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT I THINK TODAY I'M GOING --
TO OPPOSE THE BILL JUST TO PUT
MORE PRESSURE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION FOR
LARGER DEVELOPMENT SO WHAT WE
HAVE DONE THE BILL.
RELIES ON CONSENSUS NATIONAL AND
STATE ADVISORY STANDARDS. FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME UNTIL THE OFFICE
OF STATE FIRE MARSHAL.
PROMULGATES APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS WE WANT TO LOOK AT THE
REAL EXPERTS TO DECIDE AND AND
TO CREATE THE STANDARDS.
AND THEY WILL BE CONSENSUS
ADVISORY STANDARDS -- WHICH WILL
RELY.
ON SIGNIFICANT INPUT FROM ISSUE
EXPERTS SO WE WERE DECISION PIE
IN THE SKY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE THE AND AND USE THE BEST
EXPERTS TO TRY -- TO ESTABLISH
THOSE STANDARDS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE INCLUDED IN THIS
I MEAN THIS IS PART OF THEIR
PLAN.
BUT OFTEN WE OF THE STANDARDS
THAT ARE USED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE THE STANDARDS
BUT WE WANT THESE TO BE.
INSTEAD OF A BROAD BASED OF
REASONABLENESS SO WE CERTAINLY
CAN KEEP WORKING ON THAT BUT THE
GOAL IS GET THE EXPERTS IN THERE.
GET THEM TO TELL US WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND A LOCAL
OFFICIALS WHO WILL HOPEFULLY.
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF USING THE
STANDARD SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPED BY THE EXPERTS.
WELL I JUST I RESPOND THAT BEST
PRACTICES ARE ALREADY IN
PRACTICE AND I THINK THAT THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT SHOULD BE
LOOKED OUT SO WE DON'T PUT SOME
ARBITRARY.
TIONS ON THE SIZE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT WHEN THAT SEES
SENSUALLY WE'RE TRYING TO DO TO
HELP PEOPLE FOR COMMUNITIES TO
MEET THE RENOWNED.
SO I THINK THEY'RE SO I I JUST
THINK WITHIN AND YOU'VE GOT
CONFLICTS THAT ALMOST DEFEAT ONE
ANOTHER AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THAT IT
JUST KIND OF REFLECTS THAT AS I
READ IT.
AND HAVING HAD THE EXPERIENCE
FRANKLY WE HAVE WHAT ARE CALLED
FUEL MODIFICATIONS ON DOZEN AND
JOB LEAVE ME I'D LOVE TO PLANT A
LOT MORE STUFF IN MY FUEL MINES
ON BUT I CAN'T.
AND NOW I KNOW WHY AND I'M I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT WE ALSO A
PAY MORE. FOR A FIRE INSURANCE
AND WE WE ARE IN AN S. R. A..
M. DOUBTS BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S
COORDINATED THROUGH THE FIRE
AUTHORITY ORANGE COUNTY I I
DON'T THINK WE'RE THAT FAR OFF
YOUR MAYBE IT'S JUST THE
EMPHASIS IS ON A DIFFERENT
SOLANO.
LANGUAGE WHEN IT GETS RIGHT TO
RIGIDLY THEN YOU DO RIGHT
EXACTLY WHAT -- THE V. I. IS
TALKING ABOUT THAT USE THEIR
FREE THOUGH FORWARD YOU KNOW
LITIGATION ALL OUT SAID
CERTAINLY ISN'T THE INTENT AND I
DON'T.
BELIEVE THAT.
THE ARMENIAN TURPIN TATIAN WE'RE
SEEING IS NOT ONE THAT I SHARE
BUT CERTAINLY THE INTENT IS NOT
TO LIMIT -- BUT IT'S TO PROTECT
AND TO CREATE THE THE THE BEST
INFRASTRUCTURE -- WE CAN TO
PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY.
AYE AYE HI I KNOW THAT SECURITY
AND I'M JUST SAYING TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT.
OKAY INTERNATIONAL CENTER COVER
ERA MY APOLOGIES.
PICTURE -- YOU KNOW I HAVE SOME
OF THE SAME CONCERNS AS SENATOR
BATES -- SENATOR JACKSON NIGHT
THERE WERE THERE WERE TWO THINGS
THAT JUMPED OUT AT ME WHEN I
WHEN I READ THIS AND AND BOTH OF
THEM REALLY GO TOGETHER ONE WAS
THE THE RENO WHAT NUMBER
DISCUSSION -- AT A I GET THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC LIFE AND LIMB -- BUT
TO ABSOLVE THE THE ENTITY.
THAT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO BUILD
HOUSING BECAUSE THEY HAVE
PROPERTY THAT ARE THAT ARE PART
OF A MOVIE -- I THINK IS IS --
IS GOING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION
AND I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT I WAS
GOING TO ASK YOU WHAT YOUR
PURPOSE HAS BEEN TRYING TO GET
RID OF THAT BUT I ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER IF IT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT THAT YOU'RE GONNA TAKE OUT
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE I'M.
STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT --
MOVING FORWARD WHETHER I FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT.
THAT IT IT WON'T SHOW BACK UP
AGAIN BUT I JUST IF AND FRANKLY
FRANKLY -- I I GET SUSPICIOUS
WHEN PEOPLE START.
TINKERING WITH THE READING
NUMBER EVEN AS AS BAD AS THE
SYSTEM IS IT'S THE ONLY SYSTEM
WE HAVE.
AND IF WE'RE NOT BUILDING
HOUSING THEN WE'RE WE'RE
EXACERBATING THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
RIDDICK REDUCTION EFFORTS THAT
WE HAVEN'T AND WE'RE ALSO IT IT
IT JUST.
IT FORCES PEOPLE INTO
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE THEY JUST
CAN'T AFFORD THE COST WE DID
TAKE THE AMENDMENT THAT SAYS
IT'S A NET ZERO CHOSE TO CLARIFY
THAT AMENDMENT -- IF WE DID TAKE
THAT -- BECAUSE THAT ISN'T THE
INTENT HERE THE INTENT IS SHOWS
TO BE RESPECTFUL.
OF THE DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE WITH LOUISE AND TO TRY -- TO
A SURE THAT WE DON'T PEOPLE AT
IN HARM'S WAY BY BUILDING IN
AREAS WHERE IT IS DANGEROUS
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME NOT
ATTEMPTING AND NOT -- REDUCING
THE RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE
HAVE UNDER A WRITTEN. TO THE
RENEWAL REQUIREMENTS SO WE DID
TAKE THAT IS I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WERE HERE WHEN WE TOOK THAT
FIRST AMENDMENT AND AS FAR AS
THE LANGUAGE TO BALANCE THIS OUT.
THE KIND OF PERMIT UP IS TO
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON AND THEN THE
THE OTHER THE OTHER PART REALLY
HAD TO DO WITH THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PART OF IT WHICH IS
THAT -- THERE THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE UNSPECIFIED SET ASIDE
SIDE AMOUNTS OF MONEY FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR GRANTS TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES -- AND WHILE I I
THINK IT'S A IT'S A REALLY GOOD
IDEA THAT WE WE HARDEN -- THE
SAFETY ISSUES THAT WE HAVE I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO ROADS OUT WATER SUPPLY --
IF THERE'S A NEED FOR REMOTE
INFRARED CAMERAS THAT THEY'RE
NOT DOING IT AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE I GOT A LOT OF REQUESTS
FROM.
ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN MY
DISTRICT THIS YEAR FOR FIRE IN
FIRE -- STATIONS POLICE STATIONS.
LIBRARIES PARKS AND QUITE
FRANKLY MOST OF MY COMMUNITIES
ARE BLUE COLLAR POOR COMMUNITIES
AND THEY PUT THAT ON AS FEES AS
PART OF THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
SO I'M I I LOOK AT THE AT THIS
AND SAY WHY WOULDN'T LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PAY FOR THIS OR WHY
WOULDN'T THAT.
THE THE FEES IT PEOPLE PAY TO
LIVE IN THOSE COMMUNITIES VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT CENTER BATES
TALKED ABOUT THEIR THEIR
HOMEOWNERSASSOCIATION IS IS --
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR DOING
THIS THIS KIND OF THESE KINDS OF
THINGS SO WHY WOULD WE WANT THE
STATE TO PAY FOR SOME OF THIS --
OR YEAH I GET WHAT WAS SOME OF
THE ISSUES FOR EXAMPLE AREAS IN
THE MOVIE IN MY OWN DISTRICT
THAT WOULD THERE'S ONLY ONE
ACCESS EGRESS AND INGRESS.
AND HOW ARE YOU GOING TO BUILD
THAT THAT ADDITIONAL ACCESS SO
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN PARADISE THAT WAS
VERY SIMILAR PROBLEM AND THEY
EITHER DIDN'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO BUILD.
ANOTHER WAY OUT OR FOR REASONS
THAT WE NOW LOOK BACK AND
HINDSIGHT WERE MORE FOOLISH ONCE
THEY DID NOT DO SO.
SO THAT'S PART OF THE THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
IS THERE.
IS THERE SUFFICIENT INGRESS OR
EGRESS OF THE PEOPLE GET OUT IF
THEY HAVE.
TO DO WE HAVE ENOUGH -- WATER
SUPPLY DO WE HAVE ENOUGH
ELECTRICITY TO PUMP THE WATER.
IF IF IT'S NECESSARY IN THOSE
AREAS THESE ARE ALL QUESTIONS
THAT THAT WE NEED TO ASK IN THAT.
WE FRANKLY HAVE NOT DONE A REAL
GOOD JOB.
ADDRESSING THOSE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS WHEN WE SEE.
YOU KNOW ALL THE FIRES THAT
WE'VE HAD IN THE IN THE
INABILITY WE'VE HAD TO FIGHT
THEM BECAUSE THE LOOK OF THE
LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE -- SO
AGAIN -- BUILDING A FIRE STATION
IS ONE THING AND YOU KNOW YOU
CAN DO YOU CAN DO CERTAIN THINGS.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE.
BUILDING OR WHEN YOU'RE
ADDRESSING -- POPULATIONS IN
THAT WILDLIFE URBAN INTERFACE
THE ANSWERS AREN'T ALWAYS SO
SIMPLE.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WE HAVE TO START LOOKING AT
WHERE WE ARE BUILDING BECAUSE
THE COST.
OF PUTTING IN THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE MAY BE
PROHIBITIVE.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER PEOPLE ARE
PAYING FEES ARE NOT.
I THINK -- THERE ALSO.
THANK YOU CHAIR -- I NOT SURE
I'M I'M MAY BE MISSING SOMETHING
HERE IN TERMS OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES A BEEN BROUGHT UP.
WE'RE TASKED WITH FIGURING OUT
HOW TO ADJUST THE WAY WE DO
THINGS.
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THERE
IS THIS ENVIRONMENTAL GLOBAL.
ISSUE MORE MEAN ISSUE.
AND WE CAN DO THINGS THE SAME
WAY THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THEM
FOR AND THEY THEY MIGHT HAVE.
MET A CERTAIN NEED BEFORE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT MEETING THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE ANYMORE.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHY THIS MIGHT
BE A LITTLE FRUSTRATING FOR THE
BUILDING -- INDUSTRY.
BUT IF WE DON'T MAKE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE WAY WE DO THINGS IN THE
FUTURE AS FAR AS BUILDING WHERE
WE SHOULD OR BUILDING WHERE WE
SHOULD AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO FACE THE SAME.
CRISIS IS GOING TO GET WORSE AND
WORSE SO.
I'M NOT SURE IF I'M MISSING
SOMETHING BUT I THINK THAT YOU
HAVE ADDRESSED THE ISSUES AS FAR
AS WHERE WE NEED TO PLAN THIS IS
ABOUT PLANNING AHEAD.
AND NOT JUST REACTING WE HAVE
SPENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THOSE MEN AND WOMEN AND
FAMILIES WHO SUFFERED EITHER
BECAUSE THEY LOST SOMEONE THEY
LOST THEIR HOMES.
I MEAN THE THERE IS JUST
NUMEROUS PROBLEMS AND ISSUES AND
SUFFERING THAT HAVE HAPPENED.
NOW WE WANT TO SORT OF A JUST TO
SAY THOSE TWO THINGS A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT HERE WHILE NOT
FORGETTING THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO BILLS SO -- YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE ANSWERED ALL OF
MY QUESTIONS AND I THINK YOU'VE
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF MONTH.
COLLEAGUES ANY ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SO I WANT.
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND JUST TO GIVE -- SIR
PUBLICLY SAY WHAT WORK WITH MY
PERSPECTIVE IS ON ON THIS AND
THIS IS NOTHING THAT -- THE
AUTHOR HASN'T.
HEARD AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS ON HI -- I AGREED THAT
WE NEED TO DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
IN TERMS OF WHERE WE BUILD AND
THERE ARE AREAS.
WHERE WE SHOULD -- BE PULLING
BACK ON IT WAS A TOUCHY AREA
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE LIVING.
IN IN THESE AREAS ON BUT IT'S
NOT SUSTAINABLE TO JUST CONTINUE
PUT MORE MORE HOUSING IN THESE
HIGH RISK.
AREAS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
WE CALIFORNIA HAS A THREE AND A
HALF MILLION HOME DOT HOUSING
DEFICIT.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE AND I
SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD BUT
IT'S SORT OF EXTRAORDINARY OUR
HOUSING DEFICIT OF THREE MILLION
HOMES.
IS EQUAL TO THE HOUSING DEFICIT
AND THE OTHER FORTY NINE STATES
COMBINED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOMES PER
CAPITA?
CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY NINE OUT
OF FIFTY SAY THAT AGAIN
OF FIFTY IN HOMES PER CAPITA THE
ONLY STATE THAT IS LOWER.
IS THE STATE OF UTAH -- WHEN I'M
SPECULATING THAT THEY HAVE
LARGER HOUSEHOLD SIZES AND
THAT'S WHY OTHERWISE WE WOULD
PROBABLY BE FIFTY OUT OF?
FIFTY AND SO AS WE START
THINKING ABOUT OKAY ARE THERE
AREAS WHERE WE DON'T WANT TO
BUILD HOUSING ANYMORE.
WE HAVE WE CAN'T JUST LOOK AT
THAT SIDE OF THE EQUATION WE
HAVE TO SAY OKAY WHERE ARE WE
GOING. TO BUILD THE HOUSE AND
THAT'S WHY I DID HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE WAY THIS IS PHRASED IN
TERMS OF POTENTIALLY LOWERING
RINA ALLOCATIONS.
IN CITIES.
AND WITHOUT SAYING OKAY WHERE
ELSE IN YOUR CITY ARE YOU GOING
TO BUILD OKAY YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
AREA HERE BUT YOU CAN DO MORE
HERE AND MAYBE.
THAT AND THE OTHER PIECE OF IT --
IS THAT WE KNOW HAVING GONE
THROUGH THE RENO PROCESS AND I
KNOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE GONE TO
THE RE IN A PROCESS. ONE OF THE
WORST. ONE OF THE WORST PARTS OF
THE RENO PROCESS.
IS THAT CITIES THAT ARE
WEALTHIER AND MORE POWERFUL.
SHOW OF MAUREEN OBLIGATION AND
THE CITIES THAT ARE LOWER INCOME
AND LESS POWERFUL IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN THE WAY IT'S BEEN WITH RINA --
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIX THAT BUT
WHAT WE DON'T WANT -- IS -- FOR
WHEN WE SAY THE COGS YOU CAN
DECIDE HOW TO ALLOCATE A IT HAS
TO BE CABINS.
SO WE DON'T HAVE AREAS THAT ARE
MORE POWERFUL PUSHING HOUSING
AND OTHER AREAS TO THOSE OF THE
THE CONCERNS THAT.
ON THAT I'VE HAD -- AND THAT'S
WHY WE AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR GREEN TO THE PLEASE HOLD
A LANGUAGE SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGH THAT ISSUE AND I'M
CONFIDENT WE'LL BE ABLE TO COME
UP WITH THE RESOLUTION -- AND
THE FINAL POINT I MAKE IS --
YOUR WU WE WE ARE WHY I HATE
THAT WORD WHILE IN URBAN
INTERFACE IS GOING TO SAY IT
THAT WAY.
THE WAY YOU DO IT IS A IS A
REALLY REALLY REALLY BROAD.
GEOGRAPHY OF WHOLE BUNCH OF
CALIFORNIA IS A WEILAND URBAN
INTERFACE.
NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE --
FIVE DEGREES OF WILDLIFE OF
WILDLIFE WILD FIRE HAZARD -- WE
HAVE MAPS OF THE VERY HIGH RISK
HIGH RISK AND SO FORTH I SAID I
NEED TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION TO NOT ALL.
WE WE IS CREATED EQUAL -- SO
LOOK FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION
IN THE COMING WEEKS -- AND AGAIN
THANK YOU THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND SOMETIME CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS BILL.
DOES NOT BAN HOUSING IN FIRE
PRONE AREAS OF THE STATE.
IT ONLY REQUIRES THAT HIGH
STANDARDS FOR HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DESIGN IN FOR A
MERCHANT SEE RESPONSE.
BE MAD IN ORDER FOR NEW HOUSING
TO PROCEED SO THAT WE THAT WE
TAKE THE STEPS THAT WE KNOW WE
SHOULD BE TAKING TO PROTECT.
WHERE WE BUILD FROM THE
REALITIES OF THE WILDFIRES THAT
WE'VE HAD AND THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE GOING FORWARD
SO -- I WANT TO BE CLEAR ON THAT
IT IT IS.
AN INFORMATION AND EDUCATION AND
A PROTECTION -- MEASURE BUT IT'S
NOT AN EXCLUSION.
MEASURE AND HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THAT -- LANGUAGE
GOING FORWARD WE WANT TO LOCAL
PLANNING TO INCLUDE THIS AND NOT
TO IGNORE THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS --
THERE'S NO DESIRE THERE'S NO
INTENT TO REDUCE THE RENO
ALLOCATIONS US WILL BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT.
THIS BILL TRULY IS A BILL.
THAT IT ATTEMPTS TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
AND THE DAMAGE THAT THEY CREATE
SO.
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS A HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS AGAIN THE SPIRIT
OF THIS BILL.
IS NOT THE KILL HOUSING.
THE THE SPUR THIS BILL IS SO
THAT WHILE FAR DON'T KILL PEOPLE.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- DO I
HAVE A MOTION TO PASS THE BILL
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
BY SENATOR WHY CAL SKI AND WE
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS ISN'T A BILL ONE EIGHTY TWO
BY SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
MORALE.
BROWN NO BATES.
BATES SNOW COVER GIRL.
I DRAWS -- DRAWS -- BY MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
MARK NO ROUGH PROFIT BY SKINNER.
UMBERG CASKEY.
OKAY CI.
OKAY THE VOTER FIVE THE THREE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF AMBER
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
CENTER JACKSON YOU HAVE A SECOND --
BILL THAT IS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP.
TWO EIGHTY I HOPE THIS ONE GOES
A LOT FASTER.
THIS IS A THE BILL THERE WERE
CALLING THE DIGNITY AT HOME ACT
SB. TWO EIGHTY SIX TO ALLOW MORE
SENIORS AND DISABLED DISABLED
INDIVIDUALS TO AGE IN PLACE.
AND STAY IN THEIR OWN HOMES
THROUGH THE USE OF HOME
MODIFICATIONS.
THAT REDUCE THE RISK OF FALLING.
A THOUSAND PEOPLE EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY ARE TURNING
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER
OR TURN SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
33% OF ALL FALLS AMONG OLDER
ADULTS INVOLVED HAZARDS AT HOME.
ACTORS LIKE POOR LIGHTING LOOSE
CARPETS AND A LACK OF SAFETY
EQUIPMENT THINGS LIKE GRAB BARS
STAIR RAILS.
IN HIGH TOILETS ARE EXAMPLES --
ARE A BRITISH PARTICULAR RISKS
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE THOSE
AVAILABLE. 80% OF FALLS HAPPENED
BY THE WAY IN THESE HOMES IN THE
BATHROOM.
SO WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT WE CAN
DO TO PREVENT AGAINST THIS.
AND SB TWO EIGHTY DOES TWO
THINGS TO HELP SENIORS AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITIES MAKE THEIR
HOME SAFER.
AND PLACES THAT WILL ACCOMMODATE
THEM FOR YEARS TO COME FIRST
THIS AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING. TO ISSUE GRANTS TO
LOCAL. ELEVEN AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING FOR INJURY PREVENTION
SERVICES IN THE HOME.
THESE GRANTS CAN BE USED TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS AROUND THE HOME FOR
THE ADDITION OF GRAB BARS FOR
EXAMPLE OR IMPROVE LIGHTING OR
SIMPLE THINGS SUCH AS SIMPLY
TACKING A RUN DOWN.
SO THAT SOMEBODY DOESN'T SLIP
AND FALL THE SMALL IMPROVEMENTS
CAN MEAN THE DIFFERENCE FOR MANY
OLDER ADULTS BETWEEN AGING IN
PLACE AND FACING A FUTURE OF
INSTITUTIONALIZATION. 50% OF
PEOPLE WHO GO TO THE HOSPITAL
FOR FALLS AFTER HIS SENIORS DO
NOT EVER GET TO COME HOME AGAIN.
SO IF WE'RE LOOKING AT A SMALL --
FINANCIAL COST THAT IS GOING TO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE
IMPACTS FOR SENIORS AND ARE
DISABLED COMMUNITY THIS BILL.
DOT MEASURES UP THIS BILL ALSO
ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DURING
ITS NEXT TRIENNIAL RULEMAKING
CYCLE TO CONSIDER SOME BUILDING
STANDARDS CHANGES.
INCLUDING ADDING THINGS LIKE A
WIDENED DOORWAY IN ONE BEDROOM
AND ONE BATHROOM ON THE GROUND
FLOOR RELOCATING DOORBELLS LIGHT
SWITCHES AND HEATING VENTILATION
AND AIR CONDITIONING CONTROLS SO
THAT THE REACHABLE FOR THOSE WHO
HAVE MOBILITY IMPAIRMENTS.
AND THE ADDITION OF SUPPORT
BACKING FOR THE FUTURE
INSTALLATION OF GRAB BARS IN ONE
OR MORE BATHROOMS.
SIMPLE SIMPLE ITEMS BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THEY HAVE A
TREMENDOUS POSITIVE IMPACT ON
ALLOWING OUR SENIORS TO AGE IN
PLACE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT FACILITIES EVEN TO
DAY FOR OUR AGING POPULATION AND
CALIFORNIA IS AN AGING STATE WE
WILL HAVE FOUR MILLION MORE
SENIORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BAR I BELIEVE IT'S THE YEAR
TWENTY THIRTY WHERE ARE WE GOING
TO GOAL AS SENIORS.
IF WE SUFFER THESE KINDS OF
EVENTS THAT MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE
TO AGING HOME IN OUR HOME SO
WITH THAT I HAVE LAUREN WILL FOR
PRESENTING THE BILL'S SPONSOR.
THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
AS WELL AS MAXINE MAN TELL FROM
THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY.
I THANK YOU OF REACH WITNESS I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR
REMARKS TO ABOUT THREE MINUTES.
OKAY -- I'D LIKE TO SAY TO THE
COMMITTEE MY PASSION.
FOR FALLS PREVENTION.
A STEM FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE
WITH MY STEP MOTHER WHO HAD A
SERIOUS FALL.
AND SHE HAD TO STAY IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY AND REHAB
FACILITY FOR MANY MONTH.
BECAUSE SHE KNEW SHE WAS IN A
WHEELCHAIR BUT SHE COULDN'T GET
INTO HER HOUSE.
AND I COULDN'T EVEN BRING HER
INTO MY HOUSE TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOW HER TO RECOVER THEIR AND
TAKE HER TO THE TERM ROCK.
REHAB -- GIVEN CUT CALIFORNIA'S
NEED TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
AVAILABLE HOUSING.
IT'S A PERFECT TIME FOR THE
STATE TO MAKE THAT HOUSING MORE
AGE AND DISABILITY FRIENDLY.
BY INCORPORATING FALLS
PREVENTION OR SPECIFIC
ACCESSIBLE FEATURES INTO THE
STATE BUILDING STANDARDS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA HOUSING.
MAKING THESE CHANGES WILL ALLOW
RESIDENTS TO STAY IN THEIR HOME
IS A AGE AND ALLOW FAMILIES TO
EASILY BRING ELDER MEMBERS ENTER
THEIR HOME.
AS THEY NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
POLICY FEATURES CAN BE MUCH LESS
COSTLY WHEN BUILT INTO THE
ORIGINAL DESIGN OF THE HOUSING.
A DEVELOPMENT AN INDIVIDUAL
HOMES RATHER THAN TO RETROFIT
EXISTING HOMES AT A TIME WHEN --
CALIFORNIANS ARE AGING RETIRING
HAVE LESS INCOME.
THE COST OF APPS GOD DOING A
REHABILITATION LOAN IS
EXORBITANT.
NEXT TO THE COST OF WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO PUT THESE PUT
THESE.
AMENDMENTS INTO THE INTO THE
BUILDING AT THE TIME THAT IT'S
BEING BUILT -- QUESTED FEATURES
IN SB TWO EIGHTY WILL NOT
SIGNIFICANT DIFFICULTLY CHANGE
THE LOOK OR THE COST OF BUILDING
THE HOUSE.
CREATING FOREVER HOMES FOR
CALIFORNIA CAN ALSO PRESERVE
WEALTH SO THAT CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE ABLE TO SAVE MONEY AS A AGE.
BY NOT HAVING TO MOVE WHEN THEIR
PHYSICAL ABILITIES ECOME
REDUCED AND HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO HAVE THE HELP THAT THEY NEED
AS THEY AGE.
CALIFORNIA HAS TO IMPENDING
CRISES. ONE IS THE LACK OF
HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE FOR
YOUNG AND OLD CALIFORNIANS A
LIGHT.
THE SECOND IS HOW WILL WE PAY
FOR THE MEDICAL.
IN HOME CARE NEEDS OF OUR SENIOR
POPULATION.
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE WILL USE
MEDICARE.
AS A PART OF AT THE RECOVERY OR
THEIR ON GOING CARE.
AND IF THEY HAVE A FALL AND IT
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
LIVE IN THEIR HOMES OTHERWISE.
SHOULDN'T WE BE LOOKING AT
INSURING THAT PEOPLE CAN LIVE
SAFELY IN THEIR HOUSES FOR
LONGER.
AND AND THAT FAMILIES CAN AFFORD
TO CARE FOR THEIR AGING
RELATIVES IN THEIR HOMES.
RATHER THAN BE FORCED TO SEND
THEM TO MEDI CAL PAID SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES.
IN THE EFFORT TO INCREASE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE STATE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO MAKE SMART
DECISIONS.
ABOUT CREATING HOUSING THAT
LASTS FOR SENIORS FAMILIES AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MAXINE MAN
TALENT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY.
SB TWO EIGHTY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR PEOPLE LIVING
WITH MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS.
MS IS A CHRONIC AND OFTEN
DISABLING DISEASE OF THE CENTRAL
NERVOUS SYSTEM THAT TYPICALLY IS
DIAGNOSED IN YOUNG ADULTHOOD.
IT'S A PUZZLING AND
UNPREDICTABLE DISEASE VARIES
WIDELY IN ITS IMPACT NOT ONLY
FROM PERSON TO PERSON.
BUT ALSO IN THE SAME INDIVIDUAL
AT DIFFERENT TIMES.
MS CAN IMPAIR MUSCLE STRENGTH --
SENSATION BALANCE COORDINATION
AND GATE AND BECAUSE SIGNIFICANT
DISABLING FATIGUE.
STUDIES CONSISTENTLY FIND THAT
OVER 50% OF PEOPLE WITH A MASS
HAVE FALLEN DOWN IN A THREE TO
SIX MONTH PERIOD.
AND 3250% HAD FALLEN MULTIPLE
TIMES IN THE SAME TIME FRAME.
BUT HOME MODIFICATIONS CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE.
THEY CAN INCREASE SAFETY IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY AND ALLOW PEOPLE
WITH MS. TO MAINTAIN
INDEPENDENCE IN THEIR OWN HOMES
CONTINUE TO WORK AND BE ACTIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY.
SAFETY PRECAUTION PRECAUTIONS
SUCH AS GRAB BARS AND SHOWERS
ARE NEAR TOILETS.
AND INVESTMENTS AND RAMPS AT
ENTRANCE DOORS GRAB RAILS LONG
STAYERS REYES TOILETS LOWERED
LIGHT SWITCHES WILL ALLOW THE
DISABLED INDIVIDUAL CONTINUED
INDEPENDENCE.
AND HELP THEM AVOID ACCIDENTS
LEADING TO INJURIES AND HOSPITAL
STAYS AND POSSIBLY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION.
THE COST OF MODIFYING HOME TO
MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE VARIES WIDELY.
THIS GRANT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
THE POSSIBLE CHANGES TO BUILDING
STAMBERG.
BUILDING STANDARDS ESTABLISHED
THROUGH SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY
WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE ASSISTANCE
IN ENHANCING ACCESSIBILITY.
AND KEEP PEOPLE.
LIVING WITH EN MASSE AND OTHER
DISABILITY SAFE IN THEIR HOMES.
THE NATIONAL MS SOCIETY SUPPORTS
SB TWO EIGHTY AND JUST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DIGITAL SUPPORT TO CHAIRMAN%
SENATORS ON BOB BREMER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BULDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING THE FIVE MEMBER
INDUSTRY COALITION THAT HAD BEEN
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ON HER STAFF YOUR STAFF A IN THE
SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH IS.
A TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU EXPECT HER.
I'M AND WARREN WITH CALIFORNIA'S
SENIOR LEGISLATURE WITH SPONSOR
THIS BILL AND WE URGE YOU TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible] SIX FIGURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BOB MINERS ROW COPELAND I BELONG
TO A DOCTOR'S DISABILITY RIGHTS
GROUP IN SACAMENTO THIS IS A
GOOD FIRST STEP MAKES.
HOUSING ACCESSIBLE -- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL RIGHT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY THING THAT WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE BILL EVERY SINGLE.
YOU WILL SOME DAY.
OKAY -- WITH EMOTION BY SENATOR
ROTH SO -- CENTER JACKSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THE SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY BY
SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BATES RIGHT BATES I COVER --
DRAWS SO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE MORLOCK.
MY LIKE I ACROSS [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
WIENER AYE [inaudible]
ROTH HI.
UMBERG CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE. ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THAT IS ENOUGH -- TO PASSED OUT
OF THE COMMITTEE BUT WE'LL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
OKAY -- I SEE THAT CENTER ARE TO
LET IT IS HERE SO -- WILL CALL
ITEM NUMBER SIX AS BEFORE
.
THIRTY FOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMUTERS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- I AM
PRESENTING SENATE BILL.
FOUR THREE FOUR AND PRETTY
SIMPLE BILL.
SHOULD SHARE MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I PRESENT SB
FORTY FOUR WHICH WILL PLACE
INDUSTRY BEST PRACTICES THE
DAVIS STIRLING ACT. FOR MANAGERS
AND MANAGEMENT COMPANIES TO
FOLLOW WHEN TRANSFERRING
ASSOCIATION DOCUMENTS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CONDOMINIUMS.
AND AND TOWN HOUSES AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE -- THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN ASSOCIATION RETAINS
NEW MANAGEMENT.
AND THE FORMER MANAGER OR
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FAILED TO
TRANSFER THE NECESSARY DOCUMENTS
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
IN A TIMELY MANNER WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY DAYS THESE
DOCUMENTS INCLUDE BUT ARE NOT
LIMITED.
TO MEMBERSHIP THIS BOARD
MEETINGS RECORDS.
BY LAWS FINANCIAL INFORMATION
SUCH AS OF THE BUDGET CONDO PLAN
SEE SEE AN ART IN PUBLIC REPORT.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE USUALLY
HANDED OVER FROM.
ONE PROPERTY OWNER TO THE NEXT
PROPERTY OWNER.
BUT THE PROPERTY MANAGEMENT
COMPANY -- USUALLY HAS THE EXACT
SAME -- FILE.
A NEW MANAGEMENT COMPANY CANNOT
PERFORM MANY OF ITS SERVICES%
WITHOUT THESE DOCUMENTS WHICH
ULTIMATELY CREATED A SIGNIFICANT
OPERATIONAL AND FINANCIAL ISSUES.
FOR THAT ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION.
A COMMUNITY MANAGER SHE IS A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION OF
ASSOCIATION MANAGERS MEMBERS.
OF THE ASSOCIATION ABIDE BY A
CODE OF ETHICS AND BEST
PRACTICES WHICH INCLUDE
GUIDELINES FOR THE TRANSFER OF
THESE DOCUMENTS.
AND OFTENTIMES WHAT'LL HAPPEN IS
THE DEVELOPER SPECIALLY BRED
WHEN WE'RE TALK ABOUT YOU
HOUSING.
THE DEVELOPER WILL HAVE THESE
DOCUMENTS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
AND GIVEN TO THE HOMEOWNER AND
ALSO TO THE BRAND YOU
ASSOCIATION.
OF A HOMEOWNERS WHICH IS RUN BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION
SO HERE IT IS FIVE YEARS LATER.
LET'S ASSUME THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVE THEY HAVE A NEW
PRESIDENT.
AND TIME GOES ON AND HE DOESN'T
LIKE THE ASSOCIATION HE'S WITH
OR THE ASSOCIATION MANAGEMENT
COMPANY.
AND SO THEY CHANGE COMPANIES AND
THAT'S WHERE THE PROBLEM LIES.
THE ASSOCIATION COMPANY.
IS TO TRANSFER OF THE OF
INFORMATION FROM ONE COMPANY TO
THE OTHER.
AND IT'S ALSO NECESSARY FOR THE
FOR THE LENDING INSTITUTION TO
SEE EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON SO
SB.
FOUR THIRTY FOUR BORROWED FROM
THE ASSOCIATION THE CODE OF
ETHICS AND WILL CREATE A UNIFORM
STANDARD.
OF ALL COMMUNITY MANAGERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFFERS THOROUGH
ANALYSIS AND I WOULD POINT OUT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS
REGARDING THE EXEMPTION -- IT
WILL BE LOOKING AT TO THOSE
EXEMPTIONS AND TAKING THOSE --
ISSUE BY ISSUE AS NOTED THE
ALICE AN ANALYSIS I COMMIT TO
WORK WITH THEM AND AND YOURSELF
AND OUR STAFF TO TIGHTEN UP HE'S
PERCEIVED LOOPHOLES.
THE BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION
COMMITTEE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION A COMMUNITY MANAGER.
FOR THESE REASONS I THEREFORE
ASK FOR YOUR FIVE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE CODY
BOILS.
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING -- YOU
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING ANY
INFORMATION YOU MAY HAVE AS WELL.
CHRIS OR WANT ONE WITNESS. FOR
TWO AND A MISTER OKAY -- SO OVER
THERE WE GO.
KEEP IT TO THREE MINUTES EACH
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU --
CODY THANK YOU AB SENATOR AND
MEMBERS THAT COULD WELL SOME
HALF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
IT'S TO CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE WHO REPRESENT
OVER -- FIFTY THOUSAND
ASSOCIATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER ROUGHLY FIVE
MILLION RESIDENTS -- WE BELIEVE
THAT HAVING A STANDARD --
TRANSFER RULES OF DOCUMENTS WILL
DO TWO THINGS THE FIRST ONE IS
TO PROTECT THE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF HOMEOWNERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE OTHER THE SECOND THING
IS THAT IT WILL HELP.
WE THINK ALLEVIATE THE
POSSIBILITY OF COSTLY LITIGATION --
MOVING FORWARD -- THAT HAPPENS
AT TIMES WHEN YOU HAVE.
A DISPUTE WHEN ONE ASSOCIATION
IS.
TRANSFERRING THEIR DOCUMENTS
FROM ONE MANAGER -- TO THE
INCOMING MANAGER -- AS THE
SENATOR SAID -- WE ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESSING.
THE DEFINITION -- ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL TO ADDRESS.
ANY CONCERNS ANYBODY HAS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MR CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME
TODAY.
MY NAME IS TOM FREELY IN THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS.
I'VE ALSO OWNED AND BEEN SENIOR
EXECUTIVES OF MANAGEMENT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OTHER STATES AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
SB FOUR THIRTY FOURS INTENDED.
TO DIRECT THE MANAGEMENT COMPANY.
ON THE TRANSFER OF RECORDS ON
THE TERMINATION OF A CONTRACT
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN
TERMINATED OR THE MANAGEMENT
COMPANY HAS TERMINATED THE
ASSOCIATION.
I'M VERY PROUD.
THAT THIS BILL HAS.
I'D LINE SIMILAR TO THE CODE OF
ETHICS AT CCM.
ETHICS THAT WE AGGRESSIVELY HOLD
OUR MEMBERS.
TO AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MODEL
WITNESSES KEEP WITHIN TIME FOR
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT --
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI MARJORIE
MURRAY CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW --
JULIE SOMEWHAT BAFFLED BY THE
BILL WHILE WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
IDEA.
AND THE THE GOAL OF THE BILL
THAT ASSOCIATION RECORDS SHOULD
BE TRANSFERRED FROM A TERMINATED
PROPERTY MANAGER. TO A NEW
PROPERTY MANAGER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE EXEMPTIONS IN
THE BILL ARE SO BROAD.
THAT THOSE EXEMPTIONS ACTUALLY A
OBSTRUCT THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL.
THE BILL HAS PROVISIONS LIKE IF
THE PROPERTY MANAGER DECIDES
THAT IT'S TOO COSTLY TO TRANSFER
THE RECORDS OR IT'S TOO MUCH OF
AN ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
THAT THE PROPERTY MANAGER IS
EXEMPTED FROM.
TRANSFERRING THOSE RECORDS -- WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND THAT
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS.
ARE ANOTHER LEVEL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THESE ARE QUAYSIDE
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES AND LIKE
ANY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR ANY
GOVERNMENT INCLUDING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ASSOCIATION CAN'T FUNCTION
WITHOUT RECORDS.
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS ARE
REQUIRED BY LAW TO USE RECORDS
FOR MANY PURPOSES FOR EXAMPLE.
TO PROVIDE DISCLOSURES ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS OF THE
ASSOCIATION'S FINANCIAL HEALTH.
OF OF ITS -- POLICIES ON DISPUTE
RESOLUTION IT NEEDS RECORDS TO
FIGURE OUT WHO IS PAID
ASSESSMENTS AND WHO HASN'T.
BUT IF IT TURNS TO THE
TERMINATED PROPERTY MANAGER AND
SAYS HAND OVER THE RECORDS OF
THOSE WHO HAVE PAID ASSESSMENTS
AND THOSE WHO HAVE NOT.
AND THE TERMINATED PROPERTY
MANAGER SAYS -- THOSE HAVE BEEN
LOST OR DESTROYED ACCIDENTALLY
THAN THE ASSOCIATION CAN
FUNCTION.
SO -- WE OPPOSE THE BILL FOR
THOSE REASONS BECAUSE THE
EXEMPTION EXEMPTIONS ARE SO
BROAD AND SO DEEP.
THAT THEY BASICALLY OBSTRUCT THE
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS OF THE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION MY
COLLEAGUE -- TOM SIR WE'LL TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT WE FIND
TROUBLESOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MY NAME
IS TOM SIR I'M A RETIRED
SUPERIOR COURT COMMISSIONER FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY.
AT A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE OF THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION LAW.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY POINTING
OUT THAT THE MANAGER OF THE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION.
HAS A DUTY TO PRESERVE AND
PROTECT.
THE ASSOCIATION'S RECORDS.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IN THIS
EXEMPTIONS.
SECTION SUBSECTION SEE IT ALSO
IN SUBSECTION BE WHERE IT SAYS
THAT A MANAGER.
MANAGING AGENCIES LEAVING.
SHALL NOT BE REQUIRED TO PRODUCE
KLEIN RECORDS IN MORE THAN ONE
FORM EVEN IF THEY MAINTAIN SUCH
RECORDS.
AND SO THE EFFECT OF THE BILL
READ.
SENATE A REALLY IS. TO TAKE THAT
DUTY AND BASICALLY WIPE IT OUT.
BECAUSE A MANAGER CAN SAY -- IT
IS TOO COSTLY OR TOO MUCH OF A
BURDEN -- TO PRODUCE THESE
RECORDS AND THERE GOES THE DUTY --
DEVIOUS WITNESS DID MENTION THE
AVOIDANCE OF COSTLY LITIGATION
AND IRONICALLY.
CAN I TALK ABOUT A DIFFERENT
KIND OF LITIGATION.
IF IN ASSOCIATION.
THOUGHT ITS RECORDS AND THE
PREVIOUS MANAGER SAID ALL I LOST
THEM DESTROY THE MARIE WHATEVER
I DIDN'T TAKE CARE OF THE
RECORDS.
NO LITIGATION BECAUSE THIS BILL
TAKES THEM OFF THE HOOK.
AND SO I FOR THAT REASON I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY THREE NINE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE -- I WANNA --
I THANK GOD CENTER SALADA AND I
SPONSOR FOR WORKING WITH US.
WE HAVE A I FIGURE COMMITMENT.
TO KEEP TO WORK ON TIGHTENING
SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE IN THE POLLS
AND AND OUR STAFF IS AVAILABLE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK.
WITH THE AUTHOR WITH HIS SPONSOR.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE ARE TINY
AND BUT WITH -- WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BILL.
ARE COLORS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
RESEARCH CENTER ROTH.
HELLO WITH A CENTER MY COUNTY
BECAUSE HE'S LIKE THE CHOI GAI
SO.
FEDERAL.
THANK YOU VISITORS CENTER I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SOME OF THE
PHRASES THAT ARE DESCRIBED IN
THE ANALYSIS IS LOOPHOLES
PARTICULARLY THE ONE HAVING TO
DO WITH.
PROPRIETARY OR TRADE SECRET
INFORMATION I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING HOW
THAT APPLIES.
TO OF THE THE TYPE OF DOCUMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE HERE WITH YOUR
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION DOCUMENTS --
I ALSO THINK THE UNDUE BURDEN --
EXPENSE PIECE -- NEEDS TO BE.
NEEDS TO BE DEALT WITH I'M
HAVING TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING HOW --
IF THERE KALRA RECORDS HOW YOU
COULD HAVE THE IT COULD BE AN
UNDUE BURDEN OR EXPENSIVE
TURNING THEM BACK OVER.
IF I UNDERSTAND THE BILL
CORRECTLY SO.
I REALIZE WE NEED TO MOVE THISBILL OUT OF HERE DUE TO OUR
SCHEDULE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE
BUT I KNOW YOU'RE.
REFERRED TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE
AND I'M HOPING BETWEEN NOW AND
THE TIME THAT YOU.
MEET YOUR MAKER IN THE OTHER
COMMITTEE THAT -- THAT YOU DEAL
WITH THE THE THESE LANGUAGE
ISSUES IF BEFORE I RESPOND
CENTER.
YES OUR I'M I'M AWARE OF THESE
AND WE WILL TAKE THEM UP AND I
WILL PERSONALLY MEET -- WITH THE
OPPOSITION HERE BECAUSE I DO
UNDERSTAND IT NEEDS TO BE
ADJUSTED.
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
I'M BRINGING IT FORWARD BECAUSE
WE CANNOT ALLOW -- AN
ASSOCIATION NOT TO DELIVER THE
DOCUMENTS IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
THE FACT IS THAT THE LENDERS ARE
WAITING FOR THESE DOCUMENTS TO
COMPLETE THE LOAN TRANSACTION.
SO WE NEED TO DO ALL THIS
TOGETHER INITIAL WATCH WHY AM I
AM OPEN TO YOUR SUGGESTIONS AND
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL WILL COME
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FIVE SENATORS ARE
AWESOME.
I JUST WANTED. ZERO WHAT ARE --
FELLOW SENATORS HERE HAVE SAID
IS.
IT SEEMS TO CONTRADICT.
A BIT OF YOUR PURPOSE WHICH I
APPLAUD YOU -- FOR BUT IT SEEMS
TO JUST TAKE AWAY.
HE MEANING OF IT SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT BEEN STRAINED
OUT AND THEN YOU'LL GET MY BOOK.
OF A VOTE TODAY AND NEXT TIME
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FEDERAL HEALTHCARE.
A JUDGE SIR BRINGS UP THE POINT
THAT THAT THIS MANAGER HAS A
DUTY NOW THOSE ARE ACTUALLY NOT
HER RECORDS THROUGH THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION RECORDS
AND THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL I
MEAN IT'S NICE TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT.
BUT THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
HE'S GOING TO OBLITERATE THAT
DUTY.
CAN YOU RESPOND TO THAT CONCERN
OF THE OPPOSITE NOT GONNA GO
MUCH FURTHER UNLESS IT'S IT'S
ADJUSTED SO IT WILL BE ADJUSTED.
BEFORE WE GO FORWARD AGAIN
[inaudible]
AND BECAUSE OF THE FACT WHEN WE
WE STARTED THIS WE HADN'T GOTTEN --
THE SURVEY COMPLETED IN ONE OF
MY WINTERS IN THE TIME LINE TO
GET IT IN.
SO THESE THINGS ARE ARE -- NOT
NECESSARY TO BE ADJUSTED NAY
WILL BE.
ALL PLEASE STAND OFF THE BILL
TODAY JUST.
TO MAKE SURE I PAY ATTENTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU BECAUSE OF
THAT YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS I
WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT OUR
COMMITTEE DID WORK.
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS SPONSOR
AND I AM.
A 100% CONFIDENT THAT -- THEY
ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING THOSE
CHANGES THERE WAS NO RESISTANCE
WHATSOEVER I THINK WE JUST RAN
OUT OF TIME -- THIS IS GOING TO
JUDICIARY AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT --
THAT THE LANGUAGE WILL BE
ATTAINED UP TO MEET THOSE
CONCERNS AND AS I SAID --
BETWEEN JUDICIARY STAFF AND OUR
STAFFS -- YOU HAVE A LOT OF
HANDS AVAILABLE TO HELP.
ON ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTION A
SENATOR ROSS FISCAL MATURE
CONSISTENT WITH MY COMMENTS IN
THE COMMITMENT THAT WAS MADE A
MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION -- BY
SENATOR ROTH TO PASS A BILL TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE -- AND
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL BUT I'M
POLITICS CENTER TO WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR CONFIDENCE
AT THE JUSTIN TO WE MADE THAT
THANK YOU AND I PERSONALLY I
VOTE.
I THANK YOU.
OKAY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS ISN'T A BILL FOR THIRTY
FOUR BUT SENATOR ARCHULETA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CENTER WIENER.
WIENER I MORRELL.
BATES RIGHT BATES HI CAROL.
RAZA. THREE ALTHOUGH I AM
MCGUIRE.
BARLACH.
MARK I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
I UMBERG.
CASKEY.
OKAY IT'S SIX TO NOTHING THAT'S
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OPERATE A
WHOLE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OKAY I'D NEXT.
SENATOR HILL IS HERE.
ELIGIBLE FOR A MONTH.
HI CENTER HELLO HE WAS HERE
FIRST BUT THE MOST.
I THINK IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU SIR WIENER.
IF YOU'RE A DESIGNER.
AND I I JUST WANTED TO ADD I'D
SPOKEN AT CENTER HOW ABOUT THIS
BEFORE WE START SINCE I MAY HAVE
TO LEAVE IN THE MIDDLE.
OF THIS SIZE TIME FOR THIS ITEM
TO PRESENT IN HUMAN SERVICES.
I DID JUST WANT.
TO SAY BECAUSE ARENA BILLS ARE
ALWAYS A LITTLE SENSITIVE --
THAT -- IS.
THE TIME TO SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THE CENTER HILL IS.
TAKEN -- SOME GOOD AMENDMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE HOUSING
IMPRISONING ITSELF.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT FOR
THOSE WHO DON'T KNOW -- DIED A
BIG PART OF THE REASON WHY THESE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED TO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING -- WILL
I BELIEVE GET BUILT IN BRISBANE
IS BECAUSE OF THE AUTHOR BECAUSE
OF CENTER.
HILL ON I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THIS
PROJECT VERY CLOSELY IT'S RIGHT
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND IT'S BEEN A LOT OF
TENSION.
OVER THE BAY LANDS -- AND IT WAS
STOCK AND CENTER HILL GOT IT ON
STOCK -- THROUGH HIS --
POLITICAL PROWESS AND UNDER
CERTAIN THE POLITICAL PROCESS%
THE LEGISLATIVEPROCESS --
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL.
AND SO AS A RESULT -- IT'S
MOVING FORWARD IN THE VOTERS OF
BRISBANE -- ARE HAVE -- AGREED
TO IT.
AND SO I THINK THAT THIS IS RINA
ADJUSTMENT IS APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF NEW HOUSING.
MEMBERS FRIENDS OF THANK YOU
SENATOR I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
SAME IN CASE I HAVE TO LEAVE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT --
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND THE OF MY OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE AND AND REALLY MAKING IT
STRONGER.
I'M HAPPILY ACCEPTED ME VERY
VERY HAPPILY ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED IN COMIC
NUMBER EIGHT THAT INCREASES THE
REQUIREMENT. TWO SIX HUNDRED AND
15% FROM THREE HUNDRED AND 50%
INTO CONDITION THIS EXEMPTION
UPON THE CITY COUNCIL APPROVING
THE SPECIFIC PLAN FOR THE SITE.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF
RECEIVING IT FROM THE DEVELOPER.
AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
VOTERS IN BRISBANE AS YOU SAID
MADE A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT.
TO REGIONAL HOUSING WHEN THEY
APPROVED MEASURE JJ WHICH WOULD
PERMIT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED TO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING ON THE
BAILOUT.
THIS WOULD MORE THAN DOUBLE MORE
THAN DOUBLE THE HOUSING STOCK
CURRENTLY IN BRISBANE -- PASSING
MAJOR JJ WAS A WATERSHED MOMENT
FOR BRISBANE AND THE STATE MAJOR
JJ REVERSES NEARLY FIFTY YEARS
OF VOTE AGAINST DEVELOPMENT OF
THE BAY LANDS.
IT REPRESENTS A TYPE OF LOCAL
LEADERSHIP WE NEED THROUGHOUT
THE BAY AREA AND THE STATE IF WE
ARE GOING TO PUT A REAL DENT IN
THE HOUSING CRISIS.
GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
REMEDIATION AND DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS BRISBANE WILL BE WORKING
FOR MANY YEARS IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEVELOPER STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. TO KEEP THE PROJECT ON
TRACK.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO ALLOWS
BRISBANE TO FOCUS ITS EFFORTS ON
GETTING THE BAY LANDS AN
IMPORTANT REGIONAL PROJECT.
DEVELOPED PROPERLY THE BILL DOES
THIS BY INSURING CONSISTENCY IN
BRISBANE'S REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ALLOCATIONS DURING THE
PLANNING CYCLE AND THE NEXT IN
RECOGNITION OF THE COMMITMENT
ALREADY MADE BY THE CITY'S
VOTERS TO DOUBLE ITS HOUSING
STOCK.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO IS NOT A GIFT
THAT IS THE BENEFIT TO BRISBANE
UNDER THE BILL IS ONLY AVAILABLE
IF THE CITY CONTINUES TO MAKE
STEADY PROGRESS WITH THE BILL AS
DEVELOPMENT UNDER THE OVERSIGHT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOP.
DEVELOPMENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE SEEMS THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND I DO
HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- YES THANK YOU -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
OF THE COMMISSION MY NAME'S JOHN
SAKE AND THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR THE CITY OF
BRISBANE I'VE BEEN IN THAT
POSITION FOR ABOUT FOURTEEN
YEARS.
AND OVERSEE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROJECTS
WITHIN THE CITY.
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT --
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AS SENATOR HILL POINTED OUT IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
VOTERS IN BRISBANE DID APPROVE --
BOUGHT BALLOT MEASURE JJ
PERMITTING DEVELOPMENT OF
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED UNITS ON THE SITE KNOWN
AS THE BRISBANE VALENCE.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED IT DOES
DOUBLE THE THE SIZE OF THE CITY
IN THAT PARTICULAR MEASURE.
THE BAIL AND IS A HEAVILY
ENVIRONMENTALLY IMPACTED SITE
HAVING PREVIOUSLY BEEN USED AS A
LANDFILL AND OF RAIL YARD.
AND THE LANDOWNER HAS -- NOT YET
CLEANED UP THE LAND BUT IS
AGREED TO DO SO AS PART OF THIS
PLANNING EFFORT.
THE VOTE IN NOVEMBER DID
REPRESENT A MAJOR SHIFT IN THE
COMMUNITY IN RECOGNITION OF THE
NEED FOR HOUSING IN THE REGION.
AS WELL AS A DESIRE TO SEE THE
BAY LANCE CLEANED UP AND PUT --
TO A BENEFICIAL USE.
OVER THE BAY LANDS DEVELOPMENT
HIS COMPLEXION REQUIRE A NUMBER
OF YEARS OF COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE CITY AND THE VARIOUS A
REGULATORY AGENCY THE STATE
INCLUDING DTS C..
AS WELL AS THE REGIONAL WATER
QUALITY CONTROL BOARD.
AS WELL AS OTHER APPROPRIATE
AGENCIES FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND UTILITIES TO SUPPORT THE
SITE IN THE INFLUX OF
RESIDENTIAL AND COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD OCCUR.
SB SIX SIX SEVENTY TWO
RECOGNIZES THE SIGNIFICANT
COMMITMENT THE CITY'S MAKING. TO
TO REGIONAL HOUSING BY PURSUING
THE PROJECT IS MORE THAN 6100%
OF ITS CURRENT MEAN ALLOCATION.
SB SIX SEVENTY TWO FURTHER
LIMITS THE ADDITION OF NEW RENO
OBLIGATIONS TO BRISBANE FOR THE
NEXT CYCLE ALLOWING THE
DEVELOPER THE CITY.
AND THE REGULATORS AND COMMUNITY
THE FOCUS ON THE WORK THAT MUST
BE COMPLETED TO ACHIEVE THIS
PROJECT -- THE REMEDIATION
EFFORTS AND SPECIFIC PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY BE REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROJECT.
AND LASTLY SB SIX SEVENTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE SPACE AND TIME FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND CITY TO WORK.
TOGETHER ON THIS PROJECT.
WILL REQUIRING ANNUAL PROGRESS
TO BE DEMONSTRATED TO THE
SATISFACTION OF STATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
PASSED FOR I'D LOAD ON SB SIX
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND ASK AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO HAVE A
GOBBLED IT SAID IT'S BECAUSE I'M
TO GO TO HUMAN SERVICES
[inaudible]
NATURALLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SUPPORTERS YES MA'AM.
GOOD EVENING JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE PLEASED
TO TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE I
DON'T AGREE AN UNDERSCORE ENOUGH
WITH THE CITY AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE VOTERS.
HAVE AGREED TO A WE WERE
LITERALLY IN A DOUBLE THE SIZE
OF THE CITY OF BRISBANE IT'S
QUITE THE ACCOMPLISHMENT AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
MEN ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR MORLOCK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR SENATOR HILL AYE.
CAN I COME FROM A PHILOSOPHY OF
NO BETTER NO WORSE IN SO GIVING
SOMETHING TO ONE STARTS.
THE DIFFERENT ISSUES FIVE I WAS
JUST THINKING.
WHY DON'T WE SET SOME?
PARAMETERS THAT WOULD APPLY TO
EVERYBODY AND SO I'M I'M JUST
CHRIS MAYBE YOU HAVE THE ANSWER
AND WHEN YOU MEET EVERYBODY I
DIDN'T QUITE EVERY YOU KNOW
EVERY JURISDICTION EVERY CITY IN
THE CITY YEAH I LIKE IT.
WHEN WE HAVE A LIST OF VALID
EXEMPTIONS FROM RENO?
TO BEST THAT.
THE I THINK THAT WOULD BE A
GREAT IDEA AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL NEXT YEAR OKAY
I LOST.
EMPOWER YOU KNOW MUNICIPALITIES
BECAUSE OF THE BIG QUESTION IS.
A IN A THEY ARE THEY ARE
IMPROVING THE NUMBER OF HOMES.
BY A STAGGERING PERCENTAGE AND
EVERYTHING MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE A RENEWED ALLOTMENT
ISN'T THERE LIKE AN ABILITY FOR
CARRY OVER.
FOR IN THIS CASE MAYBE TEN YEARS.
BOYS AND A WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE
TODAY ME WE'RE WE'RE GIVING THEM
WHY DO WE ALLOW THAT FOR
EVERYONE WELL I'D I DON'T KNOW
PERHAPS AT SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD LOOK AT TO
MAYBE IT'S A GOOD HEARING BUT
DIED YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE.
A GOOD NEXT BILL -- BUT THIS ONE
IS SPECIFIC TO BRISBANE AND THE
THE GOOD WORK THAT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THAT CITY IS TO
UNDERTAKEN -- TO REALLY DOUBLE
AND THE POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES
OF DOUBLING THE SIZE OF THEIR
CITY IS IS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY
IT'S A IT'S A MAJOR.
ACCOMPLISHMENT THINK HOW DO WE
CAPITALIZE MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
THIS GOOD ABOUT IT.
THEN THERE SHOULD BE SOME.
EXEMPTIONS FOR OUR FOR OTHER
CITIES AND SO I AGREE AYE AYE.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
COLLABORATE WITH YOU ON A BILL
I'M NOT WORTHY.
BUT WITH SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT I THINK YOU'RE STARTING
LISA PRESIDENT THEM.
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT I AGREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SEND ANY OTHER ON
ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THEN WE DO HAVE A MOTION -- FROM
SENATOR ROBB.
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL CALL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SORRY
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEGE THANK YOU.
THE SENATE BILL SIX ME TWO BY
SENATOR HILL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
WE REFER THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
[inaudible]
MORROW [inaudible]
FACE.
YES HI BATES AYE FEDERAL DORADO
YES THE OTHER BY MCGUIRE MORLOCK.
ROTH.
MORE LIKE BY ROSS WELL THE ROTH
AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE CASKEY.
CASSIE I THE BILL HAS SIX VOTE
SO WITHOUT THAT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
PRETTY THANK YOU COLLEAGUES SHE
IS VERY MUCH.
US IS NEXT YEAR.
THE BILL HAS SIX WAS THERE HE
JUST DID NOW.
FILMS NOT HERE'S NECK A
SKINNER'S.
I'M A FIVE YEAR.
THEM.
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
2% SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A
TENNESSEE SENATOR ALLEN HERE SO.
YOU GET TO MOVE IN THE FIRST
POSITION HERE.
WHAT YOU'RE TO MOVE SOME?
THANK YOU -- THIS VICE CHAIR IN
MEMBERS -- I WILL I'M THINKING
THE CHAIR -- THERE'S NO MA'AM
IT'S BEING TAKEN IN THERE NO
MA'AM IT'S THIS COMMITTEE ASKED
FOR BUT WEARE TAKING IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE NEGOTIATED WITH --
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE.
OUT SB.
THREE THIRTY WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS RECOGNIZE AND ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT CALIFORNIA IS IN A SERIOUS
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE ARE FORTY NINTH IN HOUSING
UNITS PER CAPITA IN THE U. S..
OUR RENTS AND HOME PRICES ARE
OUT OF REACH FOR MOST EVERY
CALIFORNIAN.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE MEDIAN
PRICE. TO PURCHASE A HOME IN
CALIFORNIA WAS TWO POINT FIVE
TIMES THE AVERAGE OF WHAT YOU'D
PAY IN ANY OTHER STATE.
END OF THE FIFTY MOST EXPENSIVE
CITIES IN TERMS OF RENTAL
MARKETS THIRTY THREE ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THESE HIGH COSTS WHICH ARGUE
GREATLY TO SCARCITY BECAUSE OF
OUR VERY SEVERE LACK OF UNITS
PER CAPITA.
HAVE EXACERBATED HOMELESSNESS.
IN OUR HOMELESSNESS HAS GROWN
16% JUST IN THE TWO YEARS FROM.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND IF WE LOOK AT THE
DATA.
ARE NEWLY HOMELESS PEOPLE.
OUR EMPLOYED AND WE'RE RECENTLY
HOUSE STE THEY'RE NOT ADDICTED
THEY'RE NOT MENTALLY ILL THEY
ARE JUST PEOPLE WHO CANNOT
AFFORD THE COST OF HOUSING.
NOW YOU SAY WHY IS SB THREE
THIRTY DESIGNED TO HELP THAT SB
THREE THIRTY IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
A BILL THAT WOULD ONLY.
CREATE THE LOWEST -- MOST
AFFORDABLE UNITS RATHER IT IS A
BILL [inaudible]
THAT.
SAYS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PARTNER
WITH US AS WE ADDRESS THIS
CRISIS.
THE END [inaudible]
IT.
RELIES ON THE EXISTING ZONING
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAS.
AND IT SAYS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FACILITATE THE HOUSING THAT YOU
WOULD ALREADY ALLOW BY YOUR OWN
RULES.
DO SO BY SPEEDING UP THE
PERMITTING PROCESS SO ONCE YOU
HAVE DETERMINED YOU THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ONCE YOU HAVE
DETERMINED THAT AN APPLICATION
IS COMPLETE.
TAKE NO MORE THAN A YEAR TO
PROCESS THAT APPLICATION.
AND WITH GOVERNMENT AND FINANCES
A MEN'S HAVE NO MORE THAN FIVE
PUBLIC HEARINGS.
IT ALSO SAYS DON'T CHANGE THE
RULES MIDSTREAM ONCE YOU'VE
DEEMS THAT APPLICATION COMPLETE
DON'T CHANGE YOUR DESIGN REVIEW
STANDARDS.
DON'T CHANGE OF THE RULES JUST
PROCESS THE APPLICATION.
IT ALSO SUSPENDS FOR TEN YEARS
THE BILL'S ONLY IN EFFECT FOR
TEN YEARS IT SUSPENDS THOSE
ACTIONS THAT WOULD DECREASE OR
DELAY.
THE NEW HOUSING SUCH AS DOWN
ZONING.
POPULATION CAPS OR CAPS ON
HOUSING WHICH UNFORTUNATELY SOME
OF OUR GOVERNMENT -- GET LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ENACTED.
IT ALSO LISTS.
THEIR PARKING MINIMUMS.
BUT ONLY WITHIN A QUARTER MILE
OF TRANSIT BANDED EXAM SMALL
ROLE CITIES NOW WHY IS THAT IN
THE BILL BECAUSE WHAT MAKES
HOUSING COSTS LEAVE BESIDES JUST
THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS LABOR.
IS TIME.
SO DELAY NOW THAT'S WHY WE'RE
TRYING TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS.
AND ADD ONS LIKE PARKING PARKING
IN CALIFORNIA EACH [inaudible]
EACH.
UNIT A PARKING.
CAN BE VALUED AT YOU CAN ADD. TO
THE COST OF THAT UNIT.
MINIMUM OF TEN THOUSAND AND
UPWARDS TO SIXTY THOUSAND
DEPENDING ON WHERE IT IS BUILT
AND HOW IT IS BUILT.
SO THE LIFTING THE PARKING
MINIMUMS IT DOESN'T SAY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR DEVELOPER YOU
CAN'T ADD PARKING IF THE PERSON
WHO IS BUILDING THE HOUSING
WANTS NEEDS PARKING TO MAKE.
THE UNIT.
WORK.
THEN THAT'S ALLOWED IT JUST
LIFTS REQUIRED PARKING MINIMUMS
AGAIN WITHIN A QUARTER MILE
TRANSIT AND IN SMALL REAL CITIES
IT ALSO REMOVES FOR TEN YEARS.
THE FEES ON LOW INCOME UNITS AND
HOLDS OFF ANY INCREASES ON OTHER
FEES AGAIN JUST FOR THE TEN YEAR
PERIOD SO THAT'S IN EFFECT WITH
THE BILL WOULD DO.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SPEAKING
IT'S DAVID GARCIA FROM THE
TURNER CENTER AT UC BERKELEY.
THANK YOU MUCH GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DAVID GARCIA ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING DIVISION.
A UC BERKELEY AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL -- I THINK IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING ESPECIALLY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THAT CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE THROES OF A DEEP AND
WORSENING HOUSING CRISIS THAT
THREATENS.
OF I TELL THE ENTIRE STATE WE
HAVE HALF OF ALL THE RENTERS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED RENT PER
MINUTE OF OF THOSE 30% ARE
CONSIDERED.
A SEVERELY RENT BURDENS ON TOP
OF THAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING OUR
LOWEST RATES OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
SINCE THE NINETEEN FORTIES SO
LEAGUE NEEDLESS TO SAY THE THE
SCALE THIS CHALLENGE.
DEMANDS POLICIES THAT MATCH THE
MAGNITUDE OF THIS PROBLEM AND
THERE ARE A FEW POLICIES ON THE
TABLE THAT ARE AS BOLD.
AS WAS PROPOSED IN SB THREE
THIRTY SO SO WE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL FOR TWO SPECIFIC
REASONS THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY
OUR RESEARCH.
AND THE FIRST OF WHICH IS THAT
IT WOULD LARGELY PROHIBIT DOWN
ZONING SOME MORATORIUM'S THAT
WOULD LIMIT THE CAPACITY FOR NEW
HOUSING AS PART OF OUR
CALIFORNIA LAND USE SURVEY -- WE
HAD WE SAW THAT MANY CITIES ARE
DOING -- THEIR THEIR FAIR SHARE
TO REDUCE BARRIERS TO NEW
HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SEVERAL
CITIES THAT ACTUALLY REPORTED TO
US THAT OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS
THEY HAVE MADE THEIR LAND USE
EVEN MORE RESTRICTIVE.
MANY TIMES THESE ARE COMMUNITIES
OF AYE OPPORTUNITY WHERE IT IS
APPROPRIATE TO TO BE LOOKING TO
BUILD FOR HOUSING AND SO THIS
BILL WOULD HELP ADDRESS THAT.
ALSO THE COST TO BUILD HOUSING --
IT IS -- WAS PARTICULARLY --
GONE VERY HIGH THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND THIS BILL WOULD HELP
ADDRESS THAT BY LIMITING OUR
PARKING REQUIREMENTS MODIFYING
HOW FEES WILL BE IMPOSED IN
LIMITING OTHER.
OWNERS POLICIES SO IS OUR WORK
IS ALSO SHOWN THE COST TO BUILD
A HAS A GUN UP ASTRONOMICALLY
PARTICULARLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THINGS LIKE
EXCESSIVE FEES ON THE SIR
PARKING REQUIREMENTS -- MAIN
DELAYS IN ENTITLEMENTS AND
PERMIT ISSUANCE THESE CAN ADD
SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE TO THE
OVERALL COST TO BUILD NEW HOMES.
SO I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT -- ONE
I THINK THE SENATOR AND THE A
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND AGAIN WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ADDITIONAL -- SUPPORTERS COME
FORWARD.
I'M SORRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BATES
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PETER GOT FALL AND I'M WITH
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
IN ALL NINE BAY AREA COUNTIES
AND WE'RE HERE TO STATE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB.
THREE THIRTY BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WILL GREATLY HELP
IN THE PRODUCTION OF MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES IN THE BAY AREA
AND ALL HOMES IN GENERAL -- IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE LIKE TO
SAY THAT THERE ARE THREE MAIN
COMPONENTS TO GET IT BUILT YOU
NEED LAND MONEY AND POLITICAL
WILL AND SB THREE THIRTY WILL
TACKLE THE POLITICAL WILL
QUESTION -- IN THE BAY AREA
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
CAN TAKE ANYWHERE FROM FOUR TO
TEN YEARS TO GO FROM CONCEPT TO
REALITY.
AND BY LIMITING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS TO TWELVE MONTHS FOR NEW
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS SB THREE
THIRTY WILL GREATLY SPEED UP THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE HOMES --
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
LIKE ALL DEVELOPMENTS TO NEED
CERTAINTY IN THE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS AND THERE HAVE BEEN
INSTANCES IN THE BAY AREA FOR
INSTANCE THERE IS A BERKELEY
PROJECT THAT.
STARTED WITH ONE PARKING
REQUIREMENT IN WAS APPROVED
WITHOUT PARKING REQUIREMENT IN
MIND AND THEN AFTER THE PROJECT
WAS APPROVED.
THE PARKING REQUIREMENT WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED THE LANE
THAT THE APPROVAL THE BILL IN
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THAT PROJECT.
AND NECESSITATING FOR TO GO BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD TO FIND
MORE SUBSIDY TO PAY FOR PARKING
SPOTS -- AND SB THREE THIRTY
REMOVES THAT UNCERTAINTY IN THE
PROCESS.
AND FINALLY WE THINK THAT BY
HAVING THE CERTAINTY AND CLARITY
IN THE PROCESS WILL GET MORE
HOMES BUILT AND MORE AFFORDABLE
HOMES. FOR CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS SO FOR THAT -- FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
THREE THIRTY SILVIO FOR HIM TO
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT.
SIMONA THOMPSON ROSAMOND
SUPPORTED THE BILL.
LOUIS MANTE WITH CALIFORNIA
BEING VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY IS SPACE SILICON
VALLEY ALSO IN SUPPORT.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN I'M HAVE A BRIDGE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
A RUBBER COATED IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JEFF MORGAN PRESIDENT FIRST
COMMITTEE HOUSING IN SAN JOSE
SUPPORT.
MARJORIE MURRAY CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS.
LOG IN SUPPORT.
ALLEN J. CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LOCAL HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
MATTHEW HARPER THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THEN ALL WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR JASON
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES --
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE -- LAST TIME WHEN I
PRESENTED IN I BELIEVE HIS
GOVERNMENT'S FINANCE WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SOME OF OUR
MAIN CONCERNS AND WE CERTAINLY
DO NOT DISPUTE OR OR YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW DEBATE WHETHER NOW
WE'RE HOUSING CRISIS WE
CERTAINLY ARE AND WHEN YOU GO TO
GREAT LENGTHS IN OUR HELP
ADDRESS THAT.
WE IS BELIEVE THAT APPROACH IS
BEING TAKEN IN THIS BILL I'M NOT
ALL OF THE APPROACHES BUT THE
MAINLY THE PURCHASE OF MY TOUCH
ON HERE BRIEFLY -- ARE OF
CONCERN AND WE THINK PERHAPS
THERE'S A THERE'S A BETTER WAY
OF DOING IT -- WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FEES AND FREEZING FEEDS FOR
A DECADE I MEAN A DECADE IS IS A
LONG TIME -- AND THESE FEES ARE
IN PLACE FOR A WHOLE HOST OF
REASONS AND THOSE FEES HAVE BEEN
YOU KNOW PUT IN PLACE BASED ON
THE MITIGATION FEE ACTOR PROP --
TWO EIGHTEEN OR WHATEVER MAY BE
AND WE CAN ONLY CHARGE WHAT CASA
DELIVER THAT SERVICE I'M CITIES
ARE FEES THAT ARE THAT ARE MEANT
TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE TO THE
RESIDENTS ARE GONNA DEMAND --
SOME OF THE AND IN SOME OF THESE
FEES AND IF YOU LIMITS OF THESE
FEES ARE CAP THOSE FEES -- FOR
IT FOR A DECADE IT'S REALLY
CROSS PURPOSES WITH WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE TOLD US TO DO.
LAST TIME I SPOKE ABOUT RENT
CONTROL AND AND ACTUALLY
MENTIONED THAT THE SUPERFLUOUS
FROM GENERATE CONTROL IT DOESN'T
DO THAT BUT IT'S CERTAINLY A
PRECLUDES US FROM IMPOSING
INCLUSION HOUSING REQUIREMENTS
FOR DECADES OF THE CITY DOESN'T
HAVE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING NOW.
WE COULDN'T DO THAT -- BUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PASSED AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE THAT CLARIFIED SOME THIS
IS A REALLY TO RENTAL HOUSING.
AND IT'S A POLICY THE STATE THE
YEAH WE WANT TO SEE INCLUSIONARY
THAT'S A WAY FOR US TO GET
AFFORDABLE UNITS BUILT OUR
CMMUNITY.
THIS WOULD CERTAINLY PAS THAT
FOR A DECADE AND WE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
SOME OF OUR JURISDICTIONS EVEN
GONE AS FAR AS WEAVING SOME OF
THESE FEES ON THEIR OWN AND
PAYING FOR IT OUT OF THERE
GENERAL FUND.
THE CITY IS CURRENTLY DOING THAT
SAY FOR EXCESS RECALLING UNITS
THAT THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT AS
OUR GENERAL FUND.
THAT DECADE IF THERE'S A
DOWNTURN IN THE ECONOMY THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO REIMPOSE
THOSE FEES -- SINCE EVEN COVER
AMOUNT OF THEIR AND OTHER
GENERAL FUND SO YOU KNOW WE WE
THINK FREEZE INDUSTRIES FOR
DECADE IS IS IS A LITTLE TOO
BROAD FOR EVERY JURISDICTION WE
DON'T THINK THAT SHE HAS A GOOD
CASE.
IT REALLY IS A JURISDICTIONS AT
THE RIVER THAT FALL UNDER THIS
BILL.
NOW WITH REGARD TO PARKING WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE AMENDED
ON PARKING THAT ARE REALLY ONLY
PERTAINS TO THE QUARTER MILE --
FROM TRANSIT OR YOU COULD HAVE A
SPOT IF YOU'RE BEYOND THAT --
DIDN'T PORTENT THING TO NOTE
ABOUT PARKING AS PRIDE ONE THING
THAT WE FIGHT OVER THE MOST I
THINK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS
PARKING PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO GET FOLKS
OUT OF THE CAR SIR POLICIES IN
PLACE AT THE STATE LEVEL TO GET
PEOPLE OTHER CARS BUT IT WAS
GIVEN OF THE CAR.
SO WE ALWAYS HAVE TO BALANCE
THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND THE
SENATOR YOU MENTIONED THE THE
LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT SAVES
WHEN WE DON'T IMPOSE PARKING
FARMS ARE DEVELOPER.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL DOESN'T
CAPTURE THAT SO AT A MINIMUM I
WOULD THINK THAT IF THE STATE
WANTS TO NOT ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS IMPOSE PARKING OR
RESTRICT THAT PARKING.
THAT THERE'S AT LEAST SOME
DEMONSTRATION ON THE DEVELOPERS
AND THAT THE COST OF THE
DEVELOPMENT IS EITHER GONE DOWN
ORDER SOME SORT OF AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENT IT JUST SEEMS THAT
IT MAKES SENSE SO WE WANT TO
CAPTURE THAT.
BECAUSE OF NOT DEVELOPERS OR
LIKELY THESE THOSE ARE FOR
PROFIT WE'RE GONNA MAKE MORE
MONEY BECAUSE ARE UNDER NO
OBLIGATION TO TO LOWER THE COST
WE ALSO HAVE AN AMOUNT OF TIME
THERE'S A ONE QUICK LITTLE
LASTING SAY.
THE INITIAL COMPLETE APPLICATION
I THINK -- MY COLLEAGUES PRETTY
PIECE FOR YOU TALK ABOUT THAT --
BUT THAT'S A NEW ISSUE IN THE
BILL A NEW CONCEPT AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT SINCE EACH CD WILL
DETERMINE WHAT IS OR WHAT
INFORMATION IS INCLUDED IT TO
MAKE IT COMPLETE THE APPLICATION.
THEY'RE GONNA DO THAT OUTSIDE OF
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT WHICH MEANS YOU CAN JUST DO
IT HOWEVER THEY WANT WITHOUT ANY
INPUT WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE.
CITY GEORGIA PRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
SHE THE OTHER STAFF WORKING WITH
US -- IN FACT SHE'S PROBABLY
GONNA GET OUR ATTORNEYS TOGETHER
WITH THEIR ATTORNEYS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DOING THAT WE DO HAVE
A NUMBER A SUBSTANTIVE REMAINING
ISSUES.
I THINK A LOT OF THE PIECES OF
THE BILL ARE SUPPORTED BY A PA --
INCLUDING THE FREEZE ON
INITIATIVE IMPOSE LIMITATIONS
ELIMINATING REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOCAL VOTER APPROVAL FROM SOME
HOUSING DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE.
LIMITING RESPONSES ON EVERY VICE
APPLICATION TO THOSE ON THE
CHECKLIST OF PREVENT THE TWO
BITES AT THE APPLE.
AN ALTERNATIVE NO NET LOSS
PROCESSES AND ALTERNATIVE TO A
COMPLETE BAN ON CHANGES TO A
LESS INTENSIVE USE.
AND CLARIFICATION ON THE SEQUEL
INTERACTION ALL THOSE THE
AMENDMENTS WELL LONG WAY TO
ISSUES ADDRESSED SOME OF OUR
MORE TECHNICAL ISSUES.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
SUBSTANTIVE CONCERNS AND THE ONE
JUST MENTIONED BY THE LEAGUE --
THE NEW LAYER OF A COMPLETE
INITIAL APPLICATION.
THE E. DEFINITION OF THAT.
DOES NOT INCLUDE ENOUGH
INFORMATION FOR THE JURISDICTION
DEAVER EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THINGS COULD BE APPLIED OR
SHOULD BE APPLIED.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT IS VERY VERY CLEAR BEFORE
WE GET -- ONE OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS BUT WE DON'T THINK
IT'S NECESSARY TO ADDITIONAL.
AT LAYER OF PROCESS WHEN
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO STREAMLINE
THE PROCESS SO WE DO THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE -- ELIMINATED
FROM THE BILL -- THE RETROACTIVE
FREEZE DATES FOR A LOT OF
REQUIREMENTS ON THE OFF THE
TABLE INCLUDING ALL THE HOUSING
BILLS THAT WERE SIGNED A LAW
LAST YEAR INCLUSIONARY ZONING IF
THEY HAVE AN ADOPTED.
ONE EVEN SOME OF THE ATTEMPTS
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL TO MAKE
OBJECTIVE DESIGN REVIEW
STANDARDS ALL THOSE THINGS COULD
BE DETERMINED TO INCREASE THE
COST OF HOUSING EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE MEANT TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS.
OF THE LIMITING THE DESIGN
STANDARDS IF THEY'RE MORE COSTLY
AND EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST.
THAT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT I
THINK INCLUDES THINGS THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE ON THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF WHERE THE AUTHOR WANTS TO BE
IN THE END.
THE AFFORDABLE ROGUE
REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE EXPANDED
STREAMLINING THE BILL -- AND
WERE ALSO VERY CONCERNED WITH
THE ARBITRARY NUMBER OF HEARINGS
VERTICALLY FOR LARGE PROJECTS
GOING FROM TWO TO FIVE IS
DEFINITELY BETTER -- WE DO NOT
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH A MALE A
MAXIMUM OF TWELVE MONTHS FOR THE
PERMIT STREAMLINING ACT.
BUT THAT'S BETTER THAN AN
ARBITRARY LIMIT ON THE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS VERTICALLY FOR LARGE
PROJECTS IN PARTICULAR WHEN
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE HEARING TO SEE BECAUSE
YOU DON'T END UP IN COURT.
SO THOSE ARE THE CAN SCAN
TENURED ISSUES THAT WE HAVE.
HE'S OUT THERE YEAH.
OKAY AND THE DIVERSITY CREDIT
OKAY AWESOME THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
THE BILL PLEASE CONFIRM.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE A POSITION OF
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ARE
CONCERNED THE BILL IS IN
RELATION TO THE TEMPORARY
MORATORIUM THAT WOULD BE PLACED
ON CONNECTION FEES INCAPACITY
CHARGES -- I'D LIKE TO JUST
REITERATE THE COMMENTS JUST MADE
A AND REGARDS THOSE FEES AND THE
STRAIGHT CONSTITUTIONAL AND
STATUTORY LIMITS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST.
I DO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFFERS CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE IF WE ARE ABLE TO DRESS SO
WE DON'T KNOW FOR THEIR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CARE ALSO BE UP THE
CITY OF SALON A BEACH IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR ROSS.
THANK YOU MISTER I GUESS SINCE
EVERYBODY DISAPPEARED FROM THE
TABLE IN FRONT OF ME -- AS THE
OTHER THIS QUESTION.
THE THE LEAGUE FOR EXAMPLE IS
SAYS OBJECTED TO THE FREEZE ON
IMPACT FEES. FOR THE TEN YEAR
PERIOD REFERENCING THE FACT THAT
IT'S A VERY LONG TIME -- AND
ALSO AS A SUPPOSED PROVING
DESIGN STANDARDS OF MORE COSTLY
HAVE THERE BEEN ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSALS OFFERED BY THE LEAGUE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OBJECTIONS NO ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSALS HAVE BEEN OFFERED
TODAY.
CENTER THERE ALSO.
YES SENATOR -- WE RECENTLY HAD
IN LOS ANGELES SOME.
LOCAL MEASURES PASSED AROUND
HOUSING BOTH HOMELESS AND LOW
INCOME HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING -- IT'S WOULD OVERRIDE
ALL OF A WHAT WOULD BE THE
IMPACT ON LOCAL MEASURES PASSED
BY CITIES OR COUNTIES THE ONLY --
MEASURES THAT A CITY OR COUNTY
MAY OF ENACTED IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT THIS WOULD
AFFECT IN THIS WOULD ONLY BE
ONES ENACTED IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS WOULD BE IF THEY ENACTED
DOWN ZONING -- FOR IF ENACTED A
HOUSING CAP.
ANOTHER WORDS HE SAID WERE YOU
KNOW WE WILL NOT ALLOW ANY MORE
THAN THIS MANY UNITS OF HOUSING.
AND TO MY KNOWLEDGE THE CITY OF
LA IS NOT DONE EITHER OF THOSE --
SO.
IT WOULD NOT -- EFFECT DOES IT
DOESN'T HAVE ANY ANY ACTION ON
FOR EXAMPLE DENSITY BONUSES
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING -- IMPACT
FEES OTHER THAN THE FROM THIS
FROM WHATEVER IT GOES INTO
EFFECT HOLDING THOSE.
AT THE FEET LEVEL.
WOULD ALL BE RESPECTED.
UNDER THE BILL [inaudible]
CENTER CABALLERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
ON THE IT.
COUPLE QUESTIONS THE THE THE
LEAGUE IN -- TALKED ABOUT
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING AND THEN
FEES THAT ARE BEING PAID.
FOR FOR FROM THE GENERAL FUND --
HEY MIKE MY GUESS IS THAT'S NOT
THE INTENTION OF YOUR BILL
BECAUSE AS I READ IT THE WHOLE
PURPOSE MAN I RAN A A BILL
SIMILAR I THINK YOU DID IT MUCH
MORE ELOQUENTLY IN YOUR BILL --
THAN I DID LAST YEAR -- BUT THE
INTENTION IS THAT YOU KNOW GOING
IN WHAT IT'S GOING TO COST YOU
TO BUILD THE UNIT AND THEN IT
DOESN'T SPIRAL AND SKYROCKET --
BASED ON JUST.
KIND OF FACTORS THAT NO ONE CAN
FIGURE OUT RIGHT SO -- WHAT'S
YOUR ANALYSIS IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER -- THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
WOULD.
PROHIBIT.
THE JURISDICTION FROM ADOPTING
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING ORDINANCE
IN THE IN THE IN TRUMP -- IN IN
BOTH THE DIRECTION TO LEAD
COUNSEL WHO OF COURSE DRAFT
THESE BILLS FOR US AND TO THE
EXPERTS THAT I'VE INTERACTED
WITH. TO DESIGN THIS BILL -- IT
WAS NEVER OUR INTENTION TO
PRECLUDE INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
AND IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
DOES NOT.
SO UNTIL.
AM THE THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
ASSERTED THIS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
SAN FINANCE COMMITTEE I WENT
BACK TO THE INDIVIDUALS WHO --
HELPED CONSTRUCT THE BILL TO DO
TO GET THEIR OPINION AS TO
WHETHER IT.
PRECLUDED EXCLUSION INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING.
AND THEY ALL SAID NO SO I AM
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES.
TO TRY TO IDENTIFY IN WHAT WAY
THEY BELIEVE THAT SO BECAUSE
EVEN WHEN WE WENT BACK TO LEDGE
COUNCIL TO GET THEIR OPINION
THEY WERE LIKE NO DOESN'T.
SO BUT CLEARLY AS WE KNOW YOU
GET ANY NUMBER OF LAWYERS IN A
ROOM THEY'RE GONNA SOMETIMES
DISAGREE BUT I'M HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH THEM BECAUSE IT IS NOT
OUR INTENTION TO PRECLUDE
INCLUSIONARY HOUSING WHATSOEVER --
THE FREEZE ON FEES FOR TEN YEARS --
EASY I CAN APPRECIATE WHY --
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT -- BUT IT'S ALSO ONE
OF THOSE FACTORS WHERE.
I DIDN'T SEE THIS MY OPENING BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR
JURISDICTIONS HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
BY FIRE EARTHQUAKE.
IT IS VERY VERY COMMON AFTER A
LARGE LOSS OF UNITS DUE TO THESE
KIND OF DISASTERS THAT THE
JURISDICTION RELAXES RULES
SUSPENDS RULES AND LOWERS FEES
OR FREEZES FEES.
AGAIN TO HELP GET THAT HOUSING
REPLACED QUICKLY.
SO WE ARE IN A WE'VE IN FACT HAD
A FIRE OVER THE WHOLE STATE EVEN
THOUGH WE DIDN'T DESTROYER UNITS
WE DIDN'T BUILD ENOUGH.
SO MMHM THE APPROACH OF THE BILL
IS.
TO WITH HIS TO SAY LOOK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS YOU'VE ALREADY DONE
ALL THIS PLANNING AND ALL THIS --
DINO SEQUEL WORK EVERYTHING AND
YOU'VE ALLOWED SO MUCH HOUSING
BUT THERE'S BUILT IN SO MANY
DELAYS AND SO MANY COSTS AND SO
MANY OTHER IMPEDIMENTS.
IT ISN'T BEING PRODUCED FAST
ENOUGH AND SINCE WE'RE IN THIS
HORRIBLE CRISIS LET'S PRODUCE A
FASTER SO LET'S RELAX THINGS A
LITTLE BIT.
AND JUST SPEEDED UP IN JUST FOR
TEN YEAR PERIOD AND SEE IF WE
CAN'T GET BACK INTO BALANCE OF
THAT'S REALLY.
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL AND AS
YOU POINTED OUT CERTAIN OF THESE
THINGS ALLOW FOR THE PERSON
BUILDING HOUSING AND I DON'T SEE
DEVELOPER BECAUSE HE COULD BE
SOMEBODY JUST OWNS ONE LOT.
IT YOU KNOW JUST IT ALLOWS THEM
TO KNOW OKAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT
FIVE YEARS OR TEN YEARS.
AND THESE NEW THINGS ARE GOING
TO BE ADDED SO MY COST ESTIMATES
OTHER THAN IF CONCRETE PRICES GO
WAY UP OR SOMETHING YOU KNOW MY
COST ESTIMATES ARE PRETTY
ACCURATE.
OKAY SO THEN THE SECOND QUESTION
I DO YOU MAY HAVE ANSWERED THIS
IS THAT -- USUALLY IF IF FEES
ARE GOING TO GO UP YOU'VE DONE
THE VIEW SPENT AS A PERIOD OF
TIME.
UP DOING THE STUDIES RIGHT AND
YOU CAN SEE THEM COMING AND SO
THE JURISDICTIONS THAT I WAS
INVOLVED IN.
ARE THE JURISDICTIONS IN THE
REGION WOULD SAY WOULD TELL
DEVELOPERS GEAR COMING IN WE'RE
WE'VE GOT THESE NEW TRAFFIC
IMPACT FEES ARE WE'VE GOT THESE
THESE NEW.
PARK FEES OR WHATEVER AND BOB
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO
THEM AT AND IF YOU DON'T GET IT
DONE BY IF YOU DON'T A STARTED
BY A CERTAIN DATE -- ADMITS
ASSUMING THAT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
INTENDING TO TO FREEZE FOR THOSE
THAT TEN YEAR PERIOD.
YES AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD
NOTE IS THAT IF WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
CURRENTLY -- PUT BEFORE US WOULD
NOT ADOPTED IT YET.
BUT HE IS OFFERING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS -- HE'S HE'S
OFFERING STATE MONEY INVESTMENT
FOR THEM TO BRING.
THEIR THEIR PERMIT PROCESS SEES
TO BRING VARIOUS PLANNING PRESS
SEIZE UP TO DATE IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE HOUSING.
SO.
WHILE IT MAY NOT MEET
[inaudible]
THE WHAT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MIGHT WANT TO INCREASE THE FEE
FOR OVER THIS TEN YEAR PERIOD
IT'S CERTAINLY THE STATE IS NOT
ABANDONING THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WERE OFFERING IF WE ADOPT THAT.
WE ARE OFFERING THEM SOME
SUPPORT.
AGAIN TO TRY TO FACILITATE
HOUSING.
I SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK IT'S
IT'S A GOOD BILL I ENCOURAGE YOU --
TO OF WORK ON SOME OF THESE
DETAILS I THINK THEY'RE THE
RESOLVABLE -- AND I BUT WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU AT COLLEAGUES ANY
OTHER COMMON CENTER BATES I DO
NOT HAVE AND I AM HAD PROBLEMS
WITH A NUMBER OF THE HOUSING.
BILLS THAT HAVE FUN REDUCE
PARKING REQUIRES BECAUSE IN MY
COMMUNITY -- PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAME A BIG ISSUE WITH.
LOWERING OF PARKING REQUIREMENTS
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS WHERE THERE
A LOT OF CHILDREN.
AND PEOPLE PARK THEIR CARS AND
THE KIDS GO BETWEEN HIM AND WE
HAD TWO VERY UNFORTUNATE.
DEATHS OF CHILDREN IN OUR
COMMUNITY OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE
OF THAT SO THING VERY ODD THING
COMFORTABLE MAKING IT KIND OF
COOKIE CUTTER.
A SECOND LEAD THE DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES THAT I REMEMBER WE
IMPOSE STYLE OUT THE COUNTY.
OF ORANGE HAD A LOT TO DO WITH
THE RISING COST OF EMPLOYEES
ESPECIALLY IN CODE ENFORCEMENT
WHERE YOU HAVE TO EXPAND IN AN
S. WERE INCREASING THE
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE BUILDING OF
HOUSING YOU'RE GONNA NEED MORE
CODE ENFORCERS.
AND CERTAINLY THE LOW SALARIES
REYES AND OVER TEN YEARS I WOULD
HOPE THAT THIS STUDY IS GOING TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING THAT IS
COMPARABLE TO HOW THE US
INCREASE PUBLIC SAFETY COSTS
ACOSTA LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN YOU HAVE A MULTI MULTI
FAMILY?
THE FEES REALLY REFLECT THE NEED
FOR MORE LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ABIDING BY THE LAWS
NO PARKING ALL OF THAT.
HELLO SIR -- SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE WITH A
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH THAT
IMPLIED THAT MANDATES THIS ON
ALL CITIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT -- SO I I HOLD
THAT'LL BE SOME FLEXIBILITY AS
WE GO FORWARD PUBLIC SAFETY IS
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST ISSUE LOCAL.
COMMUNITIES I AND THAT'S WHERE
HUGE COSTS ARE NOW PUTTING MANY
OF OUR CITIES IN JEOPARDY AND
THE IMPACT FEES ARE SPECIFICALLY
TO HELP OUT.
SO -- YOU NEED TO TAKE I THINK A
DEEPER DIVE ON THAT AND I KNOW
WHEN THE CITY COMES FORWARD.
THE INFLATIONARY -- YOU KNOW
INDEX IS GOING TO HELP WITH THAT.
BUT THIS IS PRETTY FAR REACHING
OUT LASTLY MY HUSBAND'S AN
ARCHITECT HAS DONE A LOT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
IN TO ENSURE THOSE DO NOT BECOME.
GATAL LIKE AMENITIES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT -- OTHERWISE YOU
CREATE CONCRETE JUNGLES NAY
WITHOUT SOME WAY BACK WHEN AND
THAT THAT'S WHAT THE BECAME I
WORK THE PROJECTS IN LA FOR AT
LEAST.
YOU KNOW WHAT FIVE SIX YEARS
WHEN I WAS SOCIAL WORKER AND
THOSE PROJECTS NEEDED MANY MORE
AMENITIES SO THAT YOU HAD.
MORE ON A HIGHER STANDARD OF
LIVING SO WHEN YOU START
CREATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT HAVE NO AMENITIES
BECAUSE YOU'VE TAKEN AWAY IMPACT
FEES YOU'RE STARTING TO CREATE.
A PROBLEM GOING FORWARD AND THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT
FINALLY THE ODD DESIGN STANDARDS
WE'VE JUST IMPOSE A LOT OF
DESIGN STANDARDS BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE WE WE REQUIRING
SOLAR AND WE KNOW THAT
1-500-022-0000 DOLLARS IN UNIT.
THAT FOUGHT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
CONSIDERED -- IN THIS BILL AND I
THINK YOU KNOW THEY'RE ALMOST
GOT CONTRADICTORY IF YOU WANT
DESIGN STANDARDS THAT OF THAT
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE.
HIM THEN WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
THOSE ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
THEY PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
OUT.
SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS I'M
GONNA VOTE NO TODAY.
BUT I KNOW EVERYONE'S WORKING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TRYING TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING SO I JUST
LIKE YOU TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THOSE.
RATHER RIGID COOKIE CUTTER KIND
OF APPROACHES TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO TO DEVELOP MORE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING THINKS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HERE THANK YOU.
SO FIRST THE BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT EVERY.
AREA EVERY GEOGRAPHIC AREA IN
THE STATE.
THE IT'S TARGETED AND I'M
POLICIES THAT I DID NOTSPECIFY
THAT IT IS TARGETED AND ELLIE --
HAS CREATED A EXCEL SPREADSHEET
FOR US.
THAT I CAN SHARE WITH ANY
OFFICES THAT CHOOSE -- TO THAT
WOULD SHOW WHAT TIMES
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE AFFECTED
AND THE CRITERIA ARE.
VACANCY RATE.
SO VERY VERY LOW VACANCY RATES
AND THEN THE EITHER HOUSING THE
EITHER PRICE OF HOMES FOR RENTAL
INCREASE PERCENT INCREASE SO HE
REALLY IS TARGETED TOWARDS THOSE
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
THE MOST BY COST.
AND VACANCY AND IT IT WOULD
AFFECT THOSE SECONDARILY.
IT RESPECTS THE DESIGN REVIEW
STANDARDS AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ALREADY YES IT DOES
NOT REVERSE THOSE AT ALL SO WHEN
YOU DESIGN REVIEW THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WOULD STAY INTACT -- IT
ALSO REFLECTS RESPECTS ALL OF
THE IMPACT FEES THAT ARE EXIST
RIGHT NOW WOULD ONLY BE ONCE IT
WENT INTO EFFECT FOR THAT SUNSET
PERIOD DO NOT INCREASE THEM --
IT IN THE PARKING MINIMUM THIS
ONE EIGHT EIGHT SO -- IT'S ONE
OF THOSE HARD ONES WERE THE BILL
DOES NOT FOR BID PARKING.
AND WITH THE AMENDMENTS WITH
GOVERNMENT AND FINANCE IT ONLY
LISTS THE REQUIRED PARKING
MINIMUM WITHIN A QUARTER MILE OF
TRANSIT.
AND IT EXEMPTS SMALL AND RURAL
CITIES SO ANYWHERE ELSE THE
PARKING MINIMUM STAY NOW I WOULD
HAVE PREFERRED TO LIFT THE
PARKING MINIMUMS.
WHICH WOULD STILL ALLOW IF
YOU'RE BUILDING THE HOUSING AND
YOU FEEL THAT YOU MUST HAVE THAT
PARKING IT WOULD STILL ALLOW YOU
TO PUT THAT PARKING IN.
THE CHEST WOULD BE IF YOU WERE
BUILDING HOUSING AND FELT THAT
THE HOUSING COULD -- BE
SUPPORTED WITHOUT THE PARKING
BUT AS GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
WHICH I'VE.
ACCEPTED IT IS NOW ONLY WITHIN A
QUARTER MILE OF TRANSIT AND ITS
HIGH FREQUENCY TRANSIT SO --
THAT MAY NOT ADDRESS ALL OF YOUR
CONCERNS BUT AT LEAST I WANTED
TO LAY THOSE OUT BECAUSE THEY'RE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN --
WAS CHARACTERIZED.
WELL THANK YOU FINISH SKINNER
WHAT I REALLY LIKE IS THAT YOUR
FAST TRACKING.
IT OUT THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT SO
THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY -- I WANT TO REALLY THANKS --
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I THINK ONE OF THE
MOST COMMON CRITICS OF BILLS
AGAIN THE LEGISLATURE -- WHICH I
THINK IS ALSO ONE OF CRITIQUE
THAT I HOPE WE DO AWAY WITH ONE
DAY AS WELL THIS BILL REALLY
DOES A LOT.
AND A AND MEN AS A CRITICISM
SOMETIMES WHILE YOUR BILL DOES A
LOT OF STUFF.
AS YOU THINK IT'S A COMPLIMENT --
THAT THIS BILL IN A WE HAVE A
TERRIBLE HOUSING CRISIS ON OUR
HANDS -- AND THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY GETTING A VERY TANGIBLE
SPECIFIC -- SOMETIMES ABUSES.
IN THE CASE OF PUTTING A HOUSING
MORATORIUM OR A POPULATION COP
IT CETERA.
WARS -- ITUATIONS WHERE FEES
ARE PUT IN PLACE.
BETTER SO HIGH THAT ENDS UP
MAKING DEVELOPMENT IN FEASIBLE
AND PARTICULARLY. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE --
YOU CAN REALLY SEE A PROJECT TO
DEATH -- SERVICES -- HAVING A
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL AND AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR --
FOR HER WORK I KNOW THE AUTHORS
TAKING AS AUTHOR AMENDMENTS THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
AMENDMENTS.
AND OUR STAFF WILL OF COURSE
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE AS A
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO WORK AND
PROVIDE SUPPORT AND SOME
RECOMMENDING AND I BOTH -- AS
AMENDED.
BY POLITICIANS ARE AWESOME YES
NO PROBLEM -- I JUST WANT TO
SUGGEST I KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
INCLUDE THESE BIG POTS OF MONEY
THAT WERE A LOT OF DETAIL HAS
NOT BEEN INCLUDED.
AND I RAISE THE ISSUE UNDER THE
OF THE CATEGORY OF INCENTIVIZING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THIS MADE AND I'M TRYING TO PUSH
FOR THAT THE INCENTIVES SHOULD
BE CONNECTED TO HOUSING NOT JUST
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REAL TO
USE THAT WHATEVER HOWEVER THEY
WANT.
BUT I'M I BELIEVE THEY SHOULD BE
CONNECTED TO THE HOUSING. TO BE
ABLE TO ALLOW MORE HOUSING SO I
THINK THE FEES ISSUE HERE.
COULD BE ONE OF THOSE WAYS IN
WHICH THE INCENTIVES TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A WOULD MEAN
SOMETHING TO THEM.
AND IT WOULD ALSO HELP ON THE
HOUSING.
FOR THINKING.
THANK YOU OKAY -- SENATOR
SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE RIGHT.
TO HAVE A MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AS AMENDED.
YEAH.
THE RECOVERY ARMY THE MOTION
GREAT -- WITHOUT WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS ISN'T A BILL THREE THIRTY
BY SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL. FOR L. NO BATES.
BATES KNOW CAMARO.
CAMARO HI DORADO.
DRUGS SO I AM A CHOIR.
CHOIR HI MORE LOCK.
ROUGH.
PROF BY A SKINNER BY SKINNER AYE
NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE WITH HUSKY.
BECAUSE HE AYE.
OKAY THE VOTE IS A TO TO THAT'S
ENOUGH TO PASS OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN -- WE ONLY HAVE TEN TODAY.
THIS IS.
YOUR NUMBER IN MY APOLOGIES OF
OVER MISSING SOMEONE -- THAT
BILL.
THE BILL IS OUTLETS [inaudible]
OKAY -- OKAY.
SENATOR RUBIO.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB.
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SB SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN A BILL TO INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS.
DIVERT SITTING EQUITY OF
HOMELESS POLICIES BY INCLUDING
COLLEGE STUDENTS VETERANS AND
PARENTS WITH LIVE HOMELESS
EXPERIENCES IN THE STATE'S
EFFORT TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESS CRISIS.
THE HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNSEL SERVES AS A
STATEWIDE FACILITATOR
COORDINATOR AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT RESOURCE ON ENDING
THE HOMELESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE COUNCIL IS MADE UP OF
SEVENTY MEMBERS REPRESENTING
GOVERNMENTAL DEPARTMENTS
STAKEHOLDER ORGANIZATIONS AND
ONLY TWO MEMBERS WOULD LIVED
EXPERIENCES ONE FORMERLY
HOMELESS PERSON AND ONE HOMELESS
YOUTH -- COLLEGE STUDENTS
VETERANS AND PARENTS MAKE UP A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION WITH IN CALIFORNIA
ACCORDING TO RECENT STUDIES
NEARLY 20% OF COLLEGE.
STUDENTS 11% OF S. C. S. U. I'M
SORRY S. CSU STUDENTS AND 5% OF
YOU SEE STUDENTS HAVE REPORTED
INCIDENTS OF BEING HOMELESS.
FURTHERMORE THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF VETERAN AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES THAT MORE THAN ELEVEN
THOUSAND OF THE NATION'S
HOMELESS VETERANS LIVING
CALIFORNIA.
ADDITIONALLY THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT REPORTS THE FAMILIES
ACCOUNT 460% OF THE STATE'S
TOTAL HOMELESS.
POPULATION EACH OF THESE NEW
APPOINTEES WILL BRING TO YOU A
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE TO HELP
ADDRESS THE CALIFORNIA HOMELESS
CRISIS HERE WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IS SHEMONA THOMPSON OF
FORMALLY HOMELESS COLLEGE
STUDENT A MOTHER WHO IS HERE TO
SHARE.
HER HOMELESS EXPERIENCE THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS SIMONA THOMPSON
ROSS AND I AM PROUD TO BE HERE
TO TESTIFY THIS PERSON.
THE SENATE BILL -- SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO -- TODAY
I'M HERE TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCE
OF HOMELESSNESS.
MY FIRST EXPERIENCE WITH
HOMELESSNESS WAS WHEN I WAS A
TEENAGER -- AT THAT TIME I
DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
RESOURCES ARE PLACES TO GO -- MY
NEXUS VARIANCE WAS A FEW YEARS
LATER AS A SINGLE MOTHER WITH OF
TO ONCE AGAIN.
I DIDN'T I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
RESOURCES FOR SHELTER -- I AM
CURRENTLY ON THE HOUSING VOUCHER
PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
SECTION.
EIGHT THIS PROGRAM IS DESIGNED
TO HELP FAMILIES WITH THE COST
OF LIVING.
UNFORTUNATELY -- WAR I STARTED
WAS IN PLASTER COUNTY AND WHEN I
WANTED TO TRANSFER INTO
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I HAD TO GO BE
HOMELESS IN ORDER TO TRANSFER --
I WAS HOMELESS FOR SIX MONTHS.
BEFORE I FOUND A PLACE --
BECAUSE NO ONE WANTED TO RENT TO
SOMEONE ON SECTION.
EIGHT WHEN I FINALLY FOUND A
HOME THE OWNER DECIDED TO SELL
HIS HOME FOR MONTHS LATER --
ONCE AGAIN I WAS ON THE VERGE OF
BEING HOMELESS AGAIN -- PLEASE
ME [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M CURRENTLY A SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
LAST YEAR WITH MY FIRST SEMESTER --
IN JULY.
OF LAST YEAR I FOUND OUT I HAD
BREAST CANCER -- BEFORE THE
SEMESTER STARTED AND I HAD TO
HAVE A BILATERAL MASTECTOMY --
ALTHOUGH I WASN'T FULLY HILL
WHEN THE SEMESTER STARTED I
DECIDED TO GO TO SCHOOL ANYWAY.
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE
ANY REGRETS ABOUT NOT ATTENDING
SCHOOL.
MY FIRST SEMESTER I TOOK
THIRTEEN UNITS AND I HAD TO WORK
THREE JOBS TO CATCH UP.
FROM -- THE BILLS -- PILING UP
WHILE I WAS HEALING.
I DO PRETTY WELL -- GOING TO
SCHOOL I DON'T GET SICK TO THE
END OF THE SEMESTER AND
EVERYBODY WAS TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE ME.
TO SETTLE DOWN.
BUT I'M VERY PROUD OF MYSELF I
GOT A FOUR POINT NO ON MY FIRST
SEMESTER -- DUE TO MY HEALTH IN
HAPPEN TO STEP BACK THIS
SEMESTER I DECIDED TO JUST WORK
ONE JOB.
AND TAKE TWELVE UNITS -- I WORK
TWENTY HOURS A WEEK.
AND I'M TWELVE UNITS AFFECT
STAYED HOME.
IN JANUARY SECTION A INCREASE
MARIN FROM -- FOR SEVENTY TWO TO
FOURTEEN ELEVEN I DIDN'T HAVE
THE INCOME TO PAY THE HIGH COST
OF LIKE EVERYTHING TOGETHER SO
RIGHT NOW I'M IN THE PROCESS OF
WORKING WITH THEM OR YOU KNOW
TRYING TO GET THEM THE LOWER THE
RANT -- SO MY UTILITIES AND
EVERYTHING THAT I WAS PAYING
WITH THAT FOURTEEN HUNDRED THE
ADDITIONAL -- MONEY IS NOW.
TAKEN AWAY AND I CAN'T AFFORD TO
PAY MY UTILITIES.
BUT THE LANDLORD BECAUSE OF THE
DIFFICULTIES -- IN THE PROCESS
THIS IS HER FIRST TIME.
I CAN BE AT RISK OF BEING
HOMELESS AGAIN -- I HAVE TO TAKE
SCHOOL LOANS OUT -- TO TO GO TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE I CAN'T AFFORD TO
PAY FOR SCHOOL.
HOME.
AND I'M STILL WORKING WITH AS I
SAY WITH HOME WITH US SECTION A
TRYING TO GET THEM TO LOWER THE
RATE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING FOR ME
RIGHT NOW IS TO KEEP OVER MY
KEEP A ROOF OVER MY FAMILY'S
HEAD.
I HAVE RESEARCH PAPERS TO DO AND
I'M STRUGGLING TO FOCUS ON MY
EDUCATION.
WHEN I HAVE TO THINK ABOUT RAIN
AND HOW I'M GOING TO PAY MY?
YOU KNOW -- BY FOOD INSTEAD SO --
MCCARTY SINCE IT WAS JUST
CANCELED IN -- I JUST I'M I'M
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE
NECESSITIES IN MY HOUSEHOLD --
IT'S REALLY AFFECTED MY
CONCENTRATION WHEN YOU HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT HOW YOU GONNA
FEATURE FAMILY AND KEEP A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD.
AT THE SAME TIME.
I'M VERY GRATEFUL.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE A
PLACE TO LIVE AND I KNOW THAT --
SOME PEOPLE HAVE TO SLEEP IN OUR
CARS AND SOME PEOPLE WHO HAVE
CARS TO SLEEP IN BUT THEY STILL
COME TO SCHOOL.
NAM I TRY TO MAINTAIN THAT
ATTITUDE OF GRATITUDE -- WHILE
ADVOCATING FOR OTHERS.
THEIR STRUGGLE JUST LIKE ME -- I
HAVE AN EIGHT YEAR OLD SON.
WHO -- I DON'T WANT THE STRUGGLE
TO AFFECT.
ON HIS NEW REALIZE WE DON'T HAVE
MONEY -- I COACHES BASKETBALL
TEAM.
ARE WE I'M HEADED THERE WHEN I
LEAVE HERE -- I DO A LOT OF WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY -- AND I'M
TRYING TO DEVELOP A LEADERSHIP
AND MENTORING PROGRAM RIGHT NOW
WITH THE TEAM AND THE COACHES
AND EVERYTHING.
IN SPITE OF MY SITUATION.
ALWAYS TRY TO TELL THE CHILDREN
THAT I'M COACHING.
THAT NO MATTER HOW HARD THINGS
GET.
YOU CAN NEVER GIVE A LIFE IS
GOING TO BE HARD.
SO -- I'M HERE TO SUPPORT --
SENATOR RUBIO.
BECAUSE IT WOULD INCLUDE VOICES
LIKE MINE.
PEOPLE WHO SHARE THE SAME
HOMELESS EX HOMELESSNESS
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS VERY
BRAVE AND AND REALLY GLAD THAT
THINGS ARE GOING BETTER FOR YOU
SO THANK YOU FOR SHARING TODAY
WE REALLY.
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE HI THIS BILL DOES
ENJOY A AND I RECOMMENDATION --
AND I WANT TO THANK US CENTER
RUBIO -- FOR FOCUSING ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
A CENTER WHICH HOUSES.
SORRY MR AND MAY HAVE MISSED IT
THE ON PAGE THREE OF THE STAFF
REPORT THE TALK ABOUT THE U. S..
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS.
WHICH DOESN'T INCLUDE -- CLUE
THAT CATEGORY OF HOMELESS
COLLEGE STUDENT AND WHETHER
GOING FORWARD YOU WOULD HAVE A
INCREASE THE PANEL.
TO NINETEEN THAT HELP THEM MEET
THE SUB POPULATIONS THE HOMELESS
COUNCIL REPORTS ON DID YOU HAVE
A WAS HE THAT SAID THAT'S THE
POINT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCES IN DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES HAVE THEIR THEIR
VOICES HEARD IN PARTICULAR.
AS IT PERTAINS TO COLLEGE
STUDENT AS YOU ALREADY HEARD THE
SOME OF THE STRUGGLES THAT
STUDENTS HAVE AS WELL AS
VETERANS.
AND UP HERE AND STILL THE POINT
OF THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT
EVERY SUB GROUP IS REPRESENTED A
TO GIVE US GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF
HOW TO INFORM OUR DECISIONS
MOVING FORWARD.
BUT I THOUGHT THE STAFF REPORT
ALSO SAYS THAT THE COUNCIL HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ON THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN COLLEGE STUDENT PURSES AT I
CLASS THAT.
THE AT LEAST UNITED STATES
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL DOESN'T.
ACKNOWLEDGE FOR DOESN'T POINT
OUT.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY SURE WHAT
YOU'RE READING THERE BUT RIGHT
NOW CURRENTLY WE DON'T HAVE A WE
ONLY HAVE -- WE HAVE A ONE
HOMELESS PERSON ONE FORMAL LEE
HOMELESS HUGHES NOT NECESSARY A
STUDENT SO THIS BILL INTENDS TO
ADD.
NOT ONLY A COLLEGE STUDENT BUT A
VETERAN AND AND OTHER VOICES
STILL NOT NECESSARY SURE WHAT
YOU'RE READING THEY'RE ABOUT TO
AGAIN THIS IS MEANT JUST TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE.
DIVERSE VOICES OF LIVED
EXPERIENCE SAYS TO TO BRING US
INFORMATION AS HOW WE CAN HELP
THEM MOVE FORWARD.
I'M NOT SURE I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION BUT I'M NOT SURE WHAT
I'M HERE I GUESS I GUESS IT'S IT
APPEARS AT THE STAFF REPORT SAYS
THAT THE FEDERAL UNITED STATES.
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL OF
HOMELESSNESS HAS A PLAN ADDED.
TO COMBAT HOMELESSNESS AND THEY
GO FOR VETERANS THE GO FOR THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS THE GO FOR
FAMILIES WITH CHILDREN THEY GO.
FOR UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH.
THEY SAY MOVING FORWARD YOU
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE JUST COLLEGE
STUDENTS IT COULD BE USED.
THEY COULD BE.
GRAHAM FOR FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN THOSE THOSE CATEGORIES
YOU DON'T HAVE A SEPARATE
CATEGORY LEAST UNITED STATES
HASN'T TARGETED THAT CATEGORY AS
SOMEBODY SAID.
I'M.
I JUST READ REPORT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU HAD.
YOU NOT IN PLANNING TO DO IT
HERE.
AND OKAY WELL THIS IS A AND AND
I'M SORRY I DON'T HAVE ONE OF MY
STUFF AND RESPONSIVE Là.
ALEX NOW AFTER THE PRESS.
I GUESS THE SHORTER ANSWERS
YOU'RE NOT PLANNING. TO
CONSIDERING HAVING IT --
CORRESPOND WITH EXISTING FEDERAL
LAW I GUESS THAT'S THE EASIER
WAY TO SAY IT.
WELL AT THIS POINT WE'RE JUST
FOCUSING ON WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO RIGHT NOW WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE THESE
VOICES ON THE PANEL SO WE'RE
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE.
VOICES AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
HOME IS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL. TO ADD THESE
VOICES TO OUR PANEL SO.
OKAY.
THAT'S THE BEST THAT I CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION THANK YOU.
JUDICIAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY AS I MENTIONED JOYS AND I
RECOMMENDATION AND CENTER WE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
NO I JUST WOULD LIKE TO THINK AS
YOU CAN SEE IT TAKES A LOT OF
COURAGE FOR SOMEONE THAT HAS HAD
SUCH AN EXPERIENCE TO COME
FORWARD AND SPEAK AND SO FOR SO
I THINK YOU. FOR FOR SHARING AND
JUDGES WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO US
FOR YOUR YES VOTE THANK YOU.
HI I DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION. TO BE GOOD THE STARS AND
THE PAST TWO APPROPRIATIONS.
OKAY -- MOTION BY CENTER
CABALLERO.
AND WILL CALLER.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL BATES RIGHT
BATES I CAMARO.
GABRIEL I'D DORADO.
DRUGS SO I MCGUIRE.
WHERE I AM MORE LOOK?
MORE LIKE AYE ROTH.
PROFIT BY SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I AM BECAUSE HE CASSIE I
OKAY THE VOTE IS -- TEN TWO ZERO
SOMEWHERE MISSING CENTER MORALE
SO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU HAVE A
GOOD EVENING.
OKAY NO ONE ZERO OKAY SO CENTER
CABALLERO.
OKAY RIGHT AFTER THIS ON THE
CENTER COVER AREA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND CENTERS TOO PROUD TO PRESENT
SB SIX ELEVEN WHICH IS TO
ABBAS'S THE HOUSING OLDER
PERSONS EFFECTIVELY FOR HOPE.
TASK FORCE AS PART OF THE
STATE'S MASTER PLAN FOR AGING.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE IN CALIFORNIA THE
STATE'S OVER SIXTY FIVE
POPULATION WILL NEARLY DOUBLE BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THIS DEMOCRAT
GRAPHIC SHIFT WILL IMPACT ALL
AREAS OF THE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM ESPECIALLY HOUSING.
WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE BUT IT IS
TAKEN IN EVEN GREATER GREATER
TOLL AND ARE OVER SIXTY FIVE
POPULATION WAFFEN LIFT ON FIXED
INCOME.
ACCORDING TO THE U. C. L. A.
CENTER FOR HEALTH POLICY
RESEARCH MORE THAN HALF OF LOW
INCOME OLDER TENANTS ARE
SEVERELY.
RENT BURDENED WHICH MEANS
SPENDING MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING.
THIS DISPARITY BETWEEN HOUSING
COSTS AND INCOME IS LADY THESE
LEADING TO A RISE IN HOMELESS
MISS AMONG OLDER ADULTS.
AND THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS THE
HOMELESS POPULATION OVER FIFTY
FIVE I BELIEVE IS THE FASTEST
GROWING POPULATION AMONG THE
HOMELESS.
AS POLICYMAKERS DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF
OLDER ADULTS.
ARE LIKELY TO HAVE MULTIPLE
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS
INCREASED FRAILTY AND LIMITED
MOBILITY AND THE NEED FOR IN
HOME SERVICES TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS.
IN THE ABSENCE OF HOUSING
ALTERNATIVES MANY WILL BE FORCED
IN INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS WHICH
NOT ONLY HURTS THEIR FAMILIES
BUT LEADS TO ENDING INCREASE
COSTS FOR THE STATE.
THE MASTER PLAN PROCESS THE HOPE
TASK FORCE WILL CONVENE
STAKEHOLDERS FROM AROUND THE
STATE. TO HELP IDENTIFY POLICY
TO HELP OLDER ADULTS AND THOSE
WITH DISABILITY DISABILITIES HM
PLACE OPPORTUNITIES TO INTEGRATE
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES TO
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES.
AND BEST PRACTICES TO DEVELOP
INTERGENERATIONAL HOUSING THAT
INCLUDES SERVICES AND SUPPORT
FOR OUR AGING POPULATION.
THE TASK FORCE WOULD ALSO SHARE
ITS RECOMMENDATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
NOW MORETHAN EVER CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A THOUGHTFUL PLAN TO MEET
THE GROWING NEEDS FOR AFFORDABLE
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING FOR OLDER
ADULTS.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT IS PAM AUSTIN
A RESIDENT OF ASCALON ROSEVILLE
MANNER AFFORDABLE SENIOR HOUSING
JEFFREY MORGAN PRESIDENT AND CEO
OF FIRST COMMUNITY HOUSING.
AND CASEY O'CONNOR WITH THE
STATE TREASURER FIONA MáS
OFFICE.
GREAT THANK YOU AND SINCE THERE
ARE THREE WITNESSES WHO HAD
ASKED IF YOU'RE KEEPING REMARKS
TO TWO MINUTES THANK YOU SURE
YEAH.
HI MISTER CHAIR CENTERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STATE TREASURER FIONA MA.
THE TREASURE HOUSE OF VESTED
INTEREST IN THAT SHE'S BEEN
TAKING CARE OF HER PARENTS FOR
YEARS.
AND HER MOTHER WHO JUST PASSED
AWAY IN JULY -- RELIED IN A LOT
OF SERVICES BECAUSE SHE HAD A
LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
SO WE REALLY BROUGHT TO LIGHT.
HOW DISJOINTED THIS IS AND WHY
HER MOTHER HAD TO LIVE WITH HER
BECAUSE SHE COULDN'T?
FIND THE SERVICES TO DO THIS ON
OUR OWN IT WASN'T HOUSING THERE
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE GOT
EVERYTHING SHE NEEDED SO THAT'S
KIND OF HOW WE GOT TO THE TABLE
HERE AND JUST.
TO ADD ON THE SENATOR'S COMMENTS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN LOS
ANGELES REPORTED A DECREASE IN
THE OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY NOTED
A SURGE IN THE HOMELESS
POPULATION FOR SIXTY TWO AN
OLDER.
SO WHILE WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS ACROSS THE
STREET WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT FORGETTING
THE OLDER POPULATION HAS ALREADY
GIVEN SO MUCH THE STATE AND
OURSELVES.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE'S
ENOUGH TIME FOR THE OTHER TWO
WITNESSES ALL SEE THE REST OF MY
TIME TO THAN JUST THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAMELA AUSTIN
AYE A LIVE AT ESCHATON ROSEVILLE
MANNER.
I BEEN THERE ABOUT FOUR YEARS --
I LIKE QUITE A FEW OF THE
NEIGHBORS.
AT ESCHATON.
WE ALL HAD HOMES.
I MYSELF HAD DO BEAUTIFUL HOME.
ON ACREAGE WITH HORSES FOUR CAR
GARAGE BARNES YOU NAME IT PLUS A
GREAT JOB.
DOWN THE WAY I ENDED UP WITH.
PULMONARY FIBROSIS WHICH IS THE
DEATH SENTENCE AND YOUR LUNGS.
I WAS VERY VERY FORTUNATE I HAD
DOUBLE LUNG TRANSPLANT AT
STANFORD WILL BE EIGHT YEARS
THIS AUGUST.
NOW MIND YOU THIS COULD HAPPEN
TO ANYBODY ANY OF US.
YOU KNOW WHAT.
AND YOU THINK OR I'M DOING FINE.
BUT WE NEVER KNOW WE NEVER KNOW
WITH THE FUTURE REALLY HOLDS FOR
US.
AND I KNOW THERE'S PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT ARE LIKE ME THAT PARA
HOME PROPERTY WITH ALL PAID OUR
TAXES.
WE'VE.
A LOT OF US HAVE WORK TO
COMMUNITIES TO HELP THE
COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR JOBS.
I WORK FOR THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AT THAT TIME.
SO WE DO WHAT WE CAN DO.
I LOOK NOW AND I SEE.
I WAS SO FORTUNATE BECAUSE I
WOULD HAVE BEEN OUT IN THE
STREET.
IF IT HADN'T BEEN FOR MY FAMILY.
MY FAMILY SAVE ME.
AND WHAT THEY DID.
WAS I STILL OWE THEM A LOT.
BUT ONCE I GOT OVER TO MY
FAMILY'S HOME AND I LIVED THERE
FOR FOUR YEARS.
IN THE MEANTIME I WAS I PUT
MYSELF ON THE WAITING LIST FOR
ESCHATON ROSEVILLE MATTER MY
DAUGHTER LIVES IN ROSEVILLE.
TOOK FOUR YEARS.
AND I WAS ABLE TO GET ON AND I
LOVE IT THERE IT IS BEAUTIFUL
IT'S CLEAN HEY.
HAS A BEAUTIFUL COURTYARD YOU
CAN'T ASK FOR ANYTHING MORE SHE
JUST WONDERFUL THEY HAVE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS THAT GO ON WE
HAVE -- KAISER COMES AND
SOMETIMES IT TALK ABOUT
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS TO HELP US.
AND OF YEAH AND IT'S JUST IT'S
SO HORRIBLE THING TO SEE SO MANY.
OF US.
THAT.
HAVE LOST SO MUCH BUT ALSO I
HAVE GAINED.
MY PLACE IS BEAUTIFUL AND IT'S
SAFE.
WE LOCK UP EVERY NIGHT IT'S A
SAFE BUILDING AS SAFE AS YOU CAN
HAVE.
BUT I JUST OF IF IT WASN'T FOR
ESCHATON AND MY FAMILY.
I WOULDN'T BE HERE.
AND THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT I HEAR
ON TV AND I'M TRYING TO HOPE SAY
ON TWO MINUTES.
I SEE ON TELEVISION ON THE NEWS
IT'S ALL ABOUT.
HOMELESS.
THE HOMELESS A LINE OF THE
STREETS.
I HAVE COMPASSION FOR PEOPLE
THAT WOULD BE LIKE ME.
THAT HAD FAMILIES MAYBE THEY'VE
LOST THEIR JOB OR DUE TO ILLNESS
AND THEY HAD THINGS IN LIKE WHEN.
ALL THE PROPERTY WENT DOWN HILL
BACK AND WHAT.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND HAVING SO
MUCH.
EMPHASIS.
ON THE HOMELESS THERE ARE ST.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO BE.
THE BE THERE BEEN ON ALCOHOLISM
OR DRUGS TO ME THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT THAT I THINK WE'RE IN
KIND OF THE WRONG DIRECTION WE
HELP THE PEOPLE THAT NEED THE
HELP.
WE REALLY SHOULD AND AS FAR AS
THE SENIORS -- WE SHOULD BE
ALMOST ON THE TOP.
WE HAVE PAID OUR TAXES WE'VE
DONE OUR DUES.
AND I GUESS THAT'S ALL IN THE
SAME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MODE JEFF MORGAN PRESIDENT OF
FIRST COMMUNITY HOUSING AND HI
SERVICE THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
RESIDENTS PROBABLY THOUSAND
SENIORS IN THE SILICON VALLEY.
IN AND BEEN A PRIOR JOB ACTUALLY
SIR FIVE TO SIX THOUSAND SENIORS
IN THE NATIONAL AFFORDABLE
SENIOR HOUSING WHAT'S EXCITING
TO ME ABOUT.
CENTER COUPLE EUROS BILL IS THAT
WE HAVE HAD A NEED FOR CLEARING
HOUSE FOR IDEAS.
H. CD HAS PROPOSALS WHERE THEY
PUT FORWARD A LOT OF FUNDING TO
PROPOSITION ONE SEE ANOTHER WAYS
WERE BUILT THOUSANDS OF UNITS OF
HOUSING.
YET A LOT OF THOSE BEEN TARGETED
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS AND I
THINK.
IS SETTING A FOCUS ON SENIORS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT NATIONALLY
ELEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE EVERY DAY
BECOME SENIORS -- IN THE AS YOU
JUST HEARD THAT'S THE THE
HIGHEST.
THE INCREASE OF HOMELESSNESS IS
AMONG SENIORS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE AMONG IN THE
NONPROFIT WORLD A LOT OF US HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIPS WHERE -- WE
UNDERSTAND THE FOLKS LIKE PAM
ILLUSTRATE THE FACT THAT HOUSING
IS HEALTHCARE IN FACT IF YOU
LOOK AT A CLINICAL TRIAL THERE'S
NO DRUGS THERE'S NO PROCEDURE.
THAT'S BETTER THAN HAVING
HOUSING PERSONS OF INCIDENCE OF
AIDS -- OR WHERE THEY'RE DEALING
WITH THAT IT'S AS IF THEY THEY'D
HAVE NO MEDICATION STATISTICALLY
AUTHOR HOMELESS.
ANNA ANNA SENIOR PER CAN EASILY
BECOME ALMOST SO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE DATA
THAT COMES FROM THIS NOT ONLY
AFFECTS STATE POLICY BUT SERVE
AS A BASE FOR WHERE PERHAPS CMS
THE CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
MEDICAID STUDIES COULD SEE.
THE NEED TO PUT SOME OF THOSE
DOLLARS TOWARDS HOUSING AS A
SUBSIDY SO I THINK THE
POSSIBILITIES ARE VERY EXCITING
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT.
SB.
SIX ELEVEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
OF ANY AND YOUR SUPPORT
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
HAY SEUSS MOTTO LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA ALSO A SPONSOR.
OF SB SIX ELEVEN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR BIBLE.
AND YOU EXTRA KERR.
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE BY ENEMY W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
AND MEMBERS CAN BUS WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES AGENCIES ON AGING
SUPPORT.
A ROBBER COUPLE PART OF DOC
PLAYING SECOND HOMES OR GONNA
BRING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IN THAT CASE
COLLEAGUES ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS -- MOTION -- BY
SENATOR ROTH -- TO REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS.
YOU'RE THE LOOK IN YOUR FACE
YEAH I WAS GOING TO AND ASK THE
STAFF REPORT -- IN THE SUGGESTS
THAT THE SOME OF THE YOU GIVE
YOU CREATING TASK FORCE BUT
THERE'S I GUESS. TO PRESCRIPTIVE
OF FINDINGS THERE IS ALMOST
FINDINGS IN THE BILLS I WAS.
READING SOME OF THE REPORTS THAT
YOU WANT TO GO WHAT TO DO YOU.
THINK ABOUT THAT MA'AM.
HILL.
YEAH OVERVIEW YOU GET IT.
OVERVIEW OF OF PROJECTED FUTURE
NEED TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUMMARY OF EXISTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS FOR OLDER
AMERICANS.
RATHER THAN BECAUSE TYPICALLY WE
SAY HERE'S A TASK FORCE TO
REPORT BACK TO US WHAT YOU FIND.
AND IT'S I THINK IT'S ON PAGE
THREE OF THE OF THE STAFF REPORT
IS SAYING IT'S A A LITTLE BIT
PRESCRIPTIVE.
AS RIGHT NOW.
IT'S A GOOD IDEA IT WAS
INTENTIONALLY PRESCRIPTIVE.
WHAT I THINK IT WAS
INTENTIONALLY PRESCRIPTIVE I
THINK PART OF WHAT WE WANTED WAS
SOME SOME DETAIL IT WOULD HELP
US TO TO DETERMINE WHERE HAVE WE
BEEN NUMBER WE GONNA GO?
AND HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET
THERE -- SURE AND JUST TO ADD
WHEN WE WERE SPEAKING WITH A LOT
OF UP OLDER ADULTS AND SENIORS
ABOUT WHAT IS NEEDED IN THIS
BILL THEY WERE VERY SPECIFIC
REQUESTS AND THINGS THAT HAD NOT
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE PAST WHEN
TRYING TO WORK ON A MASTER PLAN.
OUR INTENTION THIS TIME AROUND
IS TO A COMPREHENSIVE OVERHAUL
MAKE SURE WHAT'S NEEDED IS
ACTUALLY THERE SO THAT'S WHY WE
STARTED THIS WAY WERE.
HAPPY -- TO DISCUSS ANY.
ISSUES WITH THAT BUT AS FAR AS
WE'RE CONCERNED WE TOOK THE
IDEAS THAT WE HEARD FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE PART OF
THIS BILL AND WE INCLUDED THEM
ACCORDINGLY AS THEY SAW FIT.
SO IT'S NOT REALLY THE TASK
FORCE THAT'S S. ASSESSING THE
HOUSING ISSUES IT'S HERE THE
CATEGORIES OF HOUSING ISSUES
GIVE US A REPORT ON THOSE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS WRITE A
REPORT USING THOSE ISSUES TO SEE
WHAT CAN BE DONE LEGISLATIVELY
OR BY THE STATE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS AND WHAT.
THE FINDINGS ARE IF THERE'S
GOING TO BE IN A RANKING OF THEM
OR WHAT THEY SEE IN THE STATE
CURRENTLY WHAT CAN BE EXPANDED
WHAT NEEDS TO BE NEW WHAT NEEDS
TO BE.
FIXED WE'RE JUST LOOKING FOR
MORE DIRECTION ON THE SPECIFIC
AREAS AND WHAT ELSE THEY CAN
FIND I BELIEVE.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
ROTH TO REFER -- THIS ITEM TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE OKAY
THANK YOU WILL CALL THE ROLL
THIS DOESN'T JOINT AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SIX ELEVEN
BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE AMARO.
I BATES.
BATES A CAMARO HI HEATHER HI
DORADO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM MORE LOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I UMBERG.
NUMBER FIVE AKOWSKI.
CASKEY AYE. THREE OKAY BY VOTERS
ELEVEN ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT.
SEVERAL NOW I SEE THE SENATOR
ALLEN HAS ARRIVED SO WE'LL CALL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX ACTUALLY
POLICIES.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE RIGHT AND I
JUST WANNA CALL THE CONCERN --
AGENDA.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM SB SIX TWENTY
THREE ON CONSENT -- MOTION -- BY --
CENTER MORE LOG.
AND THAT IS TO SEND IT TO WHERE.
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONCERN COUNTY WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEM TEN
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL.
HI BATES.
BATES -- COVER -- DRAWS OF
CONSENT.
THEY'RE ALSO.
THROW THOUGH I AM A CHOIR.
MCGUIRE MORE LUCK.
MULTI ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
I AM BURKE.
I'M BURKE I'VE HUSKY.
BECAUSE THE AYE YES IT'S ELEVEN
NOTHING AND SO SB SIX TWENTY
THREE ON CONSENT IS OUT WE WILL
NOW GO TO ITEM SEVEN SB FIVE
TWENTY SIX SENATOR ALLEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER I
LIKE I LIKE IT HIGHLIGHTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- AT I'VE
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE
SEVERAL THE HARD WORK ON DONE
THIS BILL I ALSO WANT TO I I
WILL I'M HAPPY TO TAKE THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- SO JUST GIVE SOME
CONTEXT IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THE LEGISLATURE AS MANY OF YOU
MAY KNOW PASSED SB AND THE SAD
TRUTH IS THAT.
THE REPORT THAT CAME OUT FOUND
THAT CALL CALIFORNIA IS NOT ON
TRACK TO MEET.
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS EXPECT
UNDER SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND
THE REPORT NOTED CONCERNS OVER
THE CONTINUED.
PERVASIVE IN LONG STANDING
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THIS THE
FACTORS THAT SHAPE REGIONAL
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENT
CALIFORNIA SO JUST
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT
REGULATORY HOUSING MARKET
CONDITIONS OF THE LOCAL REGIONAL.
AND STATE LEVELS IN THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY CLIMATE
HEALTH ECONOMIC AND HOUSING
GOALS.
SO -- BASED ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT REPORT
IN THE S. IN THE SB ONE FIFTY
REPORT.
HI THIS BILL SB FIVE TWENTY SIX
ESTABLISHES A TASK FORCE.
CHARGED WITH IDENTIFYING
STRATEGIES TO GET THE STATE ON
TRACK TO MEETING OUR CLIMATE
GOALS FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
AND LAND USE SECTOR BASICALLY
MEETING THE PROMISE.
OF SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE IT'S A
PROCESS FOR COLLECTING THE
NECESSARY DATA TO EVALUATE THE
PROGRESS THE REGIONS ARE MAKING.
IT'S OUR HOPE THAT THIS WILL
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND GIVE
ALL LEVELS OF DECISION MAKERS
FROM THE STATE REGIONAL AND
LOCAL LEVELS A SENSE. FOR WHAT'S
NEEDED TO MEET OUR TARGETS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A NUMBER
OF THE GROUPS -- IN OPPOSITION
TO THE MEASURE AND ENTERED INTO
BY MECHANISMS TO HELP US GET
BACK ON TRACK TOWARD REDUCING
EMISSIONS.
RELATED TO LAND USE
TRANSPORTATION AND IDENTIFY HOW
TO BEST A LINE ALL OF OUR STATE
GOALS AND FUNDING -- I I REALLY
DO THINK THE DISCUSSIONS HAVE
BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE SO FAR
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED TO CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND I HAVE WITH ME HERE MAKE THE
KEEPER.
WHO IS ONE OF THE ARCHITECTS OF
SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF TOMORROW -- MER
AND BEEN PROTON MERIT STEINBERG
INVENTORY ROOM FROM AN RTC AND
ALSO WILL BEAR IT FROM THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION.
WHO'S GONNA SPEAKING FOR THE
BILL SO WE HAVE.
RIGHT OKAY.
GOING TO SAY THAT THIS.
YOU KNOW THE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
HER ADVICE YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT
VERY DISORIENTING BUT BUT BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE NEED TO GET BACK
ON TRACK.
WITH OUR SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE
GOALS -- SO THAT.
I WILL NEVER HAVE TO COME BACK
WITH THIS BILL AGAIN.
SO -- WITH THAT -- MISS FROM.
ANSWER IS GOING TO BE TWO
WITNESSES OKAY THREE TOTAL OF
THREE TOTAL SO -- IF YOU COULD
PLEASE LIMITED TO TWO MINUTES OR
SO EACH HAVE A GREAT THANK YOU.
NATALIE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
AS YOU CAN SEE I'M BATLING A
COLD SO I'LL BE VERY BRIEF I'M
VICTORIA ROME WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE TWENTY SIX THE BILL WILL
HELP INSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
EXTEND TO THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR.
AS THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
DRIVES HOUSING DECISIONS AND
VICE VERSA.
DECISIONS WE MAKE TODAY WILL
DETERMINE HOW OUR STATE
ACCOMMODATES NEW GROWTH FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL DECADES.
SB FIVE TWENTY SIX BUILDS ON THE
WORK DONE PURSUANT TO SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND SB ONE
FIFTY FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
SHIFT PLANNING AND FUNDING
DECISIONS TO GIVE PEOPLE MORE
MOBILITY OPTIONS AND ULTIMATELY
TO HELP OUR STATE.
MEET OUR CLIMATE EQUITY AND
HOUSING GOALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD EVENING -- THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION IS CO
SPONSORING SB FIVE TWENTY SIX TO
HELP ADDRESS THE CRITICAL NEED
TO REDUCE HARMFUL TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS AND CREATE HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES.
IN SHORT LAND USE DECISIONS AND
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS MUST
BE VIEWED AS PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISIONS.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE LONG
SUPPORTED THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB -- THREE SEVENTY FIVE
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE COURSE OF
THE THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
THE IMPLEMENTATION PROCESS AND
WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED WITH THE
SB ONE FIFTY REPORTS FINDINGS
THAT WE ARE NOT ON TRACK.
THE PROMISE OF HELP YOUR
COMMUNITIES ENVISIONED IN OUR
NPOS SCS PLANS IS NOT BEING
REALIZED TUTOR AND THE VARIETY
FACTORS THAT THE SENATOR
MENTIONED. THREE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE WE CAN ACHIEVE A
WIDE RANGE PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS INCLUDING REDUCTIONS IN
CHRONIC ILLNESSES AND CANCERS.
RESPIRATORY AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE AND OBESITY RELATED
DISEASES AND DIABETES.
WE SUPPORT SB FIVE TWENTY SIX AS
A WAY TO ADDRESS THE GROWTH IN
TRANSPORTATION POLLUTION.
IN ADVANCE A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN OUR LOCAL REGIONAL AND
STATE LEVEL STAKEHOLDERS TO GET
US ON TRACK TO PLANNING
INVESTING.
IN BUILDING HEALTHY AFFORDABLE
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
WIENER MIKING KEEPER I WAS THE
CEO AT THE SACRAMENTO MPO NGUYEN.
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY FIVE
WAS DRAFTED AND PASSED AND SO I
I SAW IT FROM.
THE CREATION STAGE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION STAGE THE BILL OF
THOSE THE STATUTE HAS DONE A
GREAT DEAL OF GOOD IN THE STATE
AND MANY OF ITS BENEFITS ARE
LONG WAVE CHANGE.
KIND OF BENEFITS AS YOU CHANGE
THE URBAN STRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WILL TAKE
AWHILE. TO BE REALIZED BUT AS WE
ALL KNOW THE IMPERATIVE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE IS MUCH MORE.
URGENT TODAY THE SCIENCES
ADVANCED AND IT'S MUCH MORE OF A
CRISIS SITUATION THEN WE
UNDERSTOOD A DECADE AGO.
I THINK THE BILL THAT -- SENATOR
ALLEN AUTHORED TO ESTABLISH SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SOME
MONITORING AND SOME CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT COUPLE YEARS AGO WAS
VERY BENEFICIAL I AGREE WITH ALL
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FINDINGS THAT WERE IN THE AIR BE
REPORT -- A VERY IMPORTANT PART
OF WHAT CAN HELP THE MP EIGHTEEN
MP AS IN THE STATE MOVE FORWARD
IS MORE CONSCIOUS FOCUSED AND
EFFECTIVE COORDINATION AMONG THE
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES.
THE TOUCH THE BEHAVIORS OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMETS IN THE
REGIONALLY CHEN SEASON I THINK
THAT THIS BILL.
ACCOMPLISHES THAT IN A GOOD WAY
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THERE
ARE FOUR SEATS WILL BE ADDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE FORCE OF THE MPO
IS IN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
BE EPRESENTED -- WITH AN
EXPANDED TO CENTRALLY STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL TO ACCOMPLISH
THAT.
BUT I THINK THAT THE ENHANCED
ACCOUNTABILITY THE THE WHOLE
STATUE RELIES ON THE THE BASIC
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLE I MISS THAT
BETTER INFORMATION WILL YIELD --
BETTER ACTIONS AND THIS COMPELS
MORE AND MORE INFORMATION.
FROM THE MPO IS TO THE STATE IN
CARBON PARTICULAR SO THAT THEY
CAN GET THE TARGET SET CORRECTLY.
TO MEET THE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
THAT ARE NECESSARY AND ALSO WORK
FOR THE REGION SO I I SUPPORT
THIS SITE WILL ALSO -- CAME FROM
A MEETING WITH MAYOR STEINBERG
ON THE WAY AND HE WANTED ME TO
CONVEY HIS BEST WISHES AND
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR AND
THE CHAIR -- AND HE APPRECIATES
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON
IMPROVING HIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
OKAY THIRTY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
MATTHEW BAKER PLAYING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE ORGANIZATION CLIMATE PLAN
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SB GOVERNMENTASSEMBLY HAVE A
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
KEVIN'S GIRLFRIEND'S COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
JANET JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY AND THREE FIFTY
SOUTH ST LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JUDY POPE FOR THREE FIFTY
RIVERSIDE SO CAL THREE FIFTY
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WERE
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY --
WE DO HAVE A WE HAVE RETAINED
OUR OPPOSE POSITION ON THE BILL --
BUT AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF DIALOGUE --
IT'S BEEN QUITE PRODUCTIVE IN
FACT AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN
IN THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
LAST WEEK OR TWO WEEKS AGO I'M
TOOK CARE OF I THINK THE BULK OF
OUR MOST SERIOUS CONCERNS.
I'M WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED BECAUSE
THE BILL DOES -- WE THINK OUR
PLACE A AN EMPHASIS ON PROJECT
LEVEL V. M. T. THAT WE DON'T
THINK IS THE ONLY OR BEST
ARBITER OF WHAT -- HOW WE'RE
MEETING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS GOALS
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD -- TO TO EXPAND OUR
PERHAPS THE LISTER TO TALK ABOUT
A BETTER WAY TO REALLY MEASURE
ON HOW WE'RE MEETING OUR GOALS
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL MELISSA ROMERO THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
POLICIES FOR BEING A LTTLE LATE.
NO PROBLEM ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
THERE'S LITTLE SEVEN KNOWN BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND ROOM
MOTION BY CENTER ROTH CENTERS
SKINNER.
THANK YOU TIMES.
SENATOR ALLEN I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
BILL [inaudible]
I WONDER IF IT HAS ENOUGH TEETH
[inaudible]
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE TIME
SINCE SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE BMT IS GONE
UP CONSIDERABLY YES THE ECONOMY
HAS GROWN BUT STILL THE VMT
GROWTH IS -- BEEN WHAT A LOT DUE.
TO THE WHERE JOB CONCENTRATION
IS VERSUS WHERE PEOPLE LEFT TO
LIVE NOW TO GET TO THOSE JOBS.
AND TRANSIT RIDERSHIP SIGN DOWN
IT'S GOING DOWN IN EVERY AREA OF
THE STATE SINCE THAT TIME.
NO PART OF THAT IS LOCATION AND
PART OF THAT IS.
A RIDE SHARING RIDE HAILING WAS
NOT UBIQUITOUS AT THE POINT THAT
WE ADOPTED SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE SO IF PARTNER
IF IF OUR MOTIVATION.
IS TO GIVE BMT DOWN.
AND I'M I'M I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT I JUST WONDER IF WE
DON'T NEED MORE TEETH VERSES
JUST -- MORE COORDINATED
MEETINGS WITH US A MORE
PARTICIPANTS [inaudible]
SENATOR I THE MORE -- THE BILL
DID HAVE MORE TEETH IN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND OUR
TRANSITION CHAIR -- WE WE
BASICALLY WE'RE TRYING.
SOME OF THE GOALS IN THIS BILL
TO STEP.
AND THAT ARE CHANGES CHAIR OF
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT I
THINK COMING OUT OF THE SB ONE
DISCUSSION AND AND AND ALL OF
THAT HAPPENED THERE.
NOW THAT BEING SAID HE HAS.
SAID TO ME THAT HE'S ANDERSON
TRYING TO HELP US FIGURE OUT A
WAY -- TO TO TO STRENGTHEN THE
BILL MAYBE MAYBE USE A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF TEETH.
THAN THE STEP TEETH -- YOU KNOW
IF I DO THINK SOME OF THE INTENT
LANGUAGE AND SOME OF THE MEN'S
OF ACTUALLY -- GIVEN SOME
ADDITIONAL STRENGTH THE BILL BUT
I WOULD LOVE TO FIGURE I'D LOVE
TO WORK WITH YOU IN A WAY.
THAT -- MEETS THE CONCERNS OF
OUR TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE --
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME.
MAKE SURE THIS IS A REAL THING I
MEAN WE ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT
TRYING.
TO A FACTUAL A DIVISION OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH AS WE
ALL KNOW HAS REALLY STRUGGLED.
TO MAKE THE DIFFERENCE THAT IT
PROMISES TO MAKE -- WHEN WE HAVE
AN ENDING THIS IS AND I'M NOT
TRYING?
TO BE POINT FINGERS AT AGENCIES
RIGHT NOW BUT THERE'S BEEN SOME
CRITICISM THAT.
THEY ARE THESE POLICIES MAY HAVE.
EXACERBATED VMT BECAUSE OF
LIMITING HOUSING IN SOME AREAS
AND YOU KNOW I NOT SURE I
HAVEN'T NECESSARILY SEEN THE
DETAILED ANALYSIS ON IT BUT
THERE IS SOME CONCERN ABOUT THAT.
AND I DIDN'T MENTION THIS IN MY
BILL BUT ONE OF THE ISSUES WERE
FACING IS THIS RIDICULOUS SUPER
COMMUTES.
WITH MANY CALIFORNIANS NOW.
DRIVING EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED
MILES EACH WAY. FOR TWO HUNDRED
MILES ROUND TRIP FOR FURTHER TO
GO TO WORK YEAH -- I AND I
WONDER IF -- AN EXPLICIT VMT
REDUCTION GOAL. FOR IN A SIMILAR
WAY THAT WE'VE DONE GHG
REDUCTION GOALS.
THAT IF A OR B..
HAD TO SET ONE AND THEN ORIENTED
THEIR POLICIES ARE OTHER
AGENCIES HAD TO SET ONE THEN
THEY'D BE ORIENTING THEIR
POLICIES LOOKING THROUGH THAT
LANDS BUT THIS IS JUST FOOD FOR
THOUGHT I DON'T WANT TO DELAY
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
FEDERAL OKAY.
ALLOW ME TO DELAY THE COMMITTEE --
I'M JUST TRUE CENTER ALLEN IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
REDUCE THESE.
EMTS THAT.
THAT THAT THE IDEAS ARE BEING
PROPOSED OR TO TO REDUCE LANES
AT CONGESTION PRICING TOLL FREE.
INCREASE TOLL FEES A TENER.
AND I'M JUST WONDERING HOW DOES
THAT HELP THE POOR AND THOSE
YOUNG COUPLES THAT ARE YOU KNOW
DRIVING TILL THEY QUALIFY.
WRITTEN REDUCE THIS I'M JUST
LOOKING AT MY NUMBER WHERE
YOU'RE WHERE YOU'RE WHETHER
REDUCING LANES WITH WHERE YOU
HAD TO SEND IT'S IN MY
REPUBLICAN STAFF REPORTER
APOLOGIST TIMES STAFF REPORT
THAT WE HAVE YOUR BUT IT WOULD
THAT BE A A SOLUTION IS THAT.
IS THAT WHAT.
TO WE'LL BE AYE WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IN THE BILL -- IT MEANS YOU
MAY BE.
AT I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOUR CABLE
AND FORGIVE ME BUT IT'S IN MY
NOTICE AND I I JUST SIT HERE
IT'S A VOICE WE'RE GONNA REDUCE
LANES AS A STRATEGY THAT
ACTUALLY COMPOUNDS THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE'RE JUST PHONE
EVERYBODY DOWN.
BUT I APOLOGIZE IF IT'S NOT IN
THE STAFF THIS IS ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO SAVE HOUSING AND JOBS
NEXT.
TO NEXT TO EACH OTHER AS I'M
JUST BEING SENSITIVE TO THE
GROUP WITH SENATOR SKINNER JUST
SAT.
GETTING SUCH LONG DISTANCES NOT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO
WHO RIGHT YOU KNOW SO WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THIS
PROBLEM AND I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A FOR MAKING THEIR
GUARDIAN NOT A LITTLE MORE
COMPLEX.
THAT'S I ALL I NEEDED TO IF
ANYTHING WE'RE TRYING TO WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRY TO MAKE IT SIMPLER
RIGHT WE'RE TRYING ACTUALLY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE LIVE BE ABLE
TO LIVE NEARBY WHERE THEY GO TO
WORK AND WHICH WILL VERY MUCH
ADDRESS THE THE SOCIAL EQUITY
ISSUES YOU'RE RAISING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
ENTER SO COMMON -- SOMEONE A
BANK -- THE CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS CHAIR OF A
DIFFERENT -- THE AUTHOR -- FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL.
FORWARD AND I AGREE.
WITH THE AUTHOR WAS CENTER
SKINNER DIED ON THE PROMISE OF
PREVIOUS EFFORTS TO TRY TO ALIGN.
LAND USE AND TRANSPORTATION AND
AND REDUCE CARBON EMISSIONS HAS.
WE WE IN THE LEGISLATURE WE PUT
OUT.
WE'RE GONNA PUTTING OUT
BLUEPRINTS AND WE DON'T ALWAYS
ON PUT THE TEETH INTO A TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE IT HAPPENS.
AND PART OF IT -- IN THIS AREA.
IS A LAND USES IS REALLY HARD
ISSUE AND I I I KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW WE ALL WE ALL SEEN IT --
AND CITIES DON'T WANT TO BE TOLD
WHAT TO DO -- AND ONE A THE
OTHER SIDE PHONE SELVES FOR ONE
OF YOU KNOW WHERE YOU WAN TO
PUT HOUSING ON LAND USE HAS BEEN.
A VERY DECENTRALIZED THING IN
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK THAT'S
STARTING TO CHANGE AS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS LAND USE
DECISIONS.
I HAVE STATEWIDE IMPACT SUCH AS
FOR AFFORDABILITY BUT AROUND --
CARBON EMISSIONS IN OUR EFFORTS
TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE -- AND
SO WE DO NEED -- TEETH WE I MEAN
WE WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY --
TO PUT SOME MORE TEA FACTIONS OF
THE BILL AND I KNOW -- WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THAT AND AND I HAVE A LOT OF
IDEAS FOR TEETH CENTER SO IT --
SO ANYWAY HODA THIS DOESN'T GO
IN I RECOMMENDATION AS AMENDED
AND WE PROMOTION BY SENATOR RICK
ROSS.
AND SO -- CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE
BY I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS A
GREAT DEAL AND I I THINK THIS IS
ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT TRYING TO
BE THE PROMISE OF SB THREE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS IT
[inaudible]
VITALLY IMPORTANT -- STATEMENT
OF OF GOALS THAT REALLY DO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WORKS ON EVERY
EVERY DAY SO -- APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND AND VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE NAY VOTE.
OKAY -- THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
HI WIENER I MORRELL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES SNOW COVER.
THEY'RE ALSO.
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM MORE LOCK.
WELL I KNOW ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE.
NUMBER FIVE HUSKY [inaudible]
CASSIE I NORMAN.
OKAY -- THE VOTED SIX TO THREE
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY WILL NOW GO TO SENATOR MORE
LOCK.
ITEM THIRTEEN AS
TO SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
.
YEAH THE RESEARCHER HERE.
ONE DOWN AND AND AND ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND WE HAVE DIFFICULTY
CONVINCING PEOPLE TO COME IN FOR
OUR BOARDS SO I CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU'D ONLY HAVE AS MANY
CANDIDATES AS OPEN POSITIONS.
SO WHY VOTE ON A SINGLE SLAVE.
YES PLEASE SEVEN FIVE FOUR SAVES
ON MAILING AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS IT'S DONE FOR NUMEROUS
MUNICIPALITIES.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE MENTIONED
IN YOUR STAFF REPORT ONE
COMMUNITY MY DISTRICT HAS HAD
SIX UNCONTESTED ELECTIONS FOR
THREE HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WITH TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SENIOR ADLT UNITS.
THAT SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
COSTS AND FOR A COMMUNITY LIVING
ON RETIREMENT SAVINGS I HAVE TO
CONFESS THAT I STOLE THIS BILL
FROM SENATOR RAFI BRAND IT LAST
YEAR -- HAD A FRIEND IN IT AND
LAGUNA WOODS -- WHO IS NO LONGER
THERE BUT WE WANT TO PICK IT UP
AGAIN THAT WAS SENATE BILL?
ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT AND A WIN
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
ONLY ONE NO VOTE.
IT WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED THIS --
EXPENSIVE AND UNNECESSARY
PROCEDURE SHOULD BE RESOLVED BY
THE MEMBERS OF THAT SPECIFIC
COMMUNITY BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THE CHANGE IN THE DAVIS STIRLING
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT.
SO.
WHY MAKE SUCH A?
SHE KNEW I MAKE SUCH A SMALL
MINISTERIAL CHANGE OPTIONAL --
TO HOLD AN ELECTION IS EASY HAVE
MORE CANDIDATES THAN AVAILABLE
POSITIONS IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE
FACT THEY'RE JUST A SINGLE SITE
THEN PLEASE APPLY AND RUN.
AND GET MORE THAN THE OPENING SO
THEN YOU DO HAVE AN ELECTION --
SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT'S AN
EASY SOLUTION -- IF IF YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT NOT HAVING TO
VOTE ON A SINGLE SLATE WHICH IS
SORT OF REDUNDANT.
SO I WENT TO A ENCOURAGE
HOMEOWNERS THAT LIVE IN --
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS TO RUN
BUT COLLEAGUES LET'S SEND SB
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR TO OUR NEW
GOVERNOR.
AND LET'S GIVE THE FIFTY
THOUSAND IMPACTED COMMUNITIES A
BUDGET SAVING OPPORTUNITY
THEY'LL BE THANKFUL FOR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE WITNESSES PRESENT.
AND THEIR THROUGH ILLNESSES ARE.
TOO ONE TWO THREE OKAY SO.
OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU.
CRACKLE FOR ARMED GOOD EVENING --
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF PARKER
I'M THE NEW CEO AT LAGUNA --
WOODS VILLAGE -- IT'S A COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT AS
INDICATED OF TWELVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED HOMES AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
WERE THE SPONSOR OF SB.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR OUR MEMBERS
LIVE ON MODEST INCOMES.
FIXED INCOMES AND IN MANY CASES
WE STRIVE TO BE FRUGAL AND
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE.
WE DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
SEEK THOSE EFFICIENCIES AND
COSTS AND PREPARATION THIS BILL
IS A PRODUCT OF THOSE EFFORTS.
AS INDICATED.
WE HAVE THREE GOVERNING BOARDS
WHICH OFTEN TIMES HAVE PEOPLE.
FOR WE HAVE THREE OR FOUR
OPENINGS BUT THE THE VOLUNTEER
ELEMENT OF THIS IS BEEN
RESTRICTIVE IN THE SENSE THAT WE
CAN'T GET PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN ONE ANSWERING ON THESE BOARDS.
SO OFTEN TIMES WE JUST GET THREE
NECESSARY FOR THE FOR NECESSARY
TO BE ELECTED AND BY MOVING
TOWARDS SB FIFTY FOUR IT'S GOING
TO SAVE -- ON BIG AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO SENATOR MENTIONED --
THE TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IS
THE APPROXIMATE COST OF OUR LAST
THREE ELECTIONS FILL IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS WE'VE SPENT A TOTAL OF
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR LECTIONIS WHICH WE
HAD NO MORE CANDIDATES THAN ON
THE SLATE.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY THAT
SHOULD BE SAVED FOR OUR
RESIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEREFORE WE ASK FOR YOU
SHOULD SUPPORT WITH REDUCTION SB.
FIFTY FOUR GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LEARN ON HUGE COME BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS INSTITUTE
ALSO IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
STATED WE BELIEVE.
THAT THIS WILL SAVE ASSOCIATIONS
A GREAT DEAL OF COST BUT ALSO
PROVIDES THE PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE RE
ENCOURAGED TO RUNNING CAN RUN IF
THEY WANT -- TO SO YOUR SPECS WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
WATER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGERS IN SUPPORT
FOR THE REASONS STATED.
OKAY AN ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
SENATOR WIENER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I MARJORIE MURRAY
AGAIN.
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION LAW -- HAS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS IDEA HAS BEEN.
BROUGHT TO THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK THIS IS THE FOURTH OR
FIFTH ITERATION OF THIS IDEA.
THAT THE ACCLAMATION CAN BE THE
TOOL FOR SEATING BOARD DIRECTORS.
AND WE HAVE THE SAME OBJECTIONS
TO THIS BILL AS WE HAVE HAD IN
THE PAST.
I ONE OF STRESS JUST ONE POINT
ABOUT HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS.
WHICH I'VE ALSO MADE IN OUR
LETTER.
AND THAT IS THAT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS ARE NOT COUNTRY
CLUBS.
THEY'RE NOT NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION SAID PUT ON FOURTH
OF JULY PICNICS THIS IS ANOTHER
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT LIKE A
SPECIAL DISTRICT OR A SCHOOL
BOARD OR A CITY COUNCIL OR A
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
FACT SOME OF THEIR POWERS.
EXCEED THOSE OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE MOST OBVIOUS ONE
BEING THE ASSOCIATION'S RIGHT
BEFORE CLOSE ON SOMEONE WHO
FALLS BEHIND.
ON ASSOCIATION ASSESSMENTS.
BECAUSE OF THEIR GOVERNMENTAL
POWERS.
THE EXISTING STATUTES GOVERNING
ASSOCIATION ELECTIONS ARE
MODELED ON THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS COLD AND WITH GOOD
REASON.
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE POWERS
INVESTED IN ASSOCIATION BOARDS.
ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD.
FOR ACCLAMATION IS THAT SCHOOL
BOARD TO USE A SPECIAL DISTRICTS
USE THE CITY COUNCIL'S USER.
THAT IS AN INEXACT ANALOGY. FOR
ONE THING QUALIFICATIONS AGAIN
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SPECIAL
THE SCHOOL BOARDS AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND SO ON THOSE ARE
SET BY.
LAW THOSE ARE SET BY STATUTE.
WHEREAS IN THE HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION ENVIRONMENT
QUALIFICATIONS ARE SET BY THE
INCUMBENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
SITTING.
ON THE BOARD.
THIS IS A HUGE DIFFERENCE WHICH
MY COLLEAGUE TOM SERVER WILL
ADDRESS AND A LITTLE BIT MORE IN
DETAIL.
A SECOND IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THE ELECTIONS IN THE PUBLIC
ARENA.
ARE EXECUTED BY A REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS A DISINTERESTED THIRD
PARTY THEY ARE NOT.
EXECUTED BY AGAIN THE INCUMBENTS
WHICH IS A SITUATION AND THE
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION.
SO.
I GUESS THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
HERE IS THAT.
AS THE BILL IS WRITTEN THE
DECISION TO SEAT BOARD DIRECTORS
BY ACCLAMATION IS A PRIVATE.
ONE MEANING IT'S MADE BY THE
INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS TOGETHER
WITH THE BOARD THERE IS NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE ELECTORATE.
TO DISAGREE TO OBJECT TO DEMAND
THE ELECTION AS THEY THEY HAVE
THAT RIGHT WITH A SCHOOL BOARD.
SO HOW WE ASK FOR A NO VOTE ON
THIS BECAUSE OF THE POWERS
INVESTED IN AN ASSOCIATION BOARD.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE CATALOGUED
TOO MANY INSTANCES OF
INDIVIDUALS PUTTING THEMSELVES
FORWARD. TO RUN FOR A BOARD BUT
BECAUSE THE BOARD SETS THE
QUALIFICATIONS THEY ARE TOO
EASILY DISMISSED.
MY COLLEAGUE TOM SERVER WILL
ADDRESS A COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES
HERE AND ONE IS THE COST ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN TIME SIR I'M
ON THE LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE AT
THE CENTER.
GOING ON SEVEN YEARS AND SO I
CAN TELL YOU.
THAT THE POSITIONS AT THE CENTER
TAKES.
ON LEGISLATION EITHER IN SUPPORT
OR IN OPPOSITION.
THOSE POSITIONS ARE BASED ON THE
INFORMATION THE COMPLAINTS THE
COMMENTS THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
HOMEOWNERS ALL AROUND THE STATE.
AND THEY HAVE BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION REPEATEDLY.
THAT IN MANY HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS AROUND THE STATE.
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT THE
SPONSOR IS NECESSARILY ONE OF
THESE BUT HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS
AROUND THE STATE.
ARE OFTEN CAPTIVE THE SMALL
GROUP OF INCUMBENTS WHO HOLD ON
TO THEIR POWER AND PASS.
RULES AND SO FORTH IN THEIR
FAVOR.
AND THAT THESE ABUSIVE PRACTICES
IT'S A CONTINUUM THAT STARTS
WITH THE WRITING OF THE RULES
FOR HOW YOU RUN AN ELECTION.
AND IT CONTINUES TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION THAT THE CONDUCT
OF THE ELECTION.
AND WE HEARD OF SUCH PRACTICES
AS WRITING.
OF QUALIFICATIONS THAT EXCLUDE
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION
AND ARE TRYING TO GET ON THE
BOARD.
AND TARA THE TARGET THOSE PEOPLE
AND PREVENT THEM FROM RUNNING SO
IN THE FACE OF THAT IT'S IRONIC
TO HEAR THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH.
CANDIDATES IN SOME OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS.
OF THESE PRACTICES ARE DONE
UNDER THE RADAR SO THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP IS NOT OFTEN NOT
AWARE OF WHAT IS GOING ON AND SO
THIS BILL WHICH WOULD ALLOW
SEATING BY ACCLAMATION.
IT CONTINUES TO OR ALLOWS THIS
CONTINUUM OF ABUSE TO CONTINUE
AND IN FACT MAKES IT WORSE.
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL NOTES
THAT.
ONCE THE INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS
DETERMINES THAT.
THE NUMBER OF NOMINEES IS NOT
MORE THAN NUMBER OF VACANCIES.
THE EXACT LANGUAGES.
THE DIRECTOR NOMINEES SHALL BE
CONSIDERED ELECTED BY
ACCLAMATION IF THE ASSOCIATION
FOLLOW THE PROCEDURE THE NOTICES.
THERE'S NOT EVEN ANY INDICATION
THAT THE BOARD HAS TO TAKE AN
ACTION IT JUST HAPPENS AND AGAIN.
UNDER THE RADAR SO THAT'S WHAT
CAUSES US SUCH SO MUCH CONCERNED.
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF ARGUMENTS
PUT FORTH IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
OF ONE OF THESE IS THE LOGIC OF
WHY HOLD ELECTION IF THERE
AREN'T ENOUGH CANDIDATES WHO IS
EQUAL CANDIDATES HIS VACANCIES.
AND THAT LOGIC IS.
I'VE ADDRESS THAT IN.
SHOWING THAT THIS WOULD BE ONE
OF THE CONTINUE.
THE OTHER ANOTHER -- ARGUMENT IS
THE COST.
NOW BEGINNING WITH THE VERY
FIRST BILL THAT WAS INTRODUCED I
THINK FOUR YEARS AGO
[inaudible]
THE COST.
PENCILS OUT TO ABOUT A DOLLAR
PER MEMBER.
PER ROOM PER A ELECTION.
AND THOSE NUMBERS ARE CONFIRMED
I MEAN WE HAD THE SAME BILL
BEFORE YOU SAME SPONSOR LAST
YEAR.
AND THE FIGURES THAT ARE QUOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS ARE ACOSTA SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I BELIEVE
THAT WAS FOR THREE ELECTIONS IN
ONE PARTICULAR CYCLE.
AND WITH THE MEMBERSHIP OF
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
THAT CANCELS OUT TO A DOLLAR
EIGHTY PER MEMBER. TO MAINTAIN
DEMOCRACY I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S TOO MUCH OF A PRICE TO
PAY -- THE OTHER IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION IS IN THE PUBLIC
ELECTIONS [inaudible]
ARENA.
THE RULES ARE NOT WRITTEN BY THE
BOARD THAT'S BEING ELECTED OR
THE CITY COUNCIL NOR IS IT.
OR IS THE ELECTION CONDUCTED BY
THOSE PEOPLE BUT IN THIS CONTEXT
IT IS AND SO THAT'S WHY WE THINK
THIS BILL -- IS.
A DANGEROUS ONE AND WE URGE YOU
KNOW [inaudible]
FOR CRITICS.
WHEN ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION?
CASEY MEMORY BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
IN A ROW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS NOT A NEW
ISSUE TO ME.
I GUESS MY QUESTION TO THE
OPPONENTS IS THIS I KNOW IT FROM
THE ANALYSIS AND I KNEW FROM
LAST YEAR THAT.
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL BEFORE I
GOT INVOLVED IN IT.
INCLUDED PROVISIONS THAT THE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION WAS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE NOTICE TO
ALL MEMBERS AT LEAST TWENTY DAYS
BEFORE DECLARING ELECTION
UNCONTESTED.
IN OTHER WORDS HEY HOMEOWNERS
WE'VE GOT FIVE CANDIDATES FOR
FIVE VACANCIES.
WE'RE GOING TO DECLARE THIS
UNCONTESTED.
AND THAT DIDN'T APPEAR TO
SATISFY THE OPPONENTS TO THAT
PARTICULAR BILL BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAY IS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN SO MY QUESTION
IS THIS IS THERE ANYTHING.
THAT WOULD REMOVE YOUR
OPPOSITION. TO AN ELECTION BY
ACCLAMATION.
WHEN THE NUMBER OF CANDIDATES
EQUALS THE NUMBER OF VACANCIES?
THAT WAS ACTUALLY OUR AMENDMENT.
WHAT THE ANALYSIS SAID IT DID
NOT SATISFY THE?
OPPOSE OPPOSITION CONCERNED SO
NO TO THE MAYES BILL I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
THAT WAS OUR MEN WITH THAT WHAT
THE AND CAUSE INCREASE I'M
READING THE ANALYSIS THAT
PROVISION HOWEVER DID NOT
SATISFY OPPOSITION CONCERNS.
MAYBE YOU WERE THE OPPOSITION
HAS SENATOR WIENER DO YOU WANT
ME TO ANSWER THAT OR DOES YOUR
QUESTION -- WELL WHAT THAT
RAISES SENATOR ROTH IS THE
BROADER.
IS THE INHERENT DEFECT.
OF ACCLAMATION WHICH IS.
THERE IS NO OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
MEMBERSHIP. TO OBJECT.
AND EVEN IN THE FOR TALKING
ABOUT A SCHOOL BOARD ELECTION
AND THIS IS IN THE ANALYSIS.
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY.
FOR VOTERS WHO LIVE IN IN A
SCHOOL BOARD DISTRICT. TO GET UP
A PETITION UP AT A CERTAIN LEVEL
AND DEMAND THAT THE ELECTION BE
HELD.
AND THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN NO OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT THEY MANY VERSIONS.
OF THIS OF THE ACCLAMATION BILLS
WITHIN LET ME RE AS MY QUESTION
BECAUSE THIS OF COURSE IS THE
SACRAMENTO WAY AND WE SEE IT ALL
THE TIME.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT COULD BE
DONE TO THIS BILL. TO ALLOW
ACCLAMATION.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE WHERE THE
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES EQUALS THE
NUMBER OF VACANCIES I DON'T
THINK SO BECAUSE IT REMOVES THE
RIGHT TO VOTE FROM THE
MEMBERSHIP.
WHICH IS THE INHERENT DEFECT OF
THIS APPROACH BUT ISN'T VOTING.
IN AN ELECTION WHERE THE NUMBER
OF CANDIDATES EQUALS NUMBER OF
VACANCIES.
AN IDLE ACT [inaudible]
SO. TO EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THE
VOTING WORKS IS IS THERE
ANYTHING WATER THE OP WHAT ARE
THE OPTIONS.
AT THAT POINT FOR A VOTER IN A
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION WHERE THE
NUMBER.
OF CANDIDATES EQUALS THE NUMBER
OF VACANCIES IT'S NOT JUST
NUMBER OF CANDIDATES EQUALS
NUMBER OF VACANCIES IT'S THE
TOTALITY OF THIS APPROACH WHERE
YOU HAVE WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE.
LAID OUT IN OUR LETTER AND WHICH
I THINK -- HERREN HAS LAID OUT
IN THE ANALYSIS WHERE YOU HAVE.
THE INCUMBENTS ESTABLISHING THE
QUALIFICATIONS.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE INSPECTOR
DETERMINING THAT?
THESE PEOPLE ARE QUALIFIED
[inaudible]
AND THE INCUMBENTS ARE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING AN EXIT CHOOSING
THE INSPECTOR.
AND IMPLEMENTING THE ELECTION SO
IT'S NOT JUST A SIMPLE.
WE'VE GOT FIVE WARM BODIES TO
FILL FIVE VACANCIES.
IT'S THE TOTALITY OF THIS
PROCESS.
SO IT'S NOT JUST ACCLAMATION
IT'S THE WHOLE PACKAGE.
THANK THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE MA'AM THANK YOU THANK.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY -- SEEING NINE AND I
SOMETHING WE MOTION.
IN A ROTH OF THE BILL OKAY -- WE
HAVE A MOTION -- AND THAT IS --
JUDICIARY.
OKAY FEDERAL UP WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I I GUESS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT TWO WAYS TO
LOOK AT A HOMEOWNERS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. ONE IS THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THEM AND
THEY'RE TRYING DESPERATELY TO
MAINTAIN CONTROL AND KEEP OTHERS
OUT.
AND THERE'S THE OTHER SIDE WHERE
WE'RE JUST GLAD PEOPLE ARE
RUNNING AND SPENDING AN EVENING
A MONTH.
TO MEET WITH THE BOARD LISTEN TO
THE COMPLAINTS.
I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE OF SERVING
ON A HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION
BOARD ONE OF THE SEMINARS I WENT.
TO TOLD ME THAT -- MOST BOARD
PRESIDENT TO MOVE OUT WITHIN A
YEAR OR TWO AFTER THEY'VE SERVED
BECAUSE THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH OF
PEOPLE CALL IN THE MIDDLE MIGHT
SAY IN A MY NEWSPAPERS WET OR
THIS OR THAT.
SO -- IT'S IS BUT AS LOCAL AS IT
GETS AND IS AS FRUSTRATING AS IT
IS.
AND SO I'M I'M BUT IN THE SCHOOL.
AND I'M EXCITED TO HAVE PEOPLE
WILLING TO RUN AND IF I HAD MORE
CANDIDATES THAN POSITIONS THAT'S
REALLY GREAT NEWS -- BUT IF YOU
HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
CANDIDATES OR LESS.
THEN WHY ARE WE SPENDING THE
TIME AND EFFORT -- YOU KNOW I I
HEAR THE ARGUMENTS.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT THERE'S A SINGLE PLAY
PLEASE GET PEOPLE TO RUN.
OR MAYBE MAYBE PUT UP THE MONEY
TO PAY FOR THE FOR THE MAILING
IF YOU HAVE THE TWENTY THOUSAND
OR OR MAYBE MAYBE WE HAD A STEP
BACK AND SAY OKAY FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
SERVING INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
FIFTY FIVE AN OLDER LIKE LAGUNA
WOODS MAYBE THEY SHOULD BE
EXEMPTED.
BUT FOR CRYING ABOUT I GUESS I
WOULD SAY.
YOU KNOW HOMEOWNERS YOU'RE
ADULTS NO THE FILING PERIOD NO
THE RULES AND AND VIOLENT TIME.
OF WE HAVE TO BE AWARE OF
CRITICAL DATES IN OUR LIVES LIKE
APRIL FIFTEENTH APRIL FIFTEEN
APRIL TEN APRIL SEPT A DECEMBER
TEN WE GOT A PAIR PROPERTY TAXES
WE GOT IT.
DO OUR THING OR WE HAVE
PENALTIES.
SO I I SEE NOTHING HERE THAT'S
UNDER THE RADAR.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE THE
RESULTS OF THIS ELECTION YOU'VE
GOT ANOTHER ONE IN THE YEAR TWO
ANYA RAMP UP AND GET PEOPLE
INVOLVED.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR I I
THINK WE OWE A IS YOU KNOW A LOT
OF ASSOCIATIONS A LITTLE RELIEF
HERE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON SB.
SEVEN FIVE FOUR OKAY MOTION THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR MORLOCK MOTIONS TO
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY SENATOR WIENER HI
WIENER I AM MORALE.
MORRELL AYE BATES AYE BATES AYE
CAMERO.
GIVER I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORLOCK BY [inaudible]
I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I A CASKEY.
THE VOTED SEVEN ZERO KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO OUR FINAL
BILL TODAY WHICH IS -- SB ONE
FORTY TWO BY YOURS TRULY.
ALL HAVE AND THEIR CATTLE OVER
TO SENATOR AROUND [inaudible]
ALWAYS.
WITH THE WORLD LOS
.
WELCOME SENATOR ARE YOU READY.
READY TO GO SB ONE FORTY TO HIT.
FIVE THANK YOU -- COLLEAGUES --
THIS BILL -- FOR THOSE WHO WERE
HERE LAST YEAR SHOULD BE
FAMILIAR -- THE SMELL WAS PASSED
BY THE LEGISLATURE LAST.
LAST YEAR AND UNFORTUNATELY
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR SO WE ARE
BACK.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES OP POSED AMENDMENTS
ON PAGE SIX OF ANALYSIS.
REGARDING THE BUILDING CODE --
SECTION.
SB ONE FORTY TWO IS PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD IT'S ABOUT
MAKING SURE.
THE NEW MOTHERS ARE ABLE TO
RETURN O WORK -- AND ALSO --
EXPRESS MILK SO THEY COULD
BREASTFEED.
THEIR CHILDREN TO MANY WORKING
WOMEN PARTICULARLY -- LOWER WAGE
ARE WORKING WOMEN ARE FORCED TO
CHOOSE TO I BREASTED MY CHILD
AND NOT RETURN TO WORK WHERE DO
I RETURN THE WORK AND THEN.
STOP BREAST FEEDING HAVE TO
PURCHASE EXPENSIVE FORMULA --
AND SO FORTH WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE HUGE.
HEALTH AND OTHER BENEFITS -- TO
BREAST FEEDING.
AND WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER. TO HELP --
WORKING FAMILIES AND TO HELP
WOMEN RETURNED TO WORK WHEN THEY
CHOOSE NOT FOR SAID DECISION ON
THEM OR FOR SOME TO DELAY --
RETURNING TO WORK -- THE BILL --
WILL REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS
PROVIDE A PRIVATE SPACE OFFER
LACTATION.
AS A TABLE CHAIR -- AN
ELECTRICAL OUTLET.
AND A SINGLE REFRIGERATOR --
CLOSE BY.
IT'S A VERY FLEXIBLE BILL
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT FLEXIBILITY
TO EMPLOYER EMPLOYERS -- IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY PROVIDE THE
SPACE PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR
TEMPORARY SPACES -- PARTICULARLY
FOR EXAMPLE AND SMALL RETAIL
SPACES THAT ALLOWS MULTI TENANT
BUILDINGS TO SHARE.
A SPACE.
IT PROVIDES.
A PARTICULAR -- FLEXIBILITY FOR
CERTAIN SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES LIKE
AGRICULTURE -- AND OTHERS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE TO A
PARISH FROM LEGALLY TO WORK
ROBBINS AUSTELL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION ENDEAVOR ALBERT IS A
REGISTERED NURSE AND LACTATION
CONSULTANTS.
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JULIA
PARISH I'M A SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT WORK
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS.
WE HAVE A WORKING FAMILY HEALTH
PLAN AND WE HEAR FROM THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES A YEAR WHO FACE
THESE ISSUES OF THE WORKPLACE --
SIMPLY PUT SB ONE FORTY TO
ENSURE IS THAT LACTATING PARENTS
CAN.
FEED THEIR BABIES WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO AS PARENTS AND IT
REALLY IS SIMPLE IT'S NOT ASKING
FOR TOO MUCH IT'S NOT TOO
ONEROUS TO HAVE A SPACE.
IT'S CLEAN AND SAFE FOR A WOMAN
TO EXPRESS MILK AND I BELIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS AND WE KNOW THAT
LACTATION ACCOMMODATIONS ARE A
PROBLEM OF WORK.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH SAYS THAT ONE
THIRD OF WORKING PARENTS REPORT
THAT THEY HAVE NO BREAST FEEDING
SUPPORT WORK.
AND PARENTS WITH LOWER INCOMES
HAVE REPORT -- PROBLEMS AT A
MUCH HIGHER RATE.
IN FACT MOTHERS WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE THE FASTEST GROWING
SEGMENT OF THE US WORK FORCE AND
MOST MOTHERS REPORT THAT THEY
WANT TO BRED BREAST FEED.
IN CALIFORNIA 94% OF NEW PARENTS
START OFF BREAST FEEDING IN THE
HOSPITAL BUT AT THREE MONTHS
POST PARTUM ONLY 19% CONTINUE TO
DO SO.
AND THE SIMPLE SOLUTION IS TO
PROVIDE WORKPLACE ACCOMMODATIONS --
SO.
HEY I ALSO WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT EMPLOYERS CAN EXPECT A
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT
LACTATION SUPPORT LEADS TO FEWER
SIXTIES INCREASES MORALE --
IMPROVES -- PRODUCTIVITY AND
LOYALTY SO WITH WITH -- THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ANY OTHER -- IN SUPPORT.
YES IF.
YOU GUYS.
WE WERE ALL TALKING AND COMMENTS
OF MATHEMATICS MY NAME IS DEBBIE
ALBERT AND I'M A CLINICAL NURSE
THREE LACTATION CONSULTANT UC
DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER I'M THE
MAIN LACTATION CONSULTANT THAT
SUPPORTS.
THE PROGRAM OUT THE HEALTH
CENTER ON IN SACRAMENTO AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID WAS WE
FOLLOW CALIFORNIA LAW WE FOLLOW
UC SYSTEM WHY WE ALSO FOLLOW A
UC DAVIS.
OF A LAW THAT WE CREATED SO WE
HAVE ALL OF OUR STUFF IN A ROW
AND WE HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT -- ROOMS ACROSS THE
CAMPUS AND OF THE HEALTH CENTER
AND ONE OF THE THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE IS A BUILDING CODE.
THAT REQUIRES THAT NUMBER ONE IF
WE BUILD A NEW BUILDING THAT
THERE WILL BE A LACTATION
ACCOMMODATION IN THAT BUILDING.
AND TO KNOW EMPLOYEES SHOULD
HAVE TO WALK MORE THAN FIVE
MINUTES TO GET TO A PUMPING ROOM.
AND THAT IS A MODEL POLICY BUT
IT'S A GOOD ONE AND WE FEEL THAT
IT SHOULD BE A SITUATION WHERE
WE SUPPORT AS MANY WOMEN AS
POSSIBLE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY OUR LOW
INCOME MOMS BECAUSE WE'RE
DEALING WITH LOW HEALTH IN MANY
OF THESE SITUATIONS AND THEY
NEED A WAY IN ORDER TO IMPROVE
THEIR HEALTH STANDARDS AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT I'M
ROBBIE GONZALEZ DOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BREASTFEEDING
COALITION AND OUR VISION IS THAT
ALL PARENTS CAN MEET THEIR
BREASTFEEDING GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I JUST WANNA READ -- AN EXPERT
FROM AN EXCERPT FROM A LETTER
THAT I RECEIVED FROM A MOM NAMED
CERRA I SPOKE TO HER.
ON FRIDAY AND SHE SENT ME --
ABOUT HER SITUATION SHE WANTED
ME TO SHARE THIS.
THERE ARE MANY DAYS WHEN I
WALKED OVER TO THE MOTHER'S ROOM
IT WAS OFTEN IN USE AND I WOULD
HAVE TO WAIT FOR MY TURN.
WHEN I ASKED ABOUT ADDING A
RESERVATION OPTION TO THE ROOM I
WAS TOLD RESERVATIONS DON'T
WORKING THERE WAS CONCERN WE
MIGHT ALL NEEDED AT THE SAME
TIME?
EVEN AFTER I EXPLAINED IF YOU'RE
UNABLE TO PUMP WHEN YOU NEED YOU
CAN LOSE YOUR MILK SUPPLY AND
GET INFECTIONS IT WAS STILL
TONIGHT.
I TALK TO OTHER MOMS USING THE
ROOM AND THEY WERE TOO
FRUSTRATED WITH ALWAYS HAVING TO
WAIT AND NEVER KNOWING WHEN THE
ROOM WOULD BE AVAILABLE ONE OF
THEM DOUBLES AS SHE HAD TO USE
THE LOCKER ROOM TO PUMP IN
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO AND GORGE
AND UNCOMFORTABLE AND COULDN'T.
WAIT ANY LONGER HERE WE ALL WERE
WITH THE DESIGNATED MOTHER'S
ROOM BUT IN REALITY IT WASN'T
ACCESSIBLE AND MOST OF US NEEDED
IT WE WERE ALL DEDICATED
EMPLOYEES.
WANTING TO BE AS PRODUCTIVE AS
POSSIBLE BUT OUR COMPANY WAS NOT
GIVING US THE TOOLS TO DO IT AND
ABLE TO RESERVE A SPACE WAS
MAKING IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO
JUGGLE.
A PUMP.
OR ARE PUMP TIME WITH A MEETINGS
I OFTEN HAD TO COME MY PUMP TIME
SHORT BECAUSE THE TIME THE
MOTHER'S ROOM WAS AVAILABLE.
I WOULD ONLY I WOULD HAVE LESS
THAN FIFTEEN MINUTES TO PUMP AND
GET TO MY MEETING I AM JUST ONE
WORKING MOTHER THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF WOMEN LIKE ME.
STRIVING TO BE THE BEST
PROFESSIONALS POSSIBLE WERE
STARTING A FAMILY WITH THE
CURRENT LAW AS BEING SO VAGUE
WORKING MOTHERS RIGHT TO
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION.
IN THE WORKPLACE IS DIMINISHED
AND I JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU THAT SHE WENT BACK TO WORK
ON THE BABIES ABOUT THREE MONTHS
OLD.
HER MILK SUPPLY JUST WENT AWAY
AFTER FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS
BECAUSE OF THE STRESS OF THIS
AND BEING TOLD THAT HER --
REQUESTS WERE OUT OF LINE AND
NOW SHE'S -- PRETTY UPSET ABOUT
THE SITUATION AND DOES WANT TO
MAKE IT BETTER FOR OTHER MOTHERS
AND SHE DOES DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED FOR GOOD WORKPLACE POLICY
AND FOR ACCOMMODATIONS ADEQUATE
ACCOMMODATIONS ACT.
I THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT.
THAT NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND I
AND I'M A SILLY OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
KAREN FOR EARLY CALIFORNIA WITH
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSOR THE BILL
IN SUPPORT SPECIALLY FOR THE LOW
INCOME ON THANK YOU.
VIDEO BORN REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS AND
SUPPORT.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM A CULT
OPPOSITION SORRY.
HI GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LAURA
CURTIS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
EVENING I'M WE WORK TIRELESSLY
ON THIS BILL LAST YEAR AS WELL
AS LEMONS.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX AND WE WERE
ABLE TO GET TO A POINT WITH THE
MOANS BILL THAT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ND THE
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS.
IN OPPOSITION -- ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED THAT BILL AND WE FEEL
LIKE THAT BILL HASN'T EVEN HAD A
TIME TO BE IMPLEMENTED BEFORE SB
ONE FORTY TWO IS NOW EXPANDING
ON THAT BILL AS WELL AS CHANGING --
FOR A PROVISIONS OF THAT BILL
THAT WERE NEGOTIATED I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMMITTEE
HAS RECOMMENDED SOME PROPOSALS
FOR AMENDING.
THEBUILDING CODE PROVISION
UNFORTUNATELY THE INDIVIDUAL
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION IS UNABLE
TO BE HERE THIS EVENING DUE TO
AN UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCE --
BUT I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
THAT THAT AMENDMENTS WERE NOT
GOING TO ADDRESS THOSE OVERALL
CONCERNS I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
LAST YEAR WHEN THE BILL MADE IT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK ALL OF
THE BUILDING CODE PROVISIONS
WERE ACTUALLY AMENDED OUT OF
THIS BILL.
AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD RECOMMEND IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE -- AND ADDITIONALLY
OVERALL THERE'S LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WITH THE LABOR CODE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE ADDED OR
THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN THIS BILL --
BECAUSE RETALIATION FOR
LACTATION ACCOMMODATION IS
ALREADY A PART OF THE GOVERNMENT
CODE THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OVERSEAS LIKE --
TO OVERSEAS DISCRIMINATION AND
RETALIATION BASED ON SEX --
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE THE TWO
TWO SIX WADE VIOLATIONS WHICH
ALLOW FOR ESSENTIALLY DOUBLE
PENALTIES I WHICH MEANS THAT
EMPLOYERS WOULD BE MORE INCLINED
IN THE SITUATION TO TRY AND
REGULATE THE REST BREAKS THAT
EMPLOYEES TAKE.
WITH REGARD TO LACTATION AND I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S ANYTHING
THAT ANYBODY REALLY WANTS IS THE
EMPLOYER GETTING TOO INVOLVED IN
ONE INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO LACTATE.
I'M FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
TO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR -- AGAIN WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
WITH THEM -- FOR NOW STOOD ON
THE TO THE SECOND YEAR AND WE DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE TIME THE
STAFF IS GIVEN US THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
APPRECIATE TIME.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
AMBULANCE ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
BUSINESSES SORRY MR VICE CHAIR
YOU -- HEARD THIS ALREADY
PREVIOUSLY IN THE LABOR
COMMITTEE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPONENTS OF
OF LACTATION ACCOMMODATION WE
ACTIVELY SUPPORTED PRIOR
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS A. B..
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX LAST YEAR
OUR CONCERN IS THE IMPACT ON
BUSINESS.
SENATOR WIENER DID DROP THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THERE
WAS IN THE BILL BUT BECAUSE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REFERENCED BY MISS CURTIS OF THE
LABOR CODE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THESE ARE
SUBJECT THEN TO A REPRESENTATIVE
ACTION UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACT PAGA WHICH
GIVES US GRAVE CONCERN.
THE OTHER ROVISION IS WE'D LIKE
TO SEE AN EXPANSION OF THE WELL
THE HARDSHIP EXEMPTION IS
CONTAINED IN THE LAW TODAY IT'S
VERY LIMITED.
IN THE LAST POINT I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT THIS MEASURE IS BASED
UPON A SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE
THAT IS LESS THAN A YEAR AND A
HALF OLD AND WE THINK IT'S A
LITTLE PREMATURE TO TAKE THIS
MEASURE.
STATEWIDE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE
RISE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
AREN'T WE ALL ARE ALSO OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
ON MANY OF THE REASONS OF FOR
MANY OF THE REASONS THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY STATED BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO JUST -- EXPAND A
LITTLE BIT ON THE HARDSHIP ISSUE
WHICH IS CONCERNING FOR US WE
WERE ON THE LOW MOAN BILL LAST
YEAR I NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT I
THINK IT WAS.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO WORK OUT --
A PROVISION RELATED TO HARDSHIP
THAT HELPED US TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION THE HARDSHIP
PROVISION IN THIS BILL IS
RELATED TO THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES AT A COMPANY HAS.
AND THE COUNT OF EMPLOYEES
REALLY ISN'T THE ISSUE
ESPECIALLY FOR THE MANUFACTURING.
INDUSTRY IT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
NATURE OF THE FACILITY IF THE
FACILITY IS SUCH THAT WE CAN'T
PROVIDE A SAFE PLACE FOR MOTHER
TO LACTATE OTHER THAN.
A BATHROOM PLACE OR A TEMPORARY
STRUCTURE THEN THAT CREATES A
HARDSHIP SPECIALLY FOR OUR SMALL
MANUFACTURERS SO WE WHAT LIKE
THE HARDSHIP TO BE BASED ON THE
FACILITY NOT ON THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES WE THINK THAT IS A
BETTER TARGET AND THAT IS TRULY
WHERE.
THE HARDSHIP IS GOING TO
ORIGINATE FROM. FOR THE
LIMITATIONS OF THAT FACILITY
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
CENTER [inaudible]
ROSS.
THANK YOU MISTER BLASIER.
PERHAPS THE AUTHOR COULD CLARIFY
FOR ME BECAUSE I I'VE SEE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT.
MAYBE YOU SAID THIS AND I MISSED
IT.
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
TO REMOVE SPECIFIC BUILDING
STANDARDS SPELLED OUT IN THE
BILL.
PLACING BUILDING CODES AND
STATUTES [inaudible]
AND WITH REGARD TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO WORKPLACE ORDINANCE
THAT'S THE STARTING. FOR
PURPOSES OF DISCUSSING
APPROPRIATE.
THE ASSUME IN REGULATION IS THAT
CORRECT.
THE BILL CURRENTLY ON AMENDED OR
PRETTY MOMENT -- STRIDES
BUILDING CODES AND INSTEAD WE'RE
GOING TO STICK.
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
TO GO THROUGH ITS PROCESS.
AS IT NORMALLY DOES TO ADOPT
BUILDING CODES DIRECTING THEM.
TO DO THAT -- SO WE TAKE IN THE
MORE TRADITIONAL ROUTE.
AROUND BUILDING CODES WHICH
LEGISLATURE TYPICALLY DOESN'T
CRAFT BUILDING CODES TO WE
DIRECT THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION -- TO ADDRESS AN
ISSUE AND COME UP WITH BUILDING
CODES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
DOING.
WELL I'M INCLINED -- TO MOVE THE
BILL OUT OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HARDSHIP PROVISIONS I UNDERSTAND
THE MANUFACTURES CONCERNS OF
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES SOMETIMES IS
AN APPROPRIATE THRESHOLD AND
STANDARD SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
DEPENDING ON THE NATURE OF THE
FACILITY IN THE BUSINESS
INVOLVES SO I'D.
I'D ASK YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE OF A PUBLIC ABILITY OF
PAGO WITH RESPECTED BY LOCATIONS --
I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY ANOTHER
WAY TO GET OUT IN FORCE MEANT --
RATHER THAN -- PUT ANOTHER.
NOTCH IN THE PARK PAGO BELT HERE.
BY ALLOWING PAGA ENFORCEMENT OF
THE LABOR CODE THIS IS MY
PERSONAL VIEW SO I'D ASK YOU TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AS WELL.
BUT WE WERE THERE WE DID HAVE A
SPECIFIC RIGHT RIGHT ACTION THAT
WE REMOVED FROM THE BILL AND THE
LABOR COMMITTEE -- AND THE PAGA --
REMEDY IS A PRETTY STANDARD.
REDDING CALIFORNIA LAW IT'S NOT.
SOME A NEW.
OF THE CRAFTED CAUSE OF ACTION.
AND INSTANCE TO YOU KNOW WE TRY
TO TO WORKERS IN OTHER CONTACTS
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- THE RATE.
IS ACTUALLY A RIGHT AND IF YOU
CAN ENFORCE A IT'S NOT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN VERY MUCH SO BUT
WE WILL -- SCRAPPY TO TALK ABOUT
THAT WELL AND I UNDERSTAND PARK
IN THE CONTEXT OF A WAGE CLAIM.
IN YOUR PAYSTUB AND YOUR
OVERTIME ENTITLEMENT BUT WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO TIGHTEN THE OTHER
PIECES OF THIS UP THEN IF IN
FACT IT BECOMES POCKET CLAIM
THAT YOU CAN FORCES LIKE YOU CAN
IN OVERTIME QUICK.
BECAUSE THE OVERTIME RULES OF
PRETTY CUT AND DRIED WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF EXEMPTIONS AND EVEN
THOSE TODAY ARE PRETTY.
PRETTY SET IN STONE SO WILL THEY
MAKE SURE THAT THE THIS CAN BE
COMPLIED WITH BY.
EMPLOYERS UP AND DOWN THE STATED
FOR GOING TO ALLOW.
A REPRESENTATIVE ACTIONS FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACROSS LET'S SAY --
AN INDUSTRY.
WORK ANYWHERE THANK YOU BUT I
WILL I WILL CONTINUE WE'VE --
THIS BILL -- IS -- WE HAD SHALL
WE SAY OVER THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY WE IT
SAYS TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY HER TODAY WE MADE MANY
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL LAST YEAR
WHICH CONTINUE TO BE REFLECTED
IN THE BILL THIS YEAR.
IN DIRECT RESPONSE TO FEEDBACK
FROM THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY --
THE TWO THINGS THAT WERE REMOVED --
FROM THE BILL BEFORE WAS VETOED
WHERE THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND THE BUILDING CODE --
LAST YEAR -- THE NOW THE ONLY
THING IN THE BILL.
THAT WAS NOT IN THE VETO TO
VERSION IN TERMS OF AMENDMENTS
FROM LAST YEAR.
IS THE BUILDING CODE PROVISION
ON ON QUITE A FEW OTHER MOMENTS
WAITING THAT WE NEGOTIATED LAST
YEAR WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
REMAIN IN THE BILL AND SO I I DO
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE -- THE
MEMBERS UNDERSTANDS.
WITH A WE WORKED INTENSIVELY
WITH THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND
I'VE MADE NUMEROUS AMENDMENTS.
AND RESPONSE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE YOUR
REPUTATION PRECEDES YOU IN TERMS
OF WE ARE WILLINGNESS TO WORK
FOR FOLKS.
ON ALL SIDES OF AN ISSUE
SENATORS SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY.
WE SHOULD CENTER WE WILL KEEP
POSITION FIND THANK YOU.
ANOTHER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MATH
MUCH MISTER VICE CHAIR -- I I
SHARE THE SAME THE SAME CONCERNS --
I APPRECIATE HOW HOW HARD YOU
WORK AT NEGOTIATING AND I EXPECT
THAT.
THEY WILL CONTINUE SO I JUST
WANNA MINUTES PER TODAY -- I
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO --
BUT THE HARDSHIP IN THE PARK I
ISSUE.
CAN IT'S A BACK DOOR.
POCKET ISSUE GIVEN THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE -- ELIMINATED THAT I DO
APPRECIATE THE THE CHANGES -- I
I WANNA PUT A PIN IN THE CONTACT --
ON THAT TO SEE SOMEBODY -- ON
THAT.
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION --
IN THEY ACTUALLY DON'T RIGHT.
THE THE CODES THE THE IT USUALLY
GOES TO A DEPARTMENT AND WITH
THE WITH THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION DOES IS THEY THEY
REVIEW THEM AND THEY DO THE
PUBLIC PROCESS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER IT'S UPPER DOWN.
SO I AM NOT.
WE I THINK THE WE ME NEED TO
SEND.
WE MAY NEED TO SEND IT.
TO SOME OTHER ENTITY BUT I'M I
NEED TO THINK THROUGH THAT A
LITTLE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY IDEAS
YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AS FOR IRA.
I CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE FREE TO
BY SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER.
AYE WIENER AYE AMARO.
NO NO BROWN NO BATES
[inaudible]
CABALLERO.
EVER I'D DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
HI MOORLACH.
MOORLACH NO BAIT I'M SORRY ROUGH
[inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
HI.
ROTH AYE SKINNER PRODUCT SKINNER
AYE AMBERG.
BURKE I'M CASKEY.
CASKEY I SEVEN A TO AND UP TO
GET OUT THANK YOU SENATOR
[inaudible]
HI.
ALL THE BILLS.
SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE ON
VARIOUS BILLS I'M TRYING THIS IS.
DEAR SENATOR DROPS OF RAIN.
IF CENTER.
SENATOR SAYS NOT CONDUCT.
OKAY AND WHO ELSE.
OKAY SO WHY DON'T WE LOOKED OVER
THE TOP IN THE ROLE GO START AT
THE TOP.
THIS IS A LITTLE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
THE COMMAND PREPARATIONS.
KIMBER HI MCGUIRE.
WIRE HI ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
SKINNER I EIGHT THREE COULD
VOTERS EIGHT TO THREE THAT BILLS
ADULTS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY
TWO BY SENATOR JACKSON THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED RE
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR REQUIRE.
REQUIRE I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE AMBERG.
NUMBER I THREE THE BILL IS A TO
THREE THE BILL AS ADULTS.
AND FOR ONE FREE SCRIPT ERROR
AND TWO ONE FORTY TWO A WITH IT
ALREADY.
YEAH.
OKAY SO WE THE WAY ON THE OTHER
[inaudible]
THREE I'M SORRY.
BY THE WAY WE'RE GONNA GO ALL.
WAY AROUND.
IN ORDER THOUGH TO SEE HIS HIP
SO AND SO IN ORDER [inaudible]
TO ONE FORTY TWO IT WASN'T.
AND THE ROSES ON HERE.
OKAY SO ON SB ONE FORTY TWO THE
VOTE IS SEVENTY TWO SO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
SO IN THREE REGIONS DID.
BUT I'M FOR SB.
TWO EIGHTY THIS IS ON A BILL TO
ANY BY SENATOR JACKSON THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AND RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE NUMERO YES MORRELL I COVER
ALL.
COVER I AM MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I OKAY ELEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT. THREE THIRTY AGAIN
GAP THAT WAS.
BITTER WHO TO VOTE ON MORE.
OKAY.
THREE OKAY SO -- SB. THREE
THIRTY THAT WAS ANNOUNCED
ALREADY YES OKAY SO AS AS
READERS ALREADY OUT.
SB.
FOUR THIRTY FOUR THIS IS AN IDOL
FOR THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
SENATOR MORALE.
MORRELL AYE CAMARO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
NUMBER MCGUIRE HI I'M BURKE
[inaudible]
HI.
OKAY NINE ZERO AND IT'S ALSO AND
ASK.
OKAY NINE ZERO THE BILLS OUT --
IN SEVEN SB. FIVE TWO SIR.
THIS ISN'T A BILL FOR TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR ALAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THE TO COVER.
COVERED BY A DRAWS A OKAY ARE
THE VOTERS SEVEN THREE THE
BILL'S HOUSE.
ITEM EIGHT SB.
FIVE THIRTY TWO THIS IS SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CABALLERO.
COVER AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I THE BIRD IS NINE TO TO
THE BILL'S HOUSE.
NYNEX IS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB.
SIX ELEVEN I'M SORRY SB SIX
ELEVEN IS ALREADY OUT -- SO NEXT
IS.
AN ITEM TEN IS ALREADY OUT --
NEXT HAVE A ANIMAL THAN I AM BUT
ON THAT ITEM
PHIL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER. FIVE WIENER I AM
AROUND MORRELL I NEVER I AM A
CHOIR I HAVE WATER HI I'M BIG.
DILLON ELEVEN NOTHING THE BILL
AS ADULTS.
CONCERT ARE YOU GUYS GONNA.
OKAY. ONE TWO THREE FOUR AND FOR
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN HOURS.
JUST.
WAIT FOR RUBIO.
YEAH.
NEVER WOULD I HAVE TO RE VOTER A
COUPLE THINGS. ONE TWO ONE TWO
FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN THE THIRTY
SEVENTH [inaudible]
EVERY.
EVERYTHING.
OKAY THE THROUGH ITEM TWELVE
RENDON TWELVE SB.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN THIS IS AN APPLE
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TOMORROW
[inaudible]
BROWN NOW.
THE NORTH AND THE TIME THE ONE
THAT BILLS OUT FOR HIM THIRTEEN
ISSUE.
SEVEN FIFTY FOUR THIS IS AN
APPLE 754% OF THE MORLOCKS
EMOTIONS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR OTHER.
BROWSER I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI -- CASKEY. NINE ZERO
IS BOB COMING BACK [inaudible]
REMEMBER [inaudible]
CENTERS CAN.
THIS IS THE LAST.
ONE FOR SEE IF THERE.
THERE IS A READER IDENTITY RIGHT
NOW YOUR CALL RICHARD.
OKAY SO TO ANOTHER.
THE REST WHAT TEN NOTHING THE
BILL IS OUT SO WHAT ARE THE ONES
THAT
-- DO I HAVE A MOTION TO
REMOVE TO RECONSIDER SB.
ONE FORTY TWO THE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION TO RECONSIDER.
EVERYONE MOTION TO RECONSIDER SB
ONE FORTY TWO WE'RE GONNA CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
JEFF SAID.
THIRD WIENER HI WIENER AYE AMARO
[inaudible]
BATES.
THE ONLY.
GIRL THAT INFO THIS IS JUST OF
OPTIONS YEAH YEAH -- A SENATOR
MORROW [inaudible]
HI BATES.
BATES A CAMARO.
CAMARO I'D DRAWS OF THE OTHER I
AM A CHOIR.
I AM MORE LUCK.
MORE LIKE I ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
ON BURKE.
NUMBER GUY BECAUSE HE I CAN SEE
I LOOK AT ELEVEN NOTHING THE
MOTION TO RECONSIDER PASSES AND
NOW WILL CALL THE ROLL ON SB.
ONE FORTY TWO THIS IS SENATE
BILL ONE FORTY TWO BY SENATOR
WINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED RE REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HIGH MORALE.
MORRELL NO BATES.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I'D DRAW THOUGH I ALSO
HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK MORE LIKE NO
ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE.
NUMBER FIVE CASKEY ONE MORE
CASKEY AYE.
OKAY THE VOTE IS EIGHT TO SB ONE
FORTY TWO IS OUT -- NEXT TO
DRIVE A MOTION TO RECONSIDER THE
VOTE ON SB.
FIVE TO SIX MOVE BY SENATOR ROTH
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL. FIVE
WIENER HI MARROW HI ROOM FIVE
EIGHT FIVE THESE.
THEY'RE ALSO.
THROW SO I AM GOING. TO WORK ON
MORE LAST.
MULLIN I ROUGH.
ROUGH AYE SKINNER AYE AND
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE.
HI NUMBER FIVE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I EIGHT WILL WORK I
THOUGHT THERE WAS.
TO RETREAT TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES SNOW COVER.
COVER DRUGS SO.
DRUGS -- HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I AM MORE LUCK.
MOORLACH NO ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE
AMBERG.
CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I OKAY.
OKAY -- EIGHT TO THREE SB FIVE
TO SIX IT'S OUT.
SO FOR A TURN THAT ALL.
GOOD GOOD. FOR THERE.
OKAY WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU